COMMITTEE TO ORDER AND WE WILL
BEGIN.
AS A AS SUBCOMMITTEE.
SEEN A LACK OF A QUORUM.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON.
PLEASE NOTE THE FOLLOWING.
TODAY'S AGENDA ITEM HAS EIGHTEEN
MEASURES WITH ONE MEASURE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THAT'S FILE ITEM FIVE A. B..
TEN SEVENTY FIVE ADDITIONALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD GLORIA HAS
BEEN.
APPOINTED TO REPLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAD IN A
GONZALEZ HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO
REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
LEVINE. FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
WELCOME -- MEMBERS GLORIA
GONZALEZ WHEN THEY GET HERE.
LASTLY PLEASE NOTE THAT ARE
GENERAL GUIDELINES FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT. TWO
WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT NOR
IN OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY. FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES.
WHEN I CALL FOR TWEETERS?
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED. TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH.
FILE ITEM.
SEVEN WE BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
SEVEN A. B. TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
MISTER PATTERSON IF HE'S HERE.
THIS THIS BILL -- SO AS SUPPORT
SUPPORT AND HIS WITNESSES AND
MISTER PATTERSON HAVE THE LEAD
PRETTY QUICK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
[inaudible]
SUPPORT SUPPORT
.
THE SO CLOSE I DON'T THINK WE
NEED.
AS CHAIR THANK YOU -- PRISON I'M
GOOD AT SUGGEST TO MY WITNESSES
HERE THAT WE HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE HAD -- THE
COURTESY OF THE CHAIR SO WE'RE
GONNA MAKE A QUICK PRESENTATION
WE APPRECIATE -- VERY MUCH THE
HEALTH AND WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE ON IT -- THIS
GONNA MEN'S ABOUT LAW OUTDATED
LAWS GOVERNING STANDARDIZED
TESTING IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT THE ACT MAY OFFER A
SEVENTH TEST TO STUDENTS IN JULY --
EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TAKE THE ACT
TO MAKE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
CURRENT LAW THOUGH -- THE
GOVERNING STANDARDIZED TESTING
HINDER THE ACT FROM BEING
OFFERED A SEVEN FOR SEVEN TH
TEST DATE IN JULY WHEN STUDENTS
HAVE THE BEST CHANCE.
OF SUCCESS ON THE TEST -- AND SO --
THE THE IN IN ORDER OFFER HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS A SEVENTH TEST
DATE CURRENT LAW WOULD REQUIRE A
CITY TO RELEASE A FOURTH
PRACTICE TEST TO REMAIN IN
COMPLIANCE.
THE TEST DEVELOPMENT CYCLE
REQUIRED TO PRODUCE A FOURTH
TEST.
THAT WOULD TAKE ACT AS LONG AS
TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
YET IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
THEY COULD START OFFERING THE
ADDITIONAL SUMMER TEST TO
STUDENTS NEXT YEAR FURTHERMORE.
MANY STUDENTS NO LONGER TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE IN PERSON
PRACTICE TEST BUT RATHER ACCESS
THE PREPARATION MATERIALS AND
PRACTICE TESTS.
THAT ACT ALREADY OFFERS ON LINE.
WITH ME -- TO TESTIFY HERE AT TO
THE ADVANTAGES.
THAT THIS BUILD HAS FOR STUDENTS --
IS -- WE WROTE YOUR PRINCIPAL
ANTIOCH HIGH SCHOOL AND SERGIO
GALVIS SENIOR DIRECTOR OF TRIO
PRE UNIVERSITY PROGRAMS TO
CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN.
UNIVERSITY AND THEY WILL TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE READ.
MY NAME'S LOUIS RUSSIA PRINCIPLE
VERY OUR CARS SCHOOL AND I'M IN
FAVOR OF THIS -- ASSEMBLY BILL
BECAUSE IT BENEFITS OUR STUDENTS --
ANY -- BECAUSE WE HAVE 75% FREE
REDUCED OUR STUDENTS QUALIFY.
FOR AND THIS WOULD HELP THEM AS
THEY LOOK FOR THE SUMMER TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY. FOR
THE HIGH STAKES TESTING THAT WAS
SUPPORT THEIR ADMISSIONS TO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SAID WHO ELVIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL ARE I I REPRESENT THE TROOP
UNIVERSITY PROGRAMS AT CAL THE
THREE UNIVERSITY.
WE RUN SOME RESIDENTIAL ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
THE SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES
INVENTOR COUNTY AREAS -- THIS
BILL WOULD BE BENEFICIAL IN THE
SENSE THAT IT ALLOWS ME A
CAPTIVE AUDIENCE ALLOWS ME TO
HAVE MY STUDENTS.
ON ON CAMPUS AND FRONT LOAD TEST
PREP FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THE JULY TEST.
WE WERE SURPRISED TO THIS TIME
AROUND WHEN WE FOUND OUT THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT OPTION IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO I'M REALLY GLAD AND THANKFUL
FOR THIS COMMITTEE -- FOR
ADDRESSING ADDRESS USER THANK
YOU -- ASSEMBLY AND PATTERSON
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
I I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
IN THE BILL FORD -- AS A LONG
TIME TEACHER MYSELF I WANT TO
GIVE STUDENTS -- AS MUCH
OPPORTUNITY AS THEY CAN TO TAKE
THE TEST -- AS MANY TIMES AS THE
YEARS THEY CAN IN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS HAD BEEN DISADVANTAGE --
WITH THE AC TEST.
HAVING JUST ONE LESS OPPORTUNITY --
I'M ITSELF TOOK THE SAT AND THE
A. C. T..
I I WOULD.
ASK THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH MY COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS -- AS WE MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD ESPECIALLY AS IT
REFERS TO THE ANALYSIS ON PAGES
THREE AND FOUR WATER DOWN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- THAT
WOULD BE MY CLOTHES AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
NOT YET.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL
WILL -- WAIT FOR A QUORUM AND
THEN -- TAKE THE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU.
THE RESEARCHER.
AND NOW WE'LL GO WITH SIGN IN
ORDER -- MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MR DIAL.
FILE ITEM SIX BILL A LEVIN.
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
ESTABLISHES THE CENTER TO CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
THE MISSION OF THE CENTER IS TO
ELIMINATE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS BETWEEN SUBGROUPS OF
STUDENTS AND KEEP IN QUE THROUGH
TWELVE IN GRADES K. THROUGH.
TWELVE PROVIDING PRE SERVICE
PREPARATION FOR EDUCATORS AND
THIS YOU CSU SYSTEM FOR
EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTIONAL SCHOOL
LEADERSHIP.
PRACTICES AND THE USE OF DATA.
SERVING AS A RESOURCE FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ON
STRATEGIES FOR CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS INCLUDING.
SERVING AS A CLEARING HOUSE FOR
EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES AND
PROMISING PRACTICING PRACTICES
FOR CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
ACROSS OUR STATE.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS A
SIGNIFICANT AND PERSISTENT
DISPARITY IN STUDENT PERFORMANCE
AND EDUCATIONAL CHEAP ATTAINMENT
BETWEEN STUDENTS SUBGROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALL KNOW CERTAIN GROUPS OF
STUDENTS PERFORM BETTER THAN
OTHERS AND THAT'S THE INTENT.
OF THIS CENTER TO ESTABLISH IS
BACK BEST PRACTICES AND BE ABLE
TO TO SHARE DISSEMINATE THEM.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO OTHERS MAY EMPLOY THEM.
CURRENT LAW HAS ESTABLISHED A
SYSTEM OF POLICY MAKING DATA.
COLLECTION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND PRACTICE BUT THERE IS NO
ENTITY TASK FOR SUPPORTING
UNDERGRADUATE AND PRE SERVICE
PREPARATION OF EDUCATOR PROGRAMS.
AND ALTHOUGH THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AS WIDE LEAD STUDIED NATIONALLY
AND STATEWIDE.
FEW SUPPORTS EXISTS TO COLLECT
DISTILL AND DISTRIBUTE THE
FINDINGS FROM THAT RESEARCH TO
VOLUME POLICYMAKERS TECHNICAL
SYSTEM PROVIDERS AND
PRACTITIONERS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WILL
FILL THE RESEARCH AND PRE
SERVICE VOID.
IN THE EXISTING A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM WORKING TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP BY
ESTABLISHING A CENTER THAT'S A
ONE STOP SHOP ONE PLACE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
HOW HOW'S THE DATA AND AGAIN THE
BEST PRACTICES ASSOCIATED WITH
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
MAYBE IS -- JAMES LAND IT HAS.
ON HIS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
EDUCATIONAL RESULTS PARTNERSHIP
AND FORMER DIRECTOR.
OF THE CENTER TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
MISTER CHAIR.
AT PLEASE BEGIN GREAT -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THINK OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
VERY BRIEFLY.
THIS IS A TOUGH.
JOB.
A TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP I
SERVED AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER TEN YEARS AGO
FOURTH FOR ITS LIFE FOR THE FOR
THE THREE YEARS WE LEARNED A LOT.
WE MOSTLY WE LEARNED THAT THIS
IS A PERNICIOUS.
THING.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP EVEN
DEFINING IT IS NOT FOR THE WITH
THE THE LIGHT HEARTED IN THE
WEEK -- IT'S LOADED WITH
CONTROVERSY LOADED WITH BIAS.
LOADED WITH OBSTACLES.
EN EN BARRIERS AT EVERY TURN
[inaudible]
I WOULD [inaudible]
SUGGEST.
AND RECOMMEND HIGHLY THAT THE
GOVERNANCE OF THIS ENTITY BE
THOUGHT THROUGH [inaudible]
VERY CAREFULLY.
IT CANNOT BE STATUS QUO CANNOT
BE BUSINESS AS USUAL.
OUR GOVERNOR IT'S MODEL HAD THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AT THE TABLE
WHO IS A FIFTY FIFTY VENTURE.
AND EVENTUALLY THAT'S WHAT DID
NOT WORK IN THE INSTITUTION
CHANCER RE READ WAS NOT ABLE.
TO GET THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN
A DECISION MAKING [inaudible]
ARM.
WITH DECISION MAKING INFLUENCE
WITHIN THE CENTER AND IT WE JUST
BECAME.
MORE OF A PROBLEM FOR HIM AT
THAT TIME.
WE DECIDED. TO TO NOT BE THE
PROBLEM IN THE CENTER WAS CLOSED.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS WE
LEARNED ABOUT THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP WAS THAT IT'S NOT ONLY
PREPARATION BARRIER BUT ITS
INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS EXIST.
AT EVERY SEGMENT OF THE
EDUCATION PIPELINE FROM.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EARLY READING
THE FIFTH GRADE MATH TO EIGHTH
GRADE ALGEBRA.
THE HIGH SCHOOL COURSE SEQUENCES
TO GOING INTO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GRADUATING UNIVERSITY.
ONLY ABOUT 35% OF THE COHORT OF
NINTH GRADE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THE YEAR
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND TEN IS. 65% OF THE
COHORT FROM TWO THOUSAND TEN
HAVE DISAPPEARED FROM OUR DATA
MAPS.
ONLY ABOUT 10% HAVE MADE IT
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AWARD OF THAT MAN'S GREAT COHORT
IN ONLY 8% HAVE ACHIEVED A
UNIVERSITY AWARD. 65% OF THOSE
KIDS ARE OUR WORK FORCE TODAY
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS ALIVE AND
WELL IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA IT
REALLY DESERVES YOUR SUPPORT.
I'M ON THE ON THE EFFORTS TO
CLOSE IT I WOULD JUST REALLY
THINK HARD ABOUT THE STRATEGIES
ARE USED TO DO THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU LISTEN TO MY
COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- THREE NINE I I
DO HAVE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR --
A LOT OF THE RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS USUALLY DONE.
AT AT THE UC LEVEL.
QUESTION TO YOU TO THE AUTHOR
WHY.
WHY DO YOU RECOMMEND IN THE BILL
DID THIS -- AND TO DE BE
ESTABLISHED IN THE CSU SYSTEM
QUESTION FOR TWO REASONS --
RESEARCHERS IMPORTING IS
IMPORTANT BUT IMPLEMENTING IT IS
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT.
AND THE FACT THE MATTER IS THAT
MOST OF THE CREDENTIALS THE
TEACHING CREDENTIALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COME OUT OF
THE CSU SYSTEM.
I THE OTHER SHOW HORSE AND THE
WORK FORCE OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND AGAIN MOST OF THE
TEACHER CANDIDATES COME COME OUT
OF OUT OF THE CSU SYSTEM IN FACT
JUST VERY FEW SCHOOLS.
OF THE CSU SYSTEM SO -- I I
THINK THIS ISSUE IS THE NATURAL
PLACE IS A NATURAL FIT. FOR AN
ENTITY OF THIS TYPE BECAUSE WE
WANTED THOSE.
ARE WE WANT TO TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO HAVE.
TO GAIN FROM -- THE RESEARCH
DONE AT THE UC LEVEL AGAIN THIS
ISN'T ABOUT RESEARCH IS ABOUT
COLLECTING THE RESEARCH AND
APPLYING IT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND IF YOU WOULD LEAVE IT TO THE
CSU TO DETERMINE WHERE TO PLACE
IT NO BUT I WOULD HOPE THEY
WOULD THINK -- THE I HOPE THEY
WOULD.
TARGET SUCH A CENTER AND AN AREA
THAT I PRODUCES A LOT OF TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
AND HAS THE CHALLENGES -- IT
WITHIN ITS LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THAT -- IT HAD IT WIRED THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS PRESENT LET
ME BE BLUNT SO THEY CAN EMPLOYER
OF THE VERY LOCAL LEVEL AND
MAYBE SEND SOME THEIR TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
OUT TO LEARN FROM FROM AREA
CLASSROOMS EMPLOYING THE
TECHNIQUES.
HOUSE TO WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION
ITSELF.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY
ASTRONOMICAL.
WELL I VERY MUCH.
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS GRAPPLED WITH FOR A LONG TIME.
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR IT AND ALSO ASK YOU
TO KEEP WORKING WITH COMMITTEE.
ON SOME OF THE ANNOUNCES THAT
THEY DID -- STATED IN THE
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL ON PAGE
THREE AND FOUR UNDERSTOOD.
HI.
AND WE STILL HAVE A ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM.
OKAY WILLOW WHEN ONCE WE HAVE A
CORE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND WISH LIST ROOM.
MR REVISION -- STRUCTURE.
WILL GO TO FILE ITEM NINE MISTER
CHIU.
AB.
EIGHT THIRTEEN FORTY I'M GONNA
GRAB MY WITNESSES OKAY.
IT'S A LITTLE CHAOTIC OUT THEIR
LITTLE NOISY [inaudible]
READY.
WE HAVE SOME AS WE'RE LOOKING
FOR OKAY RUN FILE ITEM NINE A.
B..
THIRTEEN FORTY GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN FORTY TODAY.
AND LET ME JUST FIRST START BY
NOTING THAT THIS IS ONE BILL IN
A PACKAGE OF SEVEN THAT ARE
RESPONDING TO RECENT ACTIONS.
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP AND EDUCATION
SECRETARY DEVICE WHO ABANDON
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS FOR
STUDENTS STUDENTS VICTIMIZED
PREPARATORY COLLEGES THAT HAVE
PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER STUDENTS.
OUR BILL AB THIRTEEN FORTY WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
FROM OVER PRICED INEFFECTIVE
CAREER TRAINING PROGRAMS BY
REINSTATING A STATE VERSION OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
FEDERAL GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT RULE.
RECENTLY SCRAPPED BY TRUMP.
THIS WAS A RULE THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED TO ADDRESS AN ALL
TOO COMMON STORY.
STUDENTS PROMISED BY RECRUITERS
THAT THEY WILL FIND A JOB IN A
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. TO TAKE OUT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
DEBT IN ORDER TO ENROLL.
ONLY TO FIND UPON GRADUATING
THAT THEY CANNOT ACTUALLY GET
THEIR PROMISE JOB.
THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED OR
UNDEREMPLOYED BUT STILL FACE
ASTRONOMICAL DEBT REPAYMENTS OR
EVEN LOAN DEFAULTS.
THESE VICTIMS ARE OFTEN LOW
INCOME AFRICAN AMERICAN VETERANS
WERE WOMEN NATIONALLY MANY OF
THEM ARE MAKING LESS THAN THE
SEVEN DOLLAR AND TWENTY FIVE
CENTS FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE.
THE FEDERAL GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE APPLIES TO OR APPLY TO
CAREER TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID.
UNDER THE RULE A PROGRAM AND I
SHOULD SAY NOT AN ENTIRE SCHOOL
BUT AN INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM.
DIDN'T PASS MUSTER IF MORE THAN
HALF OF ITS GRADUATES HAD
EXCESSIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
BURDENS WHEN WEIGHED AGAINST HER
INCOMES AFTER COLLEGE.
BASED ON INITIAL DATA FROM THE
FEDERAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
OVER -- TO FIFTY PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA DID NOT
PASS THE TEST.
THE SHODDY PROGRAMS GRADUATED.
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
HAVE LEFT SCHOOL WITH OVER NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS CLOSE TO A BILLION
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
AND A FORTUNE LAST YEAR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SECRETARY OF
US MOVE TO SCRAP THIS RULE
FUELING THE GROWTH OF PREDATORY
SCHOOLS IN ABANDONING SAFEGUARDS
THAT ARE PROTECTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
THIS BILL WOULD REINSTATE A
VERSION OF THE GAME FOR PLANET
ROLE AS EMBODIED IN FEDERAL LAW
BEFORE TRUMP BECAME PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WOULD CAP THE
ENROLLMENT OF PROGRAMS OF SOME --
AT THEIR PRIOR YEARS LEVELS AND
PROHIBITS.
WITH REGARDS TO OTHERS -- FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT FAIL ANY NEW
ENROLLMENT.
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER IN
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO PROTECT THEM
IF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT.
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA SWEETS --
ON THE DAY I GRADUATED FROM
COLLEGE.
MY FELLOW STUDENTS AND I WERE
LINED UP.
IN A CORDONED OFF AREA UNDER THE
PERFECT SANTA BARBARA STARR.
WAITING TO ENTER THE THEATER IN
COLLECTOR DIPLOMAS.
MYSELF AND SEVERAL OTHER
STUDENTS TURNED OUR HEADS TOWARD
A COMMOTION NEAR THE ROPES AND I
LOOKED OVER TO SEE MY DAD.
BEING FOLLOWED BY AN EXASPERATED
ADMINISTRATOR TELLING HIM HE HAD
TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE CEREMONY
TO SPEAK TO HIS GRADUATE.
MY MOUNTING CONCERN TURNED TO
LAUGHTER WHEN I SAW THAT.
AND I REMEMBER MY MOM IT REMAINS
AMONG A HANDFUL OF TIMES IN MY
LIFE THAT I'VE EVER SEEN MY DAD
CRY.
WELL BROOKS THEN OWNED BY CC
CAREER EDUCATION CORPORATION IS
NO LONGER IN OPERATION.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT TRADE
SCHOOL STILL OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE MY STORY
IN THE HOPES THAT I CAN READ THE
SAME THING HAPPENED TO ME FROM
HAPPENING TO THEM.
I TENDED BROOKS IN SANTA BARBARA
FROM JANUARY TWO TOUSAND THREE
TO JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX GRADUATED WITH
A BACHELOR OF ARTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHY.
ONCE A SOURCE OF PRIDE MY
EDUCATION QUICKLY BECAME A ROOM
A SOURCE OF STRESS BOTH PERSONAL
AND FINANCIAL.
WITH A COMBINED FEDERAL AND
PRIVATE STUDENT THAT NOW
TOTALING APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SINCE GRADUATION I'VE NEVER HAD
A JOB WHERE USE EDUCATION I
RECEIVED AT BROOKS.
AND I'VE NEVER HAD A JOB THAT'S
PAYING ME EVEN.
INCOME REMOTELY CLOSE TO WHAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO BE PAY
THOSE LOANS.
I CAN'T FINANCE A CAR.
MUCH LESS A HOME.
AND IT IS UNLIKELY THAT I WOULD
EVER BE ABLE TO START A FAMILY
OR GET MARRIED BECAUSE I WOULD
CONDEMN MY FAMILY TO A LIFETIME
OF POVERTY.
I CURRENTLY WORK AS A CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANT A JOB THE
INCIDENT WE DOESN'T EVEN REQUIRE
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
MY EDUCATION TO OBTAIN A NURSING
DEGREE UNFORTUNATELY BROOKS LIKE
SO MANY OTHER FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
ACTIVELY MISLED STUDENTS OUT TO
THE TRANSFERRED REALLY OF THE
CREDITS THAT THEY EARNED WHILE
IN ATTENDANCE.
IN ADDITION THEY ALSO MADE SURE
TO GUIDE STUDENT BORROWERS TO
BAR THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL.
STUDENT LOAN DOLLARS ALLOWED IN
PURSUIT OF A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
MAKING ME AN ELIGIBLE FOR
STUDENT LOANS AND FINANCIAL AID
TO PURSUE NURSING.
BROOKS USE UNETHICAL HIGH
PRESSURE SALES TAX SUCH AS PAIN
POINTS ABOUT ME BEING THE FIRST
PERSON.
IN MY IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
TO GRADUATE COLLEGE.
THEY RELIED ON THE FACT THAT
THERE WAS NO ONE IN MY LIFE TO
HELP ME ON TO THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.
WE ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS.
THEY MADE A POINT OF NEVER
ANSWERING QUESTIONS VIA EMAIL
ONLY OVER THE PHONE.
NEW CREATED THE FALSE IMPRESSION.
THAT THE ADMISSION PROCESS WAS
COMPETITIVE WHEN IN FACT ALL THE
REALLY CARED ABOUT WAS GETTING
THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN SIGNING STUDENT LOAN
DOCUMENTS.
IN REALITY BROOKS OF MANY
ADMITTED ANYONE WITH A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED AS LONG AS
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET A STUDENT
LOAN.
ALTHOUGH I HAD NO WAY OF KNOWING
THAT AT THE TIME AFTER I
GRADUATED I FOUND OUT THAT THE
ADMISSION COUNSELORS WERE JUST
COMMISSION SALES PEOPLE.
THEY WEREN'T PAID TO GIVE ME
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SCHOOL TO TELL ME HOW MUCH IT
WOULD ACTUALLY COST ME OR TO
COUNSEL ME ON WHETHER OR NOT THE
SCHOOL WOULD HELP ME REACH MY
GOALS.
THEY WERE ONLY PAID TO GET ME TO
ENROLL.
AFTER GRADUATION CAREER SERVICES
REGULARLY CONTACTED ME WITH
FINANCIALLY MEANINGLESS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNPAID JOBS TO
BE FOUND ON THE LOCAL CRAIGSLIST
PAGE.
PERHAPS WORST OF ALL HIS MISSION
COUNSELORS BLATANTLY LIED ABOUT
THE EMPLOYMENT RATES OF STUDENTS
AFTER GRADUATION AS WELL AS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE
STUDENTS WERE MAKING.
IN SHORT WELL I WORKED MULTIPLE
JOBS TO STAY IN SCHOOL BROOKS
MCC WERE HAPPILY RAKING IN
PROFITS BY DEFRAUDING THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS AND NO ONE WAS
STOPPING THEM.
NO ONE WAS ALERTING THE PUBLIC
OR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS.
NO ONE WAS THERE TO HELP ANY OF
THIS RECOUP OUR FINANCIAL LOSSES
TO SAY NOTHING OF THE DISASTROUS
EFFECT THIS LEVEL OF DEBT HAS ON
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS.
IF THIS SEEMS OUTRAGEOUS TO YOU
GOOD.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND IT'S NOT
HYPERBOLE.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF FORMER
BURKE STUDENTS WHO'VE ALREADY
FILED FOR BORROWERS DEFENSE TO
REPAYMENT AND THAT NUMBER IS
SURE TO GROW.
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SITS ON THEIR HANDS
DOING ABSOLUTELY NOTHING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL I HOPE THAT
LEGISLATORS IN THE STATE I'VE
CALLED MY HOME FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS.
WELL ONCE AGAIN LEAD THE WAY AND
TO THE RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BOB
CHAIRMAN I AM A SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION.
I SERVED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND WORKED ON
SOME OF THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
NOW -- UNDERMINING THERE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FORMER STUDENTS WHO
AND SIMILAR SITUATIONS TO TO
RECESS HAVE SIMILAR STORIES --
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
PROTECTION LEGISLATION IF THE
BULK OF THE STUDENTS IN A MAJOR
NOT A WHOLE SCHOOL BUT IN THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS YEAR AFTER
YEAR.
I HAVING TO TAKE ON MORE DEBT
THAN IS REASONABLE FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO REPAIR A AS A
GRADUATE THAT OF THAT
INSTITUTION THE INSTITUTION
EITHER NEXT TAKE NEEDS TO TAKE
ACTION TO ADDRESS THAT. FOR STOP
IN ROLLING CALIFORNIANS THAT SUB
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTION
AGAINST EXCESSIVE DEBT GIVEN
EARNINGS.
I'M GONNA ADDRESS IF I LOOK
THROUGH THE THE LETTERS FROM
SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND AND
OPPOSITION A MEDIC QUICKLY
ADDRESS THE KEY ITEMS THAT I SAW
IN THOSE LETTERS ONE IS.
THE DATA WHERE DO WE GET THE
DATA THERE IS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR
HAVING DEBT AND EARNINGS DATA
AND IN FACT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHILE THEY ARE.
REPEALING THE REGULATIONS --
HAVE INDICATED SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE DEBT AND
EARNINGS DATA SO THE THE BEST
SOLUTION WILL BE THAT THE
COLLEGES WORK WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN GET THE DATA
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE BILL PROVIDES FOR A MATCHING
DATA WITH THE STATE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT --
CONTRARY TO WHAT IS STATED IN
ONE OR TWO OF THE LETTERS THIS
IS NOT SAMPLE DATA THIS IS
ACTUAL INDIVIDUAL -- IT DATA
FROM THE STATE YOU WHY SYSTEM --
AND WOULD PROVIDE A GOOD
REPLACEMENT IF THE FEDERAL DATA
ARE ARE NOT AVAILABLE.
A SECOND -- CRITICISM -- IN THE
LETTERS WAS THAT LOANS THAT
STUDENTS TAKE OUT FOR LIVING
EXPENSES SHOULD NOT COUNT
AGAINST THE SCHOOL.
IN THE GAME FOR EMPLOYMENT ROLE
THEY DON'T COUNT AGAINST THE
SCHOOL AT ALL THE AMOUNT THAT
COUNTS IS THE IS THE TUITION AND
FEES THAT IS CHARGED BY THE
INSTITUTION NOT THE LIVING
EXPENSES SO THIS IS A
MISUNDERSTANDING.
ABOUT THE WAY THAT THE GAME FOR
EMPLOY -- THE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE WORKS.
THIRD -- THERE -- IF THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF COSMETOLOGY
SCHOOLS COLLEGE COSMETOLOGY
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS BUT IN FACT -- THE
PROPORTION OF ABOUT LESS THAN
ONE OUT OF TEN COSMETOLOGY
PROGRAMS -- FAILED THE LAST --
THE DATA THEY CAME OUT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- IN FROM
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
ABOUT THE SAME RATE AS OTHER
KINDS OF CAREER PROGRAM SO THERE
DOES NOT SEEM TO BE ANY MAJOR
PROBLEM IN COSMETOLOGY AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE WAGES
THAT ARE NOT REPORTED.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE CAUSING --
THEM -- TO FAIL THE MEASURES IT
AT LARGE RATES AT THE SAME TIME
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY DO THERE
ARE APPEALS PROCEDURES FOR THEM
TO EIGHT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE --
ALTERNATIVES -- ALTERNATIVE
EARNINGS INFORMATION -- AND
LASTLY I WANTED TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT THE THE BUREAU ARE.
STATE REGULATOR -- CAN'T HANDLE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS -- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
THE BUREAU SORT OF LIKE THE DMV
THERE'S OUT THERE A LICENSING
AGENCIES THEY THEY THEY HAND OUT
LICENSES.
AND THEN FOLKS GO AND DO THINGS
WITH THAT WAS DO THINGS AND
DRIVING THEIR CARS OR WHATEVER
SO WE HAVE IN THE IN THE DEEP IN
THE BUREAU SITUATION PEOPLE THAN
FILE COMPLAINTS AND THEY'RE
SAYING.
HEY THIS DRIVER OF THE SCHOOL
WAS DRIVING A RADICALLY IN
HURTING PEOPLE.
BUT THEY GET THOSE COMPLAINTS
AND WHAT DO THEY DO IT'S IT IS
IT IS NOT AN EASY JOB IN THE
CONTRARY SITUATION HERE IS THAT
THE GAME FULL EMPLOYMENT ROLE IS
LIKE AT LEAST LIKE HAVING A
SENSOR IN THE CAR OUR THAT BEEPS.
WHEN YOU HAVE DEBT LEVELS THAT
ARE JUST TOO HIGH GIVEN THE
EARNINGS SO IT SENDS A SIGNAL TO
THE DRIVER AND IT IS INFORMATION
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO THE AGENCY
FOR ENFORCEMENT SO FROM AN
ENFORCEMENT STANDPOINT?
IT IS A LOT EASIER FOR THE
BUREAU TO IN FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THEN THE TASK THAT THE
BUREAU HAS HAD AN ADMITTEDLY HAS
FUMBLED IN A LOT OF WAYS BUT
THIS IS A MUCH EASIER TASK
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES.
CLEAR MEASURES THAT GET REPORTED
TO SCHOOLS THAT THEY HAVE TIME
TO ADDRESS -- BEFORE THERE'S ANY
RAMIFICATIONS ON THEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND BOB HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OBLIGATED DONNIE DONNIE
AND ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING TWO
CLIENTS CENTURY FOUNDATION AS
WELL AS THE AMITY FOUNDATION
AMITY FOUNDATION -- PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE RECENTLY --
RELEASED FROM PRISON BAKERSFIELD
ALTHOUGH ALL THE WAY TO SACK --
SAN DIEGO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
NOT ONLY THIS BILL BUT THE BILL
PACKAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ACTING
FROM SAN DIEGO I AM A FORMER I
AM A NAVY VETERAN AND A FORMER
ASHFORD EMPLOYEE AND I SAW
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THE PACKAGE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RAYMOND CURTIS IN THE STATE
POLICY MANAGER FOR VETERANS
EDUCATION SUCCESS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL AS
THE ENTIRE PACKAGE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AT HOWARD WITH THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LAW ALSO STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
IN THE PACKAGE THANK YOU. ONE
THREE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS ANGELA PERRY I'M A
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS I ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL.
SUZANNE MARTIN DOES YOUR POLICY
COUNCIL FOR CONFERRED CONSUMER
REPORTS FROM THE CONSUMERS UNION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE SEE FOR I
AM A U. S. ARMY VETERAN AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BOB
MUTE I'M A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
A PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
SAN DIEGO AND AS MANAGING
ATTORNEY OF THE VETERANS LEGAL
CLINIC I SUPPORT THE BILL.
J. BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR CALLED OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LARA MATTOON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR ELOY OAKLEY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF ALLY
UNIVERSITY WE'VE HAD VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS
REPRESENTATIVES AND I BELIEVE
WE'VE.
COME TO A MEETING AS REGARDS TO
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
AND ENTITIES THAT.
THE STATE IMPOSES POST GRADUATE
INTERNSHIP REQUIREMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND GETTING THAT DONE THANK YOU.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MR MILLER.
YES RIGHT NOW WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMANDA BUT I BELIEVE
WE'RE GETTING OUR MA'AM AND SO
[inaudible]
SAY NEUTRAL.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND IF WE COULD MAKE ROOM FOR
THEM TO COME UP TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SINCE.
THIS CHAIR REMEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF UNIVERSITY OF
PHOENIX FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THE
AUTHOR TO MEET.
ALSO FOR EVEY TO MEET TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR DATA SETS A
LITTLE BETTER I THOUGHT IT WAS --
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND THOSE.
THAT SAID -- UNIVERSITY REMAINS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
WELL CERTAINLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ROLLED BACK IN FULL
EMPLOYMENT.
PHOENIX IS NOT CONVINCED THAT IS
THE ONLY WAY TO JUDGE
INSTITUTIONS WE'VE MADE A NUMBER
OF RECOMMENDATIONS OVER THE
YEARS.
SUCH AS DISQUALIFYING STUDENTS
THAT OUR INSTITUTIONS THE
BUYBACK BAGHDAD'S USING HIGH IN
CASH MANAGEMENT.
IN BOTH THOSE CASES THEY WERE
IGNORED HAD THEY BEEN ADOPTED IN
BOTH THOSE CASES ACTUALLY
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED -- I'VE WORKED WITH
THE BPP ITS SUCCESSOR AND ITS
SUCCESSOR FOR THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS -- WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
NEW LEADERSHIP.
THERE IS NO PRACTICAL WAY THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO DO WHAT IS
STATED IN THE BILL THIS IS WHAT
THE ANALYSIS FOR SIXTEEN ELEVEN
SAID LAST YEAR.
WE BELIEVE IT'S STILL TO BE THE
CASE MY INSTITUTION IS GETTING
COMPLAINTS FROM STUDENTS THAT
ARE A YEAR OLD. TO THE EXTENT
YOU IMPOSE THESE NEW OBLIGATIONS
ON THE BUREAU IT'S SIMPLY GOING
TO BE WORSE AND IT'S NOT A FEE
FUNCTION ARE FEES ROSE TWO YEARS
AGO.
FROM FIFTY THOUSAND TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER YEAR WE ARE
PAYING OUR FAIR SHARE IT IS
SIMPLY LACKING A CLEAR MISSION.
WHICH THE HISTORICAL ISSUE IN MY
OPINION WITH THE BUREAU.
SO RATHER THAN TRYING TO
RECREATE THE FEDERAL SYSTEM
LET'S LOOK AWAY AS THE STATE CAN
DO THIS AND A SIMPLER FASHION TO
ADDRESS BAD ACTORS WHICH WE HAVE
A SHARED INTEREST ELIMINATE.
THESE REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RICK WOULD
AND THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
INSTITUTE OF TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA
FOR APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
YEARS -- WE EMPLOY TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY PEOPLE.
AND RETRAIN APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS -- EACH
CALENDAR YEAR I'M HERE TO OPPOSE
A. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY ON BEHALF OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES STUDENTS AND
MEMBERS SCHOOLS OF OUR STATE
ASSOCIATION CAPS.
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE MERITS
OF THE REGULATION.
IN PARTICULAR TODAY DURING THE
TIME THAT WE HAVE HAVE EXCUSE ME.
THIS BILL IS INHERENTLY FLAWED
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL MODEL IT'S
BASED ON WAS FLAWED IN ITS AND
SEVENTY THE FEDERAL MODEL IS
FLAWED BECAUSE IT DENIES THE
STUDENT THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE A
COURSE OF STUDY.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MEET AN
ARBITRARY METRIC IMPOSED ON THAT
PROGRAM.
THE FEDERAL MODEL IS ALSO FLAWED
BECAUSE IT ASSUMED WRONGLY THAT
WAGE DATA WAS STATIC.
ACROSS STATES COUNTIES AND IN
CITIES AND IT IS NOT. FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE LIVING IN FRESNO
COUNTY WHERE I LIVE IS GOING TO
MAKE MUCH LESS MONEY AS A
MEDICAL ASSISTANT AND THEY WILL
MAKE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND YET THE SAME METRIC IS
APPLIED EQUALLY IN EACH OF THOSE
REGIONS.
BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA MODEL IS
BASED ON THIS FEDERAL MODEL IT
TOO WOULD BE FLAWED ANDERSON
SEVENTY BECAUSE IT WOULD NOT
RECOGNIZE REGIONAL WAGE
DIFFERENCES.
LIKE THE FEDERAL MODEL THE STATE
MODEL ALSO DOES NOT ADDRESS
UNDER REPORTED WAGES FOR
VOCATIONS LIKE COSMETOLOGY.
THOSE IN FAVOR THE BILL
MENTIONED THAT NOT TOO MANY
SCHOOLS WERE SUBJECT -- TO
PENALTIES BECAUSE A GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT THAT OFFERED
COSMETOLOGY HOWEVER THE COURTS
FELT DIFFERENTLY AND MADE
CHANGES TO THE RULE TO EXEMPT
THEM FROM.
LIKE FEDERAL MODEL THERE IS NO
DIRECT CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
WAGES THAT ARE EARNED BY THEY
GRADUATED STUDENT AND REPORTED
AND THE PROGRAM OF STUDY.
TAKEN AND IN NO WAY AND THERE IS
NO WAY TO CONNECT THOSE TWO
THINGS.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'VE
OBSERVED AMONGST OUR STUDENTS IS
THAT OFTEN THEY WORK IN A JOB
THAT WAS RELATED TO THEIR
TRAINING AT ALL.
AND THOSE ARE THE WAGES THAT
WERE USED TO MAKE THE ASSESSMENT
OF THE PROGRAM OF STUDY.
AND THERE IS CURRENTLY NO REAL
WAY TO CONNECT THE TYPE OF WAYS
THEY AREN'T AS TO WHETHER IT'S
RELATED TO THE TRAINING OR NOT.
AND THE ACTUAL TRAINING THAT
TOOK PLACE.
AS WELL IDENTIFIED.
BY THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S --
HERE IN THE CAPITAL THIS BILL
CONTAINS PENALTIES THAT ARE
QUOTES SAID STANTON BILLY MORE
STRINGENT THAN THOSE IN THE
FEDERAL MODEL.
THERE IS NO APPEAL PROCESS AND
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL.
AND SCHOOLS THAT ARE FOUND OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WOULD HAVE NO
RECOURSE TO CORRECT --
NONCOMPLIANCE.
AND FINALLY ALONG SIDE. NINETY
TEN OR OTHER RECENTLY PROPOSED
STATE -- EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN
BILLS AN INSTITUTION'S ABILITY
TO COMPLY SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH
BOTH OF THOSE METRICS WOULD BE.
IN REALITY OUT OF REACH FOR
THOSE INSTITUTIONS I'LL BE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
AND BEFORE I CALL ON OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I'M
GONNA ASK.
THAT WE ESTABLISH A A QUORUM.
p[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
HELLO AND SALAS GONZALEZ LEFT
CONSERVE WOULDN'T REMEMBER.
OKAY WERE SOLUTION ONE PERSON
SHORT OF A QUORUM -- OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MAP BACK
REPRESENTING CAPS I JUST HAVE TO
POINT OUT.
DATA DOES MATTER FACTS MATTER TO
SOME OF OUR GRADUATES COULD GO
OUT OF STATE ET DE WILL NOT
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION.
BOB CD IS RECEIVING INFORMATION
FROM CALIFORNIANS LAWYERS SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT OUR GRADUATES
END UP OUT OF STATE.
OUR SCHOOLS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
COUNT THAT DATA TOWARDS THE
FORMULA THERE ARE PROFESSIONS
LIKE COSMETOLOGY FILM OTHERS IN
THE ARTS THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY TRADITIONAL W. TWO
EMPLOYEES.
THAT DATA WILL NOT BE ACCURATE
THEREFOREOUR PROGRAMS WERE FAIL
SO AGAIN THE DETAILS MATTER AND
THE FEDERAL LAW WAS CHALLENGED
IN COURT AND THOSE WHO
CHALLENGED IT PREVAIL.
THE COSMETOLOGY SCHOOLS AND THE
DATA WAS FLORA BLACK IT IJET BUT
JUST BE IN YOUR NAME AND THEY
WERE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS AND PLEASE
JUST YOUR NAME IN THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE WITH.
MITCHELL FIRST FROM NORTHWEST
COLLEGE FROM THE LOS ANGELES
AREA AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU VOTE NO ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
BAYLOR MEZA GLENDA KERR COLLEGE
FROM GLENDALE CALIFORNIA VOTE NO
ON AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY SHERRI HEARD
EMPIRE COLLEGE SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO.
EMPIRE COLLEGE EMPIRE COLLEGE
SCHOOL OF LAW SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECT LEE ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO.
PULLING BOPPING CAN STAY IN AYE
COLLEGE SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION A LOT.
NUMBER ONE OKAY WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AGAIN.
MEDINA PRESENT CHOI [inaudible]
AREA.
ROOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KILEY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU COME TO THE MICROPHONE AND
GIVE YOUR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION.
THAT YOU'RE WITH.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOUR NAME IN THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH I'M PATRICIA HANSON
I'M WITH A STANFORD UNIVERSITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION -- AND AND AND
THAT'S ALL WE WANT RIGHT NOW
JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH.
AND THAT YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THE NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO A MONTH AGO TO BEAR AND
WITH KERN ACADEMY.
ACADEMY OF MEDICAL ARTS I'M WITH
THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE BILL WILL BE SAN I COLLEGE.
THANK YOU.
SOFIA BUT TO SAYS THE AYE
COLLEGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION BECOME
THE MIKE GIVE YOUR NAME AND WHO
LIVE IN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN
CARRINGTON COLLEGE IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS BRUCE PRO SURFING UP
I COLLEGE MEDICAL BILLING AND
CODING INSTRUCTOR AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I GOT MY
CERTIFICATE.
AND ONE OF THE SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
FREDJONES ON BEHALF THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA THE FUTURE EMPLOYERS
OF THESE GRADUATES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
IF YOU COME TO THE MIKE GIVE
YOUR NAME IN THE GROUP YOU'RE
WITH.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICHARD CARLIN
AND CURRENTLY STUDENT AND COAST
COLLEGE OVER IN FAIRFIELD.
I DON'T SUPPORT THIS BILL AT ALL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GET A BROWN INTO
BECAUSE COLLEGES IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA MY AS THE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU.
ROCKY CHAVEZ CYNICAL COLLEGE I
RESPECTFULLY BUILT NOW.
HELLO Là NOW LYNCH UNDER BELLUS
ACADEMY AND RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THOMAS NAY INNER COAST COLLEGE I
RESPECTFULLY VOTE NOW.
VETERANS THE HUBBARD COLLEGE IN
LOS ANGELES.
I RICHARD MILLER FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR WHICH HER OPPOSITION PLACE --
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY AND I'M
JIM YOUR CAMPUS PRESIDENT OF YOU
WE AYE COLLEGE IN SACRAMENTO AND
AYE OPPOSED TO BILL.
SEAN TELL HER DAUGHTER YOU WE
ARE COLLEGE MEDICAL ASSISTING
AND I ALSO DECLINE THIS.
ANTHONY RAMOS SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COLLEGE OPPOSITION.
FIND AT THE TERRY YOU YEAH I
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT HENDRICKSON FROM CARRYING
COLLEGES I RECOMMEND YOU GO
AGAINST THE BILL.
SABRINA LARA FROM YOU I COLLEGE
I RESPECTFULLY WELL NOW.
SELL UNITS WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY I
COME IN TO EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
WHICH IS IN OPPOSITION TO BE
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE AND GET
THE NAME OF THE GROUP YOU'RE
WITH [inaudible]
IF.
YEAH COME TO THE MIKE AND GIVE
THE NAME OF THE GROUP YOUR WITH.
HI MY NAME IS RIGHT ALLOWED I'M
FROM HIGH DOES OUR MEDICAL
COLLEGE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MADISON HALL I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEE AND ROMAN I'M
WITH HOW DOES OUR MEDICAL
COLLEGE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IN A WHOLE I'M WITH
UNITECH COLLEGE OUT OF FREMONT
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
POSITION.
MY NAME IS THE COMMAND AS I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I POSITION.
I'M CHRISTIAN OF YOUR SORRY FROM
THE SAN DIEGO UNIVERSITY THE
GRADED STUDIES AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL.
RAYMOND DRIVERS FROM SAN DIEGO
UNIVERSITY FOR INTEGRATIVE
STUDIES ALSO OPPOSED.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DEBBIE MARIE AND I'M FROM
UNITECH COLLEGE SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE WITH AB THIRTEEN FORTY
THANK YOU.
JANICE PAULSON UNITECH COLLEGE
FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSING.
THIRTEEN FORTY HI STEVE WATKINS
UNITECH COLLEGE IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA I AM OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN FORTY THANK YOU.
IF YOU. ONE OF GIVE YOUR NAME IN
THE GROUP YOU'RE WITH -- MICHAEL
RUESS UNITECH COLLEGE AYE
OPPOSED BILL.
SUE SMITH UNITECH COLLEGE
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS NATALIE EVANS I'M A
STUDENT AT YOU WE AYE COLLEGE
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ROSALIE A CALDERON
I'M A STUDENT AT UP I COLLEGE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE NAM HONORING I'M
FOR SACRAMENTO ALL JUST AN
INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE BE THE MARK HAS
AND I AM FROM SACRAMENTO
ULTRASOUND INSTITUTE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ACTUALLY GóMEZ AND
I'M ALSO FROM SACRAMENTO OR
DISCERN INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JAN ACROSS THE I
LIVE IN LIKE IN CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO FROM SACRAMENTO OLDER SON
IS TWO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VANESSA VAN TO
HIGH AND I GO TO SACRAMENTO
STATE I MEAN A SACRAMENTO
WATERTOWN INSTITUTE.
AND I ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL AND I
LIVE IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KARENA MAGICAL
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO ULTRASOUND
INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA
CERVANTES I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
OSHITA INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL AND I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
NICHOLAS JOHNSON FROM SACRAMENTO
SUN INSTITUTE AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WE SHOULD THOMPSON FROM
SACRAMENTO TO SENATE'S TO I'M A
STUDENT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S MICHELLE I'M A STUDENT
AT SACRAMENTO ALSO INSTITUTE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHN PAUL CANADIAN VETERAN AN
INSTRUCTOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PRECIOUS CHOICE I'M A STUDENT AT
SEGMENT OLDER SON INSTITUTE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BLOOM SURGEON MANDATORY I'M A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO WHICH
SOUNDED STILL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASHLEY BURGER
I'M A STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
OLDER SON INSTITUTE I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE SPELL.
MY NAME IS KELSEY I GO TO
SACRAMENTO OLDER SON INSTITUTE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL -- MY
NAME IS DEREK -- GO TO
SACRAMENTO SIGNS TO IN I ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HAYDEN I GO TO
SACRAMENTO ULTRASOUND INTO TWO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KILL I GO TO
SACRAMENTO ULTRASOUND SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICK I GRADUATED FROM --
AS TO WHY SACRAMENTO SONS TO AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S STEFFAN I GRADUATED
FROM MRO.
SACRAMENTO JUST ON INSTITUTE I
PULLED HIS BILL.
SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES WHO
WORKED WIENER [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
I IF MOVE BY MR LOW SECOND BY MS
LOAD AND GONZALEZ FLETCHER -- I
DO HAVE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
FIRST OF TO THE AUTHOR YOU DO
AGREE TO THE MEASUREMENTS ON
PAID ABSOLUTE I WAS ACTUALLY
ABOUT TO SAY JUST THAT.
THANK YOU AND THEN -- QUESTION
ANOTHER QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
IT IN WHAT IN WHAT WAYS.
ARE. FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
BENEFITING BY NOT BEING.
BY THE X. BY AND NOT HAVING A
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT -- BEING PART
OF THE LAW.
BY NOT HAVING BREAK EPISODE LE
LET ME SAY A FEW THINGS FIRST OF
ALL VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THIS COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
DEMONIZING ALL FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS IN FACT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
ARE PASSING THIS TEST. 80% OF
THE MORE BUT 20% OF THEM ARE NOT
20% OF OUR FAMILY OUR STUDENTS.
AND BY MARKETING THE POTENTIAL
FUTURES FOR THE STUDENTS.
AND ALLOWING THEM TO ANCHOR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF DEBT.
THAT THEN LEAD TO THEM NOT BEING
ABLE TO SUCCEED IN THE WORKPLACE
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
TARGET HERE -- AND SO.
REALLY WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT
THE FEDERAL STANDARD THAT HAS
BEEN IN PLACE BEFORE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ELECTED AND BEFORE HE
AND HIS EDUCATION SECRETARY
DECIDED TO DISBAND THIS ROLE.
WE JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT
THE FEDERAL STANDARD WAS WHICH
SHOWED THAT UNDER THAT RULE
THERE WERE OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SCHOOLS.
OVER FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
LIKE TO RESA WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THIS PROGRAM WE'RE
SIMPLY TRYING. TO ESTABLISH A
STANDARD.
SO.
I THINK NOT HAVING THIS ROLE
WILL MEAN THAT THOSE 20% OF
SCHOOLS THOSE FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND FUTURE STUDENTS.
WILL NOT HAVE AN ABILITY TO KNOW
AS MISTER SHERMAN SAID IF THERE
SCHOOL -- IS NOT GONNA PROVIDE
THEM THE EDUCATION THAT THEY ARE
BEING TOLD.
BY RECRUITERS AND MARKETING
MATERIALS THAT THEY'RE GONNA GET.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I HAVE A QUESTION.
CHAIR.
ST STE CHOI [inaudible]
YOUR CHAIR.
I CANNOT UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
OF YOUR BILL -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDENTS WOULD HAVE A
YOU KNOW FULL OWNING POWER WHEN
THEY GRADUATE THE FROM.
BUT I THINK IT HAS -- BEEN OUT
OF CONCERN NOT TO MEDIA -- NOT
FEATHER STANDARD I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT UP BUT THE THE SEAT OF POWER
EACH PROGRAM EACH OCCUPATIONAL
CATEGORY HAS A WALKABLE OWNING.
SALARY POWER WOULD THAT BE AND
THE ONLY THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
OFFERED -- BY THE PROFIT
[inaudible]
COLLEGES.
ARE SO THAT MEANS TO YOUR BILL
WOULD NOT ALLOW THEM
[inaudible] TO FOR GRAHAM SAID
THAT.
OR NOT THE MEET THEIR EARNING
POWER.
SO STARTUP EARNING POWER ANY
POTENTIAL IT'S ACTUALLY WHAT
THEY ARE LEARNING AS FAR AS
INCOME WHICH IS DATA THAT WE CAN
TRACK.
SO OUR EMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT CAN
TRACK THAT DATA THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TRACK THAT DATED THIS
DATA IS ITS DATA IT'S FONG
SALARY CORRECT IT'S NOT BASED ON
A FUTURE SENSE OF WHAT YOU MIGHT
MAKE.
IT'S BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY EARNING ONCE YOU'VE
GRADUATED FROM THE SCHOOL AND I
SHOULD SAY THIS IS DATA THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
COLLECTING.
I AND DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS ROLLING
BACK THE RULE AT THIS TIME THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT OUT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
REQUIRING HIS US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ALLOW FOR PROGRAM
LEVEL DATA AROUND STUDENT
EARNINGS AND STUDENT DEBT TO
CONTINUES OUR HOPE IS THE
FEDERAL DATE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE AND CONTINUE TO BE THE
STANDARD.
BUT THIS BILL ALSO HAS AS A BACK
UP -- AND ABILITY FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO COLLECT THIS DATA
THROUGH STATE AGENCIES SO THAT
WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE ROLE
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT AGAIN IT'S NOT ABOUT FUTURE
EARNINGS ARE ANY PROJECTION OF
WHAT SOMEONE MIGHT MAKE IT'S
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
EARNING WHAT THE ACTUAL INCOME
AS THOSE.
CERTAIN OCCUPATION OR PROGRAMS
SO IF THE CURRENT LAW SALARY IS --
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO ON
GOING CURRENT LAW.
IN BEGINNING SALARY THAN -- WHAT --
TUITION AMOUNT TO WOULD BE
ALLOWED THESE THAT THE TUITION
CONTROLLER OR NOT TO ALLOW THE
PROGRAM ITSELF SO THERE'S AS
VERY SPECIFIC STANDARD THAT'S
THAT ESSENTIALLY SAYS YOU FAIL
OR YOU'RE PASSING THE TEST IF.
YOU'RE ANNUAL LOAN REPAYMENT FOR
A GRADUATE IS BELOW 20% OF YOUR
DISCRETIONARY INCOME OR 8% OF
YOUR TOTAL EARNINGS SO THAT'S
THE STANDARD.
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED.
IN LAW AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS
WHEN IT WAS ESTABLISHED IN LAWS
SOME YEARS BACK THERE ARE MANY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WHO
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS ACTUALLY
TOO LOW A STANDARD THAT THAT --
IT SHOULD BE REYES BUT THAT WAS
A STANDARD THAT WAS AGREED UPON
AND EVEN UNDER THAT LOW STANDARD
WE STILL HAVE.
AGAIN -- 250- PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
RECENTLY FAILED THAT TEST THIS
INTENDED CONTROL THOUGH TWEE
SHOWN AMOUNT THAT BEING CHARGED.
NO THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT THIS
BILL TO CONTROLS A TUITION OUT
AGAIN THE POINT OF THIS IS IF
YOU ARE A STUDENT.
AND YOU'LL TOLD YOU GO TO THIS
PARTICULAR KERR TRAINING PROGRAM.
YOUR SALARY WHEN YOU GRADUATE IS
GOING TO BE MUCH HIGHER THAN
WHATEVER YOU'RE MAKING NOW.
AND SO YOU IN KERR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF DEBT.
AND WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SAID UNTIL THIS RULE WAS WAS WAS
WAS IN THE PROCESS BEEN ROLLED
BACK IS.
THOSE STUDENTS HAVE NOT SEEN
THEIR INCOMES RISE IN FACT MANY
OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE BARELY
EARNING THE FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE.
AND SO IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IF
YOU'VE IN COURT AN AWFUL LOT OF
DEBT.
AND YOU'RE NOT SENIOR INCOME
RISE.
THAT DEGREE PROGRAM IS NOT
HELPING YOU AND WE'RE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY AGAIN THOSE PROGRAMS.
WHICH IN CALIFORNIA RECENT WAS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PROGRAMS ABOUT
25% OF THE OF 20% OF THE
PROGRAMS -- IN THE FOR PROFIT.
WORLD THOSE ARE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE FAILING OUR STUDENTS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO IDENTIFY.
WHY ARE YOU LIMITING WANTED TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS?
THERE IS ALREADY DATA THAT GETS
COLLECTED FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
AND WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO MATCH
THAT FOR THE PROPER FOR PROFIT
SECTOR SO  HAVE NO PROBLEM
APPLYING THIS TO ALL SCHOOLS.
IN FACT -- IF OTHERS WANT TO
COMMENT ON THIS I THINK THIS IS
A STANDARD THAT SHOULD APPLY TO
ALL SCHOOLS BUT WE ALSO WANTED
TO APPLY TO A SECTOR THAT HAS
NOT SEEN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY -- FOLLOW YOUR
REGULATIONS THAT SO -- SO YES --
THE UC SYSTEM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- CSU SYSTEM THEY ARE
AT THAT EDT ACTUALLY COORDINATES
WITH THOSE EDUCATION SECTORS TO
GET SIMILAR DATA.
SO THAT THIS ONE HAS ALSO BRINGS
UP A LOT OF POTENTIAL. FOR
PROFIT LOSS OF LOS WITH SO FOR
THOSE OF GRADUATE SO WHEN THEY
THIS IN ALL DON'T FIND A JOB
WITHOUT WANTED OUT.
BE ABLE TO LAW.
PAY THEIR DEBTS I WOULD SAY AS A
LAWYER IF THERE ARE CERTAIN LAW
SCHOOLS THAT ARE CAUSING
STUDENTS JUNK FOR SIX FIGURES OF
DEBTS.
AND THOSE LAWYERS ARE UNABLE TO
BE EMPLOYED AND THERE'S A VERY
REGULAR AND CONSISTENT RECORD OF
THAT I THINK WE DO HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE
STUDENTS.
I HAVE SOME -- JUST FACE IT
DOUBLE PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS DO
TRACK THESE THESE KIND OF DATA
MATCHING THEIR GRADUATES
INFORMATION WITH THE STATE ET DE
BECAUSE THEY ARE PUBLICLY.
GOVERNED AND DON'T HAVE THE SAME
INCENTIVES AS FOR PROFITS WE
TEND TO NOT HAVE THE SAME KINDS
OF PROBLEMS THERE -- AND SO
THERE ARE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS THAT APPLY
ON THE PRIVATE FOR PROFIT SIDE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE SEE THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE AS A RESULT OF
THEIR CONTROL BEING IN THE HANDS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE.
WHO ARE ABLE TO POCKET ANY MONEY
THAT'S NOT SPENT ON THE
EDUCATION SO -- THIS APPROACH
HELPS TO ENCOURAGE THE SCHOOLS
TO SPEND ON THE EDUCATION SO
THAT STUDENTS WILL HAVE THE
EARNING POWER COMING OUT TO
ACTUALLY REPAY.
THE LOAN -- OR ADJUST THEIR
PRICING IF IN FACT THAT'S WHAT'S
DRIVING THE HIGH AMOUNTS OF DEBT
IF IT'S NOT A REASONABLE AMOUNT.
BUT IT'S UP TO THE TEN IT'S UP
TO THE SCHOOLS HOW THEY WANT TO
RESPOND.
WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION --
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS BUT THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE'RE PUTTING
OUR STUDENTS FIRST AND NOT THE
SHAREHOLDERS OF CERTAIN FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS AND WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
I I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR
TOOK ON PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
WILL BE PROCESS IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS -- COMMITTEE.
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT IS AN
IMPORTANT WAY TO MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS EFFECTIVENESS OF
CAREER PREPARATION PROGRAMS I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
AND KNOW THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE.
TO WORK ON CRAFTING AN
APPROPRIATE DATA A PALETTE
PROCESS MOVING FORWARD.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY.
MISTER LOWE AND SECOND BY THIS
GONZALES FLETCHER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
BUSIESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA HI MEDINA I
CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN I?
GONZALEZ I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
FIVE ZERO WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
NEXT ST -- SIGN IN ORDER
[inaudible]
MR BERMAN -- FILE ITEM.
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM. ONE FIVE TWO ONE I'M NOT
SURE WHICH FALLS.
ITEM THAT IS.
IS FILE ITEM ONE PERFECT.
ONCE A MONTH.
FILE ITEM ONE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
BRIEF BREAK FROM PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES.
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE WOULD TASK
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER
WITH RESEARCHING DEVELOPING
IMPLEMENTING AND EVALUATING
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR HEALTH PROVIDERS.
ARE PREVENTING FIREARM RELATED
HARLEM.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH RATES OF
FIREARM RELATED DEATH AND INJURY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION REPORTED THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
FIREARM.
RELATED DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING SIXTEEN HUNDRED TEN
SUICIDES AND FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE HOMICIDES.
FURTHERMORE MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
CHANGING THE CHARACTER OF PUBLIC
LIFE IN THE STATE.
JUST LAST NOVEMBER A MASS
SHOOTING AT BORDERLINE BAR AND
GRILL IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA RESULT IN TWELVE
DEATH.
GUN VIOLENCE NOT ONLY A SERIOUS
IMPLICATIONS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH BUT IS
EXTREMELY COSTLY AS WELL.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN THE
ESTIMATED COST OF HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT CARE FOR
FARM RELATED INJURIES IN
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS WITH MEDI
CAL AND OTHER GOVERNMENT PAYERS
RESPONSIBLE 464% OF THOSE COSTS.
WELL WE WHILE WE RELY ON HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS TO SAVE LIVES
AFTER GOING VIOLENCE WE SHOULD
ALSO KNOWLEDGE THEIR UNIQUE
ABILITY TO HELP PREVENT THESE
TRAGEDIES IN THE FIRST PLACE.
TRANSAMERICAN SKIPS INSERTED A
MOTION AND SECOND.
LAST YEAR THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF PHYSICIANS PUBLISHED A
POSITION PAPER ON REDUCING FARM
INJURIES AND DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE RECOMMENDS A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH TO FIREARMS RELATED
VIOLENCE IN THE PREVENTION OF
FIREARM INJURIES AND DEATHS AND
ENCOURAGES PHYSICIANS TO DISCUSS
WITH THEIR PATIENTS.
THE RISKS THAT MAY BE ASSOCIATED
WITH HAVING A FARM IN THE HOME
AND RECOMMEND WAYS TO MITIGATE
SUCH RISKS.
WHILE MANY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
RECOGNIZE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
HELP PREVENT FARM RELATED INJURY
AND DEATH MANY CITE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE REGARDING WHEN AND HOW
TO COUNSEL PATIENTS AS A
PRINCIPAL BARRIER TO ACTION.
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE RECOGNIZES
THAT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
PREVENT FARM RELATED HARM AND AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER
IS UNIQUELY QUALIFIED. TO EQUIP
THEM WITH THE EDUCATION TRAINING
AND RESOURCES NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
PATIENTS AT RISK FOR SUCH HARM
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED
COUNSELING TO MITIGATE RISK AND
INTERVENE IN SITUATIONS OF
IMMINENT DANGER.
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
TAKE THIS TRAINING WITH ME TODAY
ARE DOCTOR GARREN WITH A MOOT.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THE COMMUNITY
INTO HAVING.
OF MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY ALL
BE A BRIEF AS WELL -- I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
ESTABLISHED -- FIRST IN THE
NATION PUBLICLY FUNDED FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER I'M
ALSO A PRACTICING EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN AT UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER DOWN THE STREET.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN HAS.
I THINK VERY AMPLY QUANTIFIED.
WE FACE A CRISIS OF FIREARM
RELATED DEATHS AND INJURY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE DO AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS A NEW MOBILIZATION TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
IN PARTICULAR A REAL SURGE OF
INTEREST AMONG AMONG A HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS PHYSICIANS NURSES
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
SOCIAL WORKERS.
A RECOGNITION THAT MANY OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE AT RISK THAT THE
FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
RISK CAN BE IDENTIFIED IN MORE
THAN THAT THEY MAY BE THE VERY
REASONS WHY WE ARE SEEING THE
PATIENT.
ALL OF WHICH CREATES WHAT WE
CALL A TEACHABLE MOMENT A PHRASE
THAT I THINK IS FAMILIAR TO ALL
OF US IT'S A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH A
PATIENT.
AND CHANGE THAT PATIENTS
BEHAVIOR IN WAYS THAT WILL
BENEFIT THEM THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I SHOULD MENTION THAT THIS
SURGE OF INTEREST -- IS NOT JUST
ON THE PART OF THE PROFESSIONAL
COMMUNITY THE RESEARCH CENTER
HAS JUST COMPLETED THE FIRST
SURVEY OF FIREARM OWNERSHIP AND
USE IN CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST
FORTY YEARS.
WE ASKED ABOUT OPINIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
VIOLENCE MIGHT BE PREVENTED OF
THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
AND WE LEARNED THAT MORE THAN
90% OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND PATIENTS ABOUT
FIREARM INJURY MORE THAN 80% OF
CALIFORNIA FIREARM OWNERS
SUPPORT THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
WHEN THERE IS AN INDICATION OF
RISK WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT? TO GIVE YOU A SENSE I
THINK I THINK THAT THE DETAILS
OF WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING TO DO
ARE LAID OUT IN THE DOCUMENTS I
WOULD BE.
HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS
IF APPROPRIATE -- CLOSE BY
GIVING YOU A SENSE OF THE SCOPE
OF THE INITIATIVE WE ARE
UNDERTAKING YOU'RE PROPOSING TO
UNDERTAKE.
CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY FIFTY
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS IN PRIMARY
CARE SPECIALTIES FAMILY MEDICINE
INTERNAL MEDICINE PEDIATRICS SIX
THOUSAND EMERGENCY MEDICINE
PHYSICIANS LIKE ME SEVEN
THOUSAND PSYCHIATRISTS ALL OF
WHOM.
MAY HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN THIS
WE ALSO HAVE SOMEWHERE NORTH OF
FOUR MILLION FIREARM OWNERS IN
THE IN THE STATE IT WOULD TAKE A
LABOR FORCE OF THE THE SIZE I AM
I AM HINTING AT TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SUFFICIENT
FREQUENCY.
HELP IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
WE HAD A MOTION -- BUT BEFORE
THAT I JUST ONE IS THANK THE
AUTHOR -- FOR BRING THE BILL
FORWARD.
AND AND I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
TRAINING COULD LEAD -- COULD
LEAD TO INTERVENTIONS THAT WOULD
PREVENT.
MORE FIREARM RELATED TRAGEDIES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE STATE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISTER GLORIA IS SECOND BY MISS
MISTER LOWE.
AND MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN I KILEY
GONZALEZ?
GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE THE BILL
OPEN THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT -- FILE ITEM. TEN LOVE.
TO THIS PAST WEEKEND.
GOOD GOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FILE ITEM.
TEN AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND MISTER CHAIR.
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ADVOCATES RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT STUDENTS CALIFORNIA'S
ROLE BECOMES EVEN MORE CRITICAL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WILL
PREVENT COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES FROM EVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT BY REQUIRING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION THAT
CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT COLLEGE
OR A PUBLIC COLLEGE.
ACTUALLY MEETS THE DEFINITION OF
A NONPROFIT CORPORATION OR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THESE COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
ARE STARTING TO USE A NON PROFIT
OR PUBLIC LABEL MISLEADING
STUDENTS WHILE THE SAME TIME
DODGING APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
THESE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES ARE
TRYING TO GAME THE SYSTEM.
THE DECLINE IN ENFORCEMENT OF
NONPROFIT STATUS BY THE FEDERAL
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICES
ALLOWING SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES. TO GET AWAY WITH USING
COMPLICATED FINACIAL SCHEMES
AND SHELL CORPORATIONS TO LAY
CLAIM TO NONPROFIT STATUS.
THIS EMERGING PROBLEM IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
FOR EXAMPLE GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INCORPORATED IS A FOR
PROFIT COMPANY TRADED ON NASDAQ.
THEY CREATED A GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY AND CLAIM IT IS A
NONPROFIT COLLEGE.
HOWEVER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NONPROFIT GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY IS ALSO THE C. E. O.
OF THE FOR PROFIT GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INCORPORATED.
AND ABOUT 60% OF THE TUITION
REVENUE THAT THE NONPROFIT
COLLEGE RECEIVED FLOWS THROUGH
THE FOR PROFIT COMPANY.
AS GEORGETOWN LAW PROFESSOR IN
NONPROFIT LAW EXPERT BRIAN
GALLEY SAID THE NONPROFIT IS
ESSENTIALLY A TRUSTWORTHY
LOOKING WRAPPER AROUND A FOR
PROFIT BUSINESS.
THE ARRANGEMENT MAKES A MOCKERY
OF THE CONCEPT OF A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION.
WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT OR OVERSIGHT
THESE COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
WILL CONTINUE TO MISLEAD
STUDENTS AND AVOID APPROPRIATE
STATE OVERSIGHT.
IN FACT ASHFORD UNIVERSITY OWNED
BY BRIDGE POINT EDUCATION
INCORPORATED HAS ALREADY STATED
THAT IT WOULD FOLLOW GRAND
CANYON UNIVERSITY'S LEAD AND
CLAIM NONPROFIT STATUS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA CANNOT
RELY ON THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
DESPITE THE POOR RECORD OF SOME
FEDERALLY FUNDED FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES AND SCANDALS THAT HAVE
PLAGUED THE FOR PROFIT INDUSTRY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REFUSES
TO ADMIT THAT INVESTOR CONTROL
OF COLLEGES IS DETRIMENTAL TO
STUDENTS AND TAXPAYERS.
THEREFORE CALIFORNIA MUST STEP
UP AND STEP IN TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT REMAINS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN WITH ME TO TEST FIRE BOB
SHERMAN IN ERIC DEAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BOB CHAIRMAN
FROM THE CENTURY FOUNDATION --
WE'VE STUDIED THIS ISSUE OF FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES -- CAN CLAIMING
TO CONVERT TO NON PROFIT AND
HAVE FOUND THAT IN MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES WHAT THEY'VE
REALLY DONE IS SET UP A SHELL
CORPORATION AND PRETENDED TO BE
NONPROFIT BECAUSE THE IRS IS NO
LONGER REALLY ENFORCING
OVERSIGHT OF GENUINE NONPROFIT
STATUS.
THE NONPROFIT NO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT FRAUD COMPLAINTS FROM
STUDENTS WHO TEXTED LOANS MOST
STUDENT LOANS ARE ARE GO TO
STUDENTS AT NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES BUTTON ALMOST 99%
OF THE FRAUD COMPLAINTS
INVOLVING FEDERAL STUDENT LOANS.
ARE FROM FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
THAT'S BECAUSE THE PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT CONTROL OF COLLEGES
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION IT HAS BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE AND IT IS WHY
THERE IS A GOOD REPUTATION
GENERALLY. FOR PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE FOR PROFITS WANT TO GRAB ON
TO THAT REPUTATION AND SELL
THEIR COLLEGE BASED ON THAT
REPUTATION WELL NOT ACTUALLY
APPLYING TO THEMSELVES THE RULES
THAT SEPARATE THE MONEY MAKING
FROM THE CONTROL.
OF THE COLLEGE THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH FOR CALIFORNIA PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR COLLEGES
CALLING ITSELF NONPROFIT OR
PUBLIC THAT ACTUALLY OPERATES
THAT WAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR -- MY NAME
IS ACTING I'M ACTUALLY SENDING A
RESIDENT AND A FORMER ASHFORD
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEE AND NAVY
VETERAN MYSELF AND I WAS A
MILITARY OR ENROLLMENT SERVICES
ADVISOR AT ASHFORD.
FOR A TWO AND A HALF YEARS FROM
JUNE TWENTY FIFTEEN TO DECEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I WAS ABLE TO
SEE FIRST HAND HOW IT WORKS
THERE WITHIN THE FIRST THREE
WEEKS.
I LEARNED THAT I WAS BEING
TRAINED TO BE A SALES PERSON.
I WASN'T THERE TO ADVISE I
WASN'T THERE -- TO BRING
STUDENTS INTO THE WORLD OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IT WAS THERE.
TO SELL.
AND I WANT TO SPEAK FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE OF CALLING COLD
CALLING TWO HUNDRED UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE A DAY.
AND MOST THE PEOPLE I SPOKE TO
WAR OF THE WORLDS FROM LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN THE ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THAT WILL OUR SHARES WERE
BEING SOLD ON THE STOCK MARKET.
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY TO ME AS A
FORMER EMPLOYEE WHEN I HAD TO
SIT THERE AND CALL PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND BECOME
THEIR FRIEND AND ROLL THEM AND
WATCH THEM RACK UP STUDENT THAT
AND I WOULDN'T CARE BECAUSE I
WAS ALREADY ON TO THE NEXT MONTH
NUMBERS THAT I HAD HIT.
I WAS ON THE PHONE FOR FOUR
HOURS A DAY AND MY JOB WAS TO
TELL A MARKET EDUCATION.
AND BECAUSE WE HAD BPI SHARES.
TO LINE UP PUT THE SHAREHOLDER
POCKETS AND WHEN WE WENT THROUGH
THAT IT WAS X. IT A CREATE A
COMPETITIVE SALES ENVIRONMENT SO
WE WOULD DO COMPETITIONS ON THE
FLOOR THAT THE OF THE COLLEGE IF
YOU WELL.
AND WE WOULD.
BE GIVEN FLAGS OF WE GOT MORE TO
ENROLL OR OR PRESENT PRICES LIKE --
YOU KNOW SHOUT OUTS FROM YOUR
DIRECTOR AND IF WE WEREN'T
HITTING OUR NUMBERS WERE BROUGHT
INTO A CONFERENCE ROOM AND
PUBLICLY SHAMED IN FRONT OF OUR
PEERS.
THIS IS HOW ASHFORD UNIVERSITY
IS RUN AND WHILE I WAS THERE
BEFORE IT'S TRYING TO SWITCH
OVER NONPROFIT I CAN ASSURE YOU
AS LONG AS BPI HAS SHARES ON THE
NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
IT WILL RUN THE EXACT SAME WAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU COME
TO THE MIKE GIVE YOUR NAME GROUP
YOU'RE WITH GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AT HOWARD ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE THE AMITY
FOUNDATION AND THE SENTRY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RAYMOND CURTIS
REPRESENTING VETERANS EDUCATION
SUCCESS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IN THE ENTIRE PACKAGE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BOBBIE IS
MANAGING ATTORNEY OF US THESE
VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
SUSAN MARTIN DON'T CONSUMER
REPORTS ALSO VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS BILL THE WHOLE
PACKAGE.
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JOSEFINA MEAL FROM HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES OF
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MIKE TO COME TO THE TABLE.
TWENTY YEAH THAT'S FINE THIS IS
A LONG.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF ASHFORD
UNIVERSITY WE'VE HAD SOME
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS WITH
SPONSORS -- MEMBERS OFFICE I
THINK WE'RE GONNA TRY AND HAVE
SOME MEETINGS AND SEE WHERE WE
CAN GO MORE.
IN THIS IN THIS BILL I THINK GAS
WHAT IS IN THE MIDST OF DOING
ONE OF THESE CONVERSIONS FROM
FOR PROFIT TO NOT FOR PROFIT AND
WITH A FOUR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NO OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS NOT SEEING ANY.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH RESPECT FASTER AYE VOTE THE
MISTER.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FORWARD WE HAD A MOTION
BY MISTER LOW.
A SECOND BY MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN I KILEY?
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
A SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THE MEASURE
THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE WILL HAVE -- ITEM
EIGHT MS REAVERS.
AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WELCOME IS
REVERSED THANK YOU
.
AND AND AND JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
TIME I WILL POINT OUT.
THAT THIS BILL DOES.
ENJOY SUPPORT SUPPORT.
I'M LOS SITES AND ANY ANY HAD A
MOTION.
DOESN'T GET MUCH BETTER IN MATH
I KNOW.
I'LL BE QUICK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENT THEY'LL TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS.
I'M LAID OUT IN THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN WHICH SIX TO ENSURE
THAT A STUDENT'S FUTURE IS NOT%
HELD HOSTAGE BY COLLEGES BY
PROHIBITING POST SECONDARY
SCHOOLS FROM REFUSING TO PROVIDE
A TRANSCRIPT.
ON THE GROUNDS THAT THE STUDENT
OWES A DEBT.
COLLEGE TRANSCRIPTS ARE CRITICAL
DOCUMENTS THAT STUDENTS OFTEN
NEED TO OBTAIN A JOB OR PURSUE A
HIGHER DEGREE -- TODAY I'M HAPPY
TO HAVE WITH ME TOO TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WHO IS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
STUDENT BORRAR PROTECTION CENTER
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
I THANK YOU MY NAME IS ANTHONY
LEAVE THEM WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE AG IS PROUD.
TO SPONSOR AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WHICH SEEKS TO
RESTRICT POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
FROM THE PRACTICE OF WITHHOLDING
STUDENT TRANSCRIPTS AS A MEANS
OF DEBT COLLECTION.
AND WE SHARE THE AUTHORS
CONCERNED THAT THIS PRACTICE
HANDCUFFS STUDENTS FROM PURSUING
EDUCATIONAL.
AND CAREER OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO YOUR
TRANSCRIPT IN ORDER TO APPLY FOR
GRAD SCHOOL TRANSFER TO A BETTER
SCHOOL OR OBTAIN A FELLOWSHIP
FOR A JOB.
SO WE JOINED THE CALL TO CHANGE
THE CONVERSATION AROUND THIS.
LONG STANDING METHOD OF
COLLECTING DATA AND I WENT
INTRODUCED. FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY MY
NAME IS REBECCA MORE.
YOU'RE FINE -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS REBECCA MORE MINUTE
TOURNEY WHO REPRESENT STUDENT
BORROWERS IN ADDITION TO MY LAW
PRACTICE I'M A STUDENT LOAN
JUSTICE FOLLOW AT THE STUDENT
BORROWER PROTECTION CENTER.
A NONPROFIT FOUNDED BY THE
FORMER STUDENT LOAN OMBUDSMAN AT
THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU.
MY RESEARCH FOCUSES ON THE
PRACTICE OF TRANSCRIPT
WITHHOLDING WHICH IS THE FOCUS
OF THIS BILL.
IN MY CAPACITY AS AN ADVOCATE
AND DOESN'T SB PC FELLOW I'M
PLEASED TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN I WANTED A THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INVITATION AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THE PRACTICE OF TRANSFER
WITHHOLDING ALLOWS AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO REFUSE TO PRODUCE AN OFFICIAL
TRANSCRIPT WHEN A STUDENT HAS A
FINANCIAL HOLD ON THEIR ACCOUNT.
CONSIDER A FAIRLY TYPICAL
SITUATION JOHN SMITH IS ENROLLED
IN A FOR PROFIT COLLEGE WHERE HE
IS WORKING ON AN ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE.
ONCE COMPLETED HE'LL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR A PROMOTION AT WORK.
JOHN IS ONLY A FEW CREDITS AWAY
FROM FINISHING WHEN HIS CAR
BREAKS DOWN AND HE HAS AN
UNEXPECTED REPAIR.
THIS CAR REPAIR SETS JOHN BACK
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS AND MAKES
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR HIM TO COVER
THIS TUITION PAYMENTS.
JOHN WITHDRAWS FROM THE CLASS
AND ENDS UP WITH THE FINANCIAL
HOLD ON HIS ACCOUNT FOR THE
UNPAID TUITION.
A FEW MONTHS LATER JOHN IS READY
TO COMPLETE HIS DEGREE BUT HE
FINDS THAT HIS FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE I'M DOES NOT HAVE
FLEXIBLE POLICIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW HIM TO RE ENROLL AND GET
THE CREDIT HE NEEDS.
HOWEVER THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DOWN THE ROAD DOES.
THE PROBLEM JOHN'S ORIGINAL
SCHOOL REFUSES TO RELEASE HIS
TRANSCRIPT WELL JOHN HAS AND
FINANCIAL HOLD ON HIS ACCOUNT.
JOHN CANNOT TRANSFER HIS CREDITS
CANNOT FINISH HIS DEGREE AND
CANNOT EVEN APPLY FOR THE RACE
THAT WOULD HELP HIM GET RID OF
THIS TUITION DEBT.
IN OTHER WORDS THE ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL OF JOHNS TO GREET IS
LOCKED UP IN THE TRANSCRIPT.
IN MY RESEARCH IN IN MY PRACTICE
I FOUND TRANSIT WITHHOLDING TO
BE A COMMON PRACTICE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS IS LOCKED UP BECAUSE
OF TRANSCRIPT WITHHOLDING.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WILL LIMIT
THE ABILITY OF INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO WITHHOLD
TRANSCRIPTS BECAUSE OF SMALL
FINANCIAL HOLDS.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WILL UNLOCK
THE ECONOMIC POTENTIAL OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
LOOKING TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES
THROUGH THE AMERICAN DREAM OF AN
EDUCATION. FOR THESE REASONS I
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AGAIN SEE NINE ANY TWEETERS
[inaudible]
TWEETERS.
LARA MATTOON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION WE'RE WORKING OUR WAY
TO A SUPPORT WE ARE AWARE OF A
HANDFUL OF SITUATIONS WHERE THIS
HAS HAPPENED.
WERE OUR COLLEGES WERE THE ONES
USING THE AUTHORITY TO WITHHOLD
TRANSCRIPTS MORE OFTEN WE HEAR
THE SITUATIONS THAT WERE
DESCRIBED IN THE TESTIMONY WHICH
WE THINK IS NOT THE PRACTICE
THAT BEST SUPPORTS OUR STUDENTS
SO I HOPE TO BE IN SUPPORT IN
YOUR NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
OTHER TWEETERS.
TYLER I DO ARMY AFTER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL AS WELL
WE APPRECIATE -- THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT AND WE WORK WITH THE
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS WELL WE
PRIMARILY SEE THIS METHOD FOR
DEBT COLLECTION AS A WAY TO
START A CONVERSATION WITH
STUDENTS AND SOMETIMES WE'RE NOT
HOLDING THEM TO YOU KNOW.
ANY PARTICULAR AMOUNT BUT IT
GETS US TO A PLACE WHERE WE
COULD FEEL LIKE NOW WE CAN AT
LEAST -- TALK ABOUT THE DEBT AND
SEE IF IT'S REPAIRABLE BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO ORDER THE OTHERS
OFFICE AND WE'VE I'VE EXPLAINED
OUR CONCERNS AND WILL BE ENGAGED
IN A THANKS AGAIN.
END OF THE NEXT WINTERS WOULD
JUST GIVE THEIR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS SURE OF
COURSE I CAN TAKE A HINT ALEX
GRAVES OF THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES OUT ECHO MUCH OF
WHAT MY PREDECESSOR SET FROM YOU
SEE THANK YOU.
HI MAGGIE RIGHT WITH CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY I WOULD ALSO ADD ECHO
OF MY COUNTERPARTS AT THE OTHER
SYSTEMS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
A PRIEST PREACHES THE
CONVERSATION ON THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION -- THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU AND WHILE I KNOW THE
CONCERNED FROM.
SOME OF THE SEGMENTS I AM
PERSUADED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S.
ARGUMENT THAT WITHHOLDING
TRANSCRIPTS FROM STUDENTS CAN DO
MORE HARM THAN GOOD SO I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AND FOR PROCESSING PURPOSES THE
AMENDMENTS DESCRIBE AND THEN
ANALYSIS WILL BE TAKEN WITH THE
AUTHORS CONCURRENCE WHEN THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
LOW.
A SECOND BY MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AND SECRETARY VIEWED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I GLORIA.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KILEY GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
FIVE ZERO WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
GIVE.
AND LOOKING IN SIGNED IN ORDER I
DON'T SEE MISTER BONTA.
I DON'T SEE MISTER MURATSUCHI SO
WE WILL GO TO ITEM TWELVE THE
SECOND.
WELCOME THIS SEGMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS A SIMPLE BILL TO
PROTECT VETERANS AND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS -- IN THE ME START BY
SAYING LIKE STEP THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON IT AND I KNOW WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
FORWARD -- AND AS WE TALK ABOUT
THIS BILL WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND
THAT THESE ARE FOR PROFIT
BUSINESSES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
AND WANT TO DO VERY WELL --
FINANCIALLY ESPECIALLY.
WE HAVE SEEN ONE ACCESS TO
STUDENT AID INCREASES AND
REGULATIONS DECREES -- THAT'S
WHEN POLICY MAKERS NEED TO STEP
IN AND DO SOMETHING -- THERE IS
A REASON THAT SHARES OF FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES JUMPED 40% AFTER
THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ELECTION BECAUSE INVESTORS KNEW
THAT THERE WAS MONEY TO BE MADE.
AND WE CAN BE ANGRY AT THEM FOR
THAT THEY ARE FOR PROFIT
BUSINESSES THAT'S WHAT THEY DO
THEY MAKE MONEY -- AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR JOB AS POLICY MAKERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECT OUR
VETERANS AS WELL AS OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
RIGHT NOW FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
HAVE VARIOUS TAXPAYER FUNDED
SOURCES OF REVENUE.
THAT TITLE FOR AID AND GI
BENEFITS.
IN SOME CAL GRANTS AS WELL.
WHILE WE CURRENTLY HAVE A NINETY
TEN RULE FOR TITLE FOUR EIGHT A
SEPARATE EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN
RULE FOR GI BILL BENEFITS DOES.
TO REGULATIONS DON'T TALK TO
EACH OTHER.
AND DON'T ADD UP TO A SINGLE
AMOUNT.
SO ESSENTIALLY SCHOOLS CAN BE A
100% FUNDED BY GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS BUT WITHOUT THE MANDATE
THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE.
AND THAT'S NOT AGAIN IS NOT
THEIR ROLE TO POLICE THEMSELVES
THAT IS OUR ROLE AS POLICY
MAKERS TO MAKE SURE OF THAT OUR
VETERANS ARE.
LEAVING THE SCHOOLS WITH HUGE
AMOUNTS OF DEBT THAT THEY NEED
TO PAY BACK.
AND THAT DEBT BEING OFF THE THE
THEIR TUITION MEAN ALL FUNDED BY
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
STEP APART FROM THE NEW YORK
FEDERAL RESERVE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
RESEARCH SHOW THAT THE LINK
BETWEEN HOW MUCH SCHOOLS CHARGE
AND HOW MUCH IS AVAILABLE.
IS DIRECTLY RELATED -- SO.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CONTAIN COSTS
TO AN 8515% RULE ON TAXPAYER
FUNDING -- IF SCHOOLS CAN'T MEET
THAT THRESHOLD -- THEN WE ARE
ASKING THAT 50% OF THEIR FUNDING
OF THE MONEY THEY RECEIVE GO
DIRECTLY TO TUITION AND I AM
MINDFUL THAT WE'RE STILL FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS --
BUT WE WANT TO BE MINDFUL THAT
THAT MONEY.
IS INTENDED FOR STUDENTS IT IS
NOT GOING TO SHAREHOLDER PROFITS
AND TARGETED AT STUDENT
RECRUITMENT -- WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S UP FOR FOR PROFIT
UNIVERSITIES THAT IS A HIGH
THING THEY DO IS THEY GO AFTER
STUDENTS THAT MONEY AT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS SHOULD BE GOING INTO THE
TEACHING [inaudible]
I AM.
WE COULD SET TUITION CAPS I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY WANTS TO DO
THAT OR WE COULD MAKE SKIDS
SCHOOLS BID COMPETITIVELY FOR
FEDERAL OR STATE RESOURCES --
BUT WE TOOK A NUMBER OF
CONSERVATIVE APPROACH THAT JUST
SAID BUT LET THE MARKET DECIDE
LET THE MARKET DECIDE IF THE
SCHOOL IS THAT GOOD THEN 50% OF
THAT MONEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COME FROM -- PRIVATE PAY OR IF
NOT.
THEY CAN HAVE THE FULL AMOUNT
BUT THEN 50% OF THAT NEEDS TO GO
TO TUITION -- IF THERE IS TRULY
A BENEFIT TO THESE PROGRAMS AND
SOMEONE OTHER THAN THE
GOVERNMENT MUST BE WILLING TO
PAY -- AND AGAIN REMEMBER STE
THE THE THE THE VETERANS ARE
LEFT WITH HUGE AMOUNTS OF DEBTS
AFTERWARDS SO AGAIN BUT IN
ESSENCE WERE PAYING TWICE -- WE
KNOW -- PARTICULAR WASHINGTON
ONE CONTROLLED CONGRESS CYCLED
SO TO THE REGULATIONS ON THE
SCHOOLS IN NINETEEN EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT THE EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN ROLE
WAS WEAKENED TO A RATIO OF
NINETY TEN AND MORE RECENTLY THE
US DEPARTMENT EDUCATION UNDER
SECRETARY DEVICE HAS ROLLED BACK
EVEN OTHER PROTECTIONS -- IN
ADDITION TO WEAKENING
REGULATIONS A HUGE INCREASE IN
POST NINE ELEVEN GI BILL
BENEFITS AND RECIPIENTS BEEN A
NEW POT OF FEDERAL MONEY.
COMING IN TO BE AVAILABLE -- WE
KNOW THAT SCHOOLS TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF TAXPAYER FUNDED PROGRAMS TO
THE EXTENT THE CONGRESS PASSED A
LAW TO PROTECT IT WELL WE ARE
ALLOWING HER EVEN ENCOURAGING
THE TARGETING OF PENSION
BENEFITS TO FUND FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTION.
IT DEGRADES THE INTENT OF THE
ROLE AND HERS VETERANS STUDENTS.
MIGHT HEAR OPPONENTS SAY THAT
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE 5275290% OF
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS IN THE
STATE.
WHICH TO ME IS A DEMONSTRATION
OF HOW BIG THIS PROBLEM IS --
AND THISTHAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THE MAJORITY OF FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE BUSINESSES MODELS DEPEND
ON ON THE ON THE STRUCTURE THAT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY USING.
G. I. BENEFITS ARE SUBSIDIZING
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ARE RAYMOND CURTIS FROM
VETERANS EDUCATION SUCCESS AND
DEAN A WHISTLEBLOWER WHO BROUGHT
TO LIGHT THE RECRUITING
PRACTICES AT ASHFORD UNIVERSITY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HEARING US THIS MORNING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RAYMOND
CURTIS.
I AM THE STATE POLICY MANAGER
FOR VETERANS EDUCATION SUCCESS
AND I AM A AN IRAQ WAR VETERAN
SERVED IN THE MILITARY IN THE
ARMY FROM 200-032-2000 AND NINE
AND IN IRAQ IN 200-052-0006.
I AM HERE TODAY TO EXTEND --
IT'S PLAYING SOME ISSUES IN THE
TWO PRIMARY PURPOSES OF THIS
BILL -- SO THAT WE CAN THEN
EXPLAINED -- THE THE DAMAGE HAS
BEEN CAUSED BY THE LOOPHOLE THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST WITHIN THE
FEDERAL LAW SO FIRST OF ALL AS
THE REPRESENTATIVE SPOKE ABOUT
WE HAVE WAYS OF SETTING OF
UNDERSTANDING PROPER PRICING
WHEN TAX DOLLARS ARE PAYING FOR
THINGS SUCH AS IS ANYTHING
ADMITTED TO IT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
OF DEFENSE FOR BUYING WEAPONS OR
THINGS LIKE THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
MORRIS IF WE'RE PAYING MEDICAL
BILLS FOR SOMEBODY THE HOSPITAL
CONSENT A BILL IN THE GOVERNMENT
TELLS THEM HOW MUCH THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY.
SO WHEN IT COMES T THE
EDUCATION -- PRICES THIS IS SET
IN THIS WAS DECIDED WITH NINETY
TEN ROLL THIS IS SET.
BY ENSURING THAT AT LEAST 10% OF
PRIVATE DOLLARS NO MATTER WHERE
IT COMES FROM IS SPENT AT THE
SCHOOL FOR THIS PRODUCT
OTHERWISE THE PRODUCT IS OVER
PRICED.
IF THE PRODUCT IS OVERPRICED AND
PEOPLE AREN'T SPENDING THEIR OWN
DOLLARS ON THIS AND THERE IS A
DISTINCT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SENDING SPENDING YOUR OWN
DOLLARS AND SPENDING A VOUCHER
THAT YOU RECEIVE THAT CAN BE
USED FOR NOTHING ELSE EXCEPT FOR
EDUCATION.
SO THOSE OF THE THE WHAT THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THIS
REGULATION SO IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE MARKET IS FUNCTIONING
PROPERLY AND WE AREN'T
DRASTICALLY OVER PRICING THESE
WELL WE SCHOOL INSTITUTIONS ARE
DRASTICALLY OVER PRICING THE
PRODUCT THAT THEY'RE OFFERING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN
RECEIVE.
FEDERAL TUITION DOLLARS FROM IT
SECONDLY THIS IS GOING TO BE
PROTECTING OUR VETERANS WHO
RIGHT NOW ARE CAUGHT UP IN A
LOOPHOLE THAT IS CAUSING
PROBLEMS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY VETERANS EDUCATION
SUCCESS WE WORK WITH NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND VETERANS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEFRAUDED BY FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY ON
IT'S OF THEM IN THIS VERY STATE.
SO THE LOOPHOLE WAS CREATED
BECAUSE THE NINETY TEN RULE
STARTED IN THE NINETIES THE POST
NINE ELEVEN GI BILL AND
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION WHICH
I USED TO GO TO SCHOOL WAS
CREATED IN THE AFTERWARDS IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AFTER THE
INVASION OF IRAQ -- THE AFTER
THE INVASION OF IRAQ -- SO.
THAT BENEFIT AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE MONEY AS
WELL AS BY THE WAY -- FOSTER
CHILDREN BENEFITS -- DOESN'T
FALL UNDER TITLE FOR WHICH IS
HOW THE REGULATION DEFINES WHAT
IS FEDERAL TUITION ASSISTANCE
AND THAT'S HOW IT WAS IN THE
NINETIES BUT NOW IT'S DIFFERENT.
AND SO WE NEED TO BE
INCORPORATING ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FEDERAL
BENEFITS SO THAT THE REGULATION
IS PROPERLY FUNCTIONING SO THAT
WE'RE GETTING A PROPER PRICE.
ON THE PRODUCT THAT IS BEING
DELIVERED AND IT'S NOT SET BY
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
TUITION ASSISTANCE THAT THE
SCHOOLS CAN GET.
A MINUTE.
IF OF I MIGHT GO TO THE SECOND
WITNESS -- JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE EVERYONE THE
ALLOTTED TIME.
MY APOLOGIES OKAY.
CHECK -- AGAIN MY NAME IS ACTING
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE EARLIER I
WAS A ADVISER AT ASHFORD
UNIVERSITY ICE OUT OF THE TWO
YEARS AND SEVEN MONTHS I SPENT
THERE TWO POINT. TWO TWO YEARS
AND SIX AND FOUR MONTHS OF THAT
WAS SPENT AS A MILITARY ADVISER.
ENROLLMENT SERVICES ADVISER FOR
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
SO A BOOK OF MY WORK WAS CALLING
THESE VETERANS EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO GET THEM TO ENROLL IN SCHOOL
AND I THINK THE MOST POWERFUL
PART OF THIS IS THAT I WAS A
VETERAN.
AND BEFORE I WAS EMPLOYED AT
ASHFORD WHEN EMPLOYED ME WITH
ONLY THIRTY ONE COLLEGE CREDITS.
I WAS NEARLY HOMELESS AND THAT
WAS ONLY JOB IN SAN DIEGO THAT
WOULD PAY OVER. SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR THIRTY
COLLEGE CREDITS SO I JUMPED IN
MY BODY AND AND I STARTED SALES
FOR FOR THE MILITARY -- AND I
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH VETERANS STRUGGLING TO GET
ON THEIR FEET TRANSITION JUST
LIKE I HAD SO I SAW SOMETHING IN
THEM.
AND I WANTED TO HELP THEM BUT I
REALIZED LATER ON THAT AND
ROLLING THEM INTO A FOR PROFIT
UNIVERSITY WASN'T A BENEFIT TO
THEM IT WAS DISENFRANCHISED
ALREADY DISENFRANCHISED -- AND
YEAH AGAIN THIS WAS ABOUT BEING
THE STUDENTS FRIENDS GETTING
THEM TO SIGN UP FOR SCHOOL AND
FORGET ABOUT THEM.
IF OUR NUMBERS WERE SLIPPING OUR
DIRECTOR WOULD POST IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM.
AND PUBLICLY POSTER NUMBERS ON
THE PROJECTOR FOR OUR TEAM TO
CHASTISE US AFTERWARDS -- ON TOP
OF THAT THE PRESSURE WE WERE PUT
TO GET THE STUDENTS VA DOCUMENTS
COMPLETOS CRUCIAL'S CRUCIAL TO
ASHFORD ATTAINMENT STRATEGY WAS
PUSHING THEM.
TO COMPLETE THESE VIDAK THAT'S
RIGHT AWAY -- THE GI BILL MONEY
IS KEY TO THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PLACES LIKE ASHFORD -- THE THEY
NEED TO SURVIVE WHICH MEANS THEY
HAVE TO TARGET VETERANS KEEP
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS HAPPY AGAIN
THIS IS ALL ABOUT PUTTING PROFIT
ABOVE EDUCATION IT IS A MODEL
THAT FILLS OUR VETERANS FILLS
OUR STUDENTS AND FILLS OUR
COUNTRY'S.
PLEASE PASS AB.
FOR THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION --
WITH.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S ANGELA PERRY I'M AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS AND I'M STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BOB
MUTE I'M MANAGING ATTORNEY OF
THE VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL%
OF LAW AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
I'M -- COMBAT THAT WITH TWO
COMBAT TOURS -- MY CLIENTS
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA SPORTS AS LESLIE'S
THANKS.
AT OUR CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW STROKES.
I WOULD GET ON A WITH COULD DONE
IN ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION AND THE AMITY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IN THIS PACKAGE THANK
YOU.
CAN YOU GET TERRACE ON HALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
FLOOR MATTOON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY AND THE NEARLY
SIXTY THOUSAND BETTER AND
STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT.
BERRY GRUBIN'S COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS IN SUPPORT.
JOSEPH HOW TO ME -- FROM HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEE NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CAN COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE.
AND IF WE'D MAKE ROOM FOR THE
WITNESSES IN.
OPPOSITION AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
AND AS THE WITNESSES BEFORE. TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES. FOUR FOUR
MINUTES ANYWAY YOU WANT TO
DIVIDE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS TO GO TO BEAR --
I SERVED IN THE US ARMY AS A
MEDIC WITH THE THE TIME ABOUT
THE VISION IN UPSTATE NEW YORK --
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
ATTEND A CRITIC CAN BE A MEDICAL
ARTS -- I CHOSE A SCHOOL
PRIMARILY -- BECAUSE WHEN I GOT
OUT OF THE ARMY I HAD ALREADY --
I WAS MARRIED AND HAD A ONE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER SO I DIDN'T HAVE --
THE TIME.
TO GO TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
AND AT PLAY -- ACTUALLY IT
LOOKED FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
I'VE MAPPED OUT MY SCHEDULE AND
THAT WOULD HAVE TAKEN ME -- FOR
MY PARTICULAR PROGRAM ARE AND AT
LEAST TWO YEARS JUST TO MY
PREREQUISITES BEFORE I COULD GET
INTO SCHOOL -- AND THE OTHER ARE
IN PROGRAMS I WAS ABLE -- TO
LOCATE WHERE YOU THEIR WATERY
BASED OR JUST NOT GOING TO WORK
WITH WITH MY LIFE I I LIKE I
SAID I HAVE ALREADY HAD -- A
WIFE AND MY DAUGHTER AND WHEN I
GOT OUT OF THE ARMY I DIDN'T
HAVE TIME.
TO MESS AROUND IN SCHOOL AND I
NEEDED TO TO GET MY CAREER GOING
IN AND PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY --
KARNIK -- OFFERED ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY WITH A CONDENSED
PROGRAM -- AND THEY LET ME GET
IN WITH NO PRIOR SCHOOLING --
THEY TOOK ME STRAIGHT IN AND I
ACTUALLY FOUND OUT ABOUT THEM --
THROUGH MY MY FATHER HE'S OUR
AND AND A COWORKER OF HIS
RECOMMENDED IT TO ME -- AT NO
POINT DID I SEE ANY
ADVERTISEMENTS OR PREDATORY
MARKETING -- DIRECTED OF
VETERANS OR ANYTHING OF THAT
SORT -- I ACTUALLY DIDN'T EVEN
THOUGH THE SCHOOL EXISTED IN MY
PRIOR SEARCHES -- FOR A SCHOOL --
AND SO BECAUSE OF THESE THINGS
AT THE TIME FRAME AND AND AND
THE THINGS THAT KERN IT COULD
OFFER ME THAT.
THAT OTHER SCHOOLS COULDN'T -- I
I REALLY THINK THAT THE THIS
BILL MIGHT AFFECT PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS AND NOT PROVIDE.
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY FOR
VETERANS LIKE MYSELF.
TO HIT THE GROUND RUNNING WHEN
THEY GE OUT AND AND CONTINUE
THEIR CAREER AND SMOOTH FASHION
IN AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA HANSON AND I
WAS A STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND
IRVINE CALIFORNIA.
I WANTED TO GO INTO THE FIELD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND THERE'S
ONLY FIVE AT THE TIME IS ONLY
FIVE ACCREDITED SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT OFFERED
THE PROGRAM THAT I WAS LOOKING.
FOR THE ONE THAT WAS CLOSEST TO
ME TEN MINUTES FROM MY HOUSE
WITH A LOTTERY BASED SYSTEM AND
I DID NOT HAVE THE TIME OR THE
RESOURCES TO WAIT AROUND.
FOR ANYTHING LIKE TO EX WIFE A
LOTTERY TO HAPPEN SO I SOUGHT
OUT MY OTHER OPTIONS ONE OF
THOSE BEING STANFORD UNIVERSITY --
WHEN I GOT THERE I FOUND THAT I
HAD AN EASIER TIME ATTENDING THE
COLLEGE BECAUSE WHEN I GOT OUT
OF THE MILITARY?
I'VE -- HAD HAD A TBI PTSD OR
TRY TO BRAIN INJURY CAUSED BY
STRESS DISORDER AS WELL AS
SUFFERED.
FROM A MILITARY SEXUAL TRAUMA.
SO BECAUSE OF ALL THESE THINGS
BEING IN THESE LARGE CAMPUSES
WITH -- LOTS OF OTHER PEOPLE AND
THE CONSTANTLY CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT WITH LIKE THE
DIFFERENT TEACHERS AND STUFF.
I WE HAD A REALLY HARD TIME TELL
MYSELF REALLY ANXIOUS AND
STRUGGLE TO ATTEND SCHOOL
REGULARLY.
WITH THE PRIVATE AJIT BUT THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL THAT I WENT TO
EITHER OF THEM SCAMMERS
UNIVERSITY THE CLASSROOMS ARE
MUCH SMALLER.
AND I WAS ABLE TO LEARN HOW TO
INTEGRATE MYSELF BETTER INTO
SOCIETY AND WITHOUT.
BEING ABLE TO BE THERE I
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
SUCH A THING -- I HAD A
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE AT MY
COLLEGE NEVER NOT ONCE DID I
FEEL PREYED UPON -- AND FOR MY
GI BILL OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT I
AM CHOSEN SOUGHT OUT THE SCHOOL
MYSELF.
AND THIS BILL WOULD NEGATIVELY
AFFECT OTHERS LIKE ME A IF
THEY'RE NOT A LOT THEY'RE NOT A
LOT AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT THEY
ARE NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BUT
I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RICK WOULD INSTITUTE A
TECHNOLOGY IN OPPOSITION.
MAP BACK REPRESENTING CAPS IN
OPPOSITION.
JIM YOUR CAMPUS PRESIDENT TO YOU
WE ARE COLLEGE SACRAMENTO WHO
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMARON HAVE A SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN CARE
CAN COLLAGEN IN OPPOSITION.
IN OUR MENTAL WITH AFTER COLLEGE
SACRAMENTO IN OPPOSITION. TEN
AYE JIMENEZ IFTEEN YEAR
AIRFORCE VETERAN AFTER COLLEGE I
IN OPPOSITION.
COME UP TO THE MIKE GIVE YOUR
NAME RUBIO WITH CHANTELLE HER
TAUGHT -- YOU WE AYE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE.
HI RECORDING A UP I STUDENT
SACRAMENTO A SETTLEMENT MEDI
CALL BILLING AND I DO OPPOSE.
BRUCE PRESSLER INSTRUCTOR AT UP
I COLLEGE I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
SPECIALIST THE RUMORED OREO FROM
UNITECH COLLEGE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
JANICE PAULSON UNITECH COLLEGE
FREMONT -- STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS MITCHELL FIRST FROM
NORTHWEST COLLEGES AND THE LOS
ANGELES AREA IT'S STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THIS BILL
WILL HARM STUDENTS IT DOESN'T
HELP STUDENTS IT HARMS OF ONE
ALLEN SHOWN ARE THE BELLAS
ACADEMY SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
FRED JONES PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
BAYLOR MEZA GLINDA KERR COLLEGE
GOING TO CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE COLLEGE LESS
AFFORDABLE TO THOSE WHO NEED IT
MOST.
HE'S GOT NO RESPECTFULLY.
MY NAME IS MADISON HALL AND I
REPRESENT CAREER CONNECTS STUDY
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IN A HOLE WITH
UNITECH COLLEGE FROM FREMONT
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
STEVE WATKINS WITH UNITECH
COLLEGE IN BAKERSFIELD AND AYE
OPPOSED.
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY
UNIVERSITY.
OF COME HERE TO OPPOSE.
EMPIRE COLLEGE SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS IN SCHOOL OF LAW AND
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA I VOTE NO.
HI SHERRY HEARD EMPIRE COLLEGE
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA.
I REQUEST THAT YOU VOTE NO.
MICHAEL FRANKLIN UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS AND I SAY NO.
JOHN KANDER ARMY THAT AS CAPTAIN
AND I SAID NO.
DON'T GOING OVER STEDMAN OPPOSED.
CATCHER GARY ARMY VETERAN I
OPPOSE.
JOE GIFFORD ARMY VETERAN AYE
OPPOSES.
RICHARD KERN AIRFORCE BETTER
OPPOSE.
HI MICHELLE FROM ROSEVILLE I'M A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
WHERE I'M GOING SORRY.
IN ALL DESIGN INSTITUTE AND I
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ALICIA THOMPSON FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO ULTRASOUND INSTITUTE
NAY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PRECIOUS AND I'M FROM ELK GROVE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
ULTRASOUND INSTITUTE.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS JOHNSON I'M
FROM BACK BILL CALIFORNIA WITH
US SACRAMENTO SENATE STUDENT
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANTHONY RAMOS SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COLLEGE IN OPPOSITION.
ROBERT HENDRICKSON CARRINGTON
HELLO MY NAME IS JAN ACROSS THE
I LIVE IN LIKE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ACTUALLY GOMA AND I'M
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VANESSA VAN A HIGH
AND I'M STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE NOW MINE I AM
FROM FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WOULD BE THE MARK HAS
AND I'M FROM WHAT I CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSES.
MY NAME IS KARENA MANAGEABLE AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA RUN TESTS ON
HIS SECOND RUN ON AYE OPPOSED TO
SPILL.
SERGIO MANDATORY FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M AMY I'M FOR A NATIONAL
CREDIT CATION AND SUCH -- SITES
I'M ALSO A VETERAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ANNA MARIE MALKA
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT FROM
NATIONAL CAREER EDUCATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ANGEL I'M CUT -- I'M
FROM NATIONAL COURAGE CATION
MAKRIS SERVICE COORDINATOR I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS NICK WELL AGAIN FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA -- I GO TO
SACRAMENTO SON IS TWO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHAN THEIR
MISSION I'M FROM SACRAMENTO TO
STONE INSTITUTE FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS PAMELA WALDEN I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO ALL FOR SOUND
INSTITUTE AND I LIVE IN
ROSEVILLE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
SAMIR MAGEN CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER AT S. SACRAMENTO SAN
INSTITUTE NATIONALLY POSES BUT
SALLY MAKE KILL BMS INSTITUTE
FOR BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY.
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CELINE IS WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY IN
SILICON VALLEY VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL WHICH
LIMITS THE CHOICE OF VETERANS.
WHICH IS AND EARNED BENEFIT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR A MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
OPPOSED IT WAS LOUD OUT THERE
I'M SORRY WAS THERE A REFERENCE
TO THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS -- THE TO THE
AMENDMENTS THE RECOMMEND RIGHT
IT WILL BE PROCESSED IN BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS THAT START THANK
YOU.
GEORGE MILLER MEMBERS ON BEHALF
ASHFORD UNIVERSITY PUZZLE AS
AMENDED THANK -- DAVID VICE WITH
ASHER COLLEGE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
ON'T MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
APOLOGIES I GOT HERE LATE --
WERE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT ALEX
TORE AS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
HE WAS CHAIRMAN OF JUST QUESTION
FOR US.
THE AUTHOR DOES 50% WELL YOU ARE
YOU ACCEPTING THE MAN I AM 50%
OF TWO FROM TUITION REVENUE
GOING TO FINISH.
DEDICATED TO NUTRITION ANY SENSE
OF WHAT THAT METRIC IS NOW FOR
MOST SCHOOLS I MEAN THAT THAT
STRIKES ME LOW LOW ACTUALLY.
YEAH I'VE I'VE JUST GOT TO
BECAUSE THAT'S BASED ON WHAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE MANDATE IS IS 50% IT'S
TO TOWARDS TEACHER SALARIES WERE
AND SO WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
WHAT THAT DEFINITION LOOKS LIKE
BUT IT'S YEAH IT'S 50% YOU'D BE
LIKE IT'S BE HIGHER.
YEAH IT WAS STUDENTS SUCTION
MEANING TEACHER YEAR CURRENTLY
DEFINED AS TEACHER SALARY.
THE THAT'S WHAT THE
COMMUNICATIVE DOES THAT'S WHAT
WE STILL NEED TO WORK OUT LIKE
WHAT EXACTLY THAT MEANS.
FOR DIRECTLY TO TO STUDENTS BUT
OTHER TUITION YES THERE'S MY
VISION AND NOT APPROACHES TO SUB
TODAY SPECIAL GUEST STAR AND
MANY RIGHT -- IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME IS LOW IF WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS WHETHER OR NOT -- TO
WHEN HE WITNESSES TESTIMONY
ABOUT YOU KNOW WALL STREET
PROFITS AND ALL THAT KIND OF
STUFF.
YOU KNOW 50% GONE THE CLASSROOM
50% GONE SOMEWHERE ELSE I DON'T
THINK IT'S WHAT WHAT WHAT WE
INTENDED TO DO SO -- JUST -- MY
TWO CENTS -- AND IT'S A VERY
GOOD INVESTMENT FOR SHAREHOLDERS.
THAT'S NOT THIS DEATH AT THE NOW
THAT NOW IS A NO.
NO AND YOU KNOW I THERE'S A
THERE'S A HOST OF BILLS HERE
TODAY THERE'S A LONG AGENDA I
WANNA EDITORIALIZE TOO MUCH BUT
WE KNOW WHAT THIS PROBLEM IS WE
NEED TO SOLVE IT -- THIS IS
TAXPAYER MONEY EARNED BY PEOPLE.
IN THE MOST CASES SERVING OUR
NATION -- THIS IS NOT TO BE
EXPLOITED THIS IS NOT TO BE TO
MAKE A PROFIT OFF OF THREE THEIR
**** INSTITUTIONS TO STEP UP AND
DO MORE FOR VETERANS -- VIOLENCE
IN THIS PROFIT CENTERS -- I
APPRECIATE THE ROLE IT SENATORS
PLAYED -- IN ADVOCATING FOR THIS
LEGISLATION VERTICALLY MY ALMA
MATER UNIVERSITY SAN DIEGO WHICH
IS NOT CHEAP TO ATTEND BUT IS
ALSO NOT A FOR PROFIT.
ENTERPRISE -- IN TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE ARE.
SITUATIONS WHERE WE HAVE OF
ATTORNEY VETERANS WHO CAN'T
ACCESS MORE TRADITIONAL PRIVATE
NONPROFIT -- A NON NONPROFIT --
EARNING SITUATIONS WHAT WE NEED
TO REALLY ENCOURAGE US
INSTITUTIONS A STEP UP AND SERVE --
THE STUDENTS IN A IN WERE NOT
TRADITIONAL SETTINGS CERTAINLY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE TESTIMONY OF
PEOPLE MANY OF WHOM ARE FROM SAN
DIEGO REFERENCING THEY CAN'T
NECESSARILY ATTENDANT ON A ONE A
MORE NORMAL FORMAT -- BUT THE
EXCUSE FOR THAT IS NOT TO TURN
THEM INTO A SHAREHOLDERS PROFIT
THE THE THE CHALLENGE OUGHT TO
BE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR CS
USE UC'S AND FOR PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE ONE I
GRADUATE FROM TO FIGURE IT OUT --
AND NOT TO TURN THESE PEOPLE
INTO PAYCHECKS FOR FOR THE FOLKS
UP I PLEASURE OUT OF ACTIVISM ON
THIS I'D ASK YOU TO ADD ME AS A
CO AUTHOR IF YOU'D BE SO WILLING --
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
MISTER GABER.
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I JUST
WANNA PLUG THE AUTHOR I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BILL APPRECIATE
YOU -- JUMP JUMPING IN TACKLING
THIS ISSUE -- PLEASED TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY JUST HAD ONE QUESTION I
I THINK IT'S I THINK I'M REGULAR
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I'M --
ACCURATE IN YOU SAID THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE ONLY THING THEY GAVE ME A
LITTLE BIT OF PAS ABOUT THIS
BILL WAS.
THE RETROACTIVITY PROVISION
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I
GENERALLY GET A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS WITH ACROSS THE BOARD
ANSWER JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM
THAT MOVING FORWARD THAT'S BEEN
REMOVED THAT HAS OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS SEGMENT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK ON THIS I THINK IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE IT
IT IS ROLLING ACROSS OUR NATION.
AND IS CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS --
AGAIN IT IS OUR JOB TO PROTECT
TAXPAYERS TO PROTECT OUR
VETERANS AND TO ENCOURAGE OTHER
TYPES OF INSTITUTIONS A STEP UP
IN SERVICE.
I'M VERY GLAD MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HAS A STRONG VETERANS --
CENTER -- BUT MORE AND MORE
ACROSS THE STATE ARE THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS WITHIN
OUR COMMUNICATIONS WITH IN OUR
AT NOT NONPROFITS AND WITHIN OUR
SEE ISSUE SYSTEM.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS OUT
THERE FOR PEOPLE TO GET EDUCATED.
AGAIN WE WOULD ARGUE THIS IS IT
DEFINITE SUPPORT OF VETERANS IT
IS SAYING SHAREHOLDERS YOU
SHOULD NOT BE MAKING A 100% OF
YOUR MONEY ON THE BACKS OF
TAXPAYERS LEAVING VETERANS WITH
A HUGE AMOUNT OF DEBT.
IF THEY ARE GREAT COLLEGES THAN
50% WOULD LET THE MARKET DICTATE
IF NOT THEN 50% OF THAT OF THEIR
TUITION SHOULD GO TOWARD STUDENT
SERVICES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND BEFORE I ASKS -- THOSE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL I
WANT TO SAY THAT THE VETERANS
AND OTHER SERVICE MEMBERS OF HAD
A HISTORY OF BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE.
OF FOR THEIR BENEFITS -- AND
SUPER THE SUPPORT THAT I'VE SEEN
HERE FROM VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS
TELLS ME ALL I NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS BILL.
THE AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED BY
THE COMMITTEE WILL AGAIN BE
PROCESS IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR EGGMAN FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
WE HAD A MOTION BY MS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER SECOND BY MISTER LOWE
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN KILEY.
MR KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
SANTIAGO WEBER. FIVE ZERO WE
WILL LEAVE THAT -- OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT ITEM TO MISTER BRYANT
THIS.
USE THE PRESSURE
.
YEAH SECOND OKAY.
OF THE MOTION AND SECOND -- BY.
A GONZALEZ -- AND LOW.
GO AHEAD TO MAKE A PRESENTATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY ON
AB.
SEVEN TEN POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS HAVE NO STANDARD
SYSTEM WIDE PROCESS FOR
CALCULATING A STUDENTS OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING COSTS COLLEGES
HAVE CONSIDERABLE DISCRETION
OVER HOW THEY MEASURE EACH TYPE
ACOSTA COMP COMPRISES THE COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
STUDENTS OFTEN FIND OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING COST ESTIMATES IN
ACCURATE LEAVING STUDENTS WITHIN
AN ACCURATE PICTURE OF THE REAL
PRICE TAG FOR THEIR COLLEGE
DREAMS FOR CURRENT AND
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS IN ACCURATE
ESTIMATES CANNOT ONLY THROW OFF
THE STUDENTS BUDGETING BUT ALSO
THEIR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES.
NO PART IN A STUDENTS BUDGET BUT
MANY STUDENTS FIND THEIR BUDGETS
DRASTICALLY REDUCED OR END UP
TAKING MORE LOANS IN NEEDED. ONE
WHEN ESTIMATES ARE INACCURATE
THEY DO NOT ONLY DETERMINE THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL AID
A STUDENT CAN GET THE CRATES
UNANTICIPATED EXPENSES DUE TO AN
ACCURATE HOUSING DATA THAT CAN
BE COMPRISED.
COMPRISES STUDENTS STUDIES
FORCING THEM TO TAKE ON MORE
PART TIME WORK OR ENCOUNTER
HOUSING AND FOOD AND SECURITY
AND AN INABILITY TO FOR
TEXTBOOKS.
STUDENTS WITH FEWER RESOURCES
WERE ALREADY STRUGGLE TO AFFORD
COLLEGE SHOULD NOT ENCOUNTER
SYSTEM THAT MIS CALCULATES
HOUSING COSTS.
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO USE ACCURATE DATA THAT
REFLECTS THE ONGOING HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND THEIR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
AB SEVEN TEN SIX TO ENSURE THAT
WE DO NOT UNDERESTIMATE OR
OVERESTIMATE COLLEGE COST WHICH
CAN MEAN A DIFFERENCE OF A
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
PERSPECTIVE IN CURRENT STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES DESERVE TO
HAVE AN ACCURATE INFORMATION SO
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT COLLEGES
AT ALL STAGES OF THE PROCESS.
AB SEVEN TEN WILL ENSURE
INSTITUTIONS USE THE FAIR MARKET
RENT DOCUMENTATION SYSTEM FROM
THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
DATA TO STANDARDIZE THE OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING COSTS FOR
STUDENTS.
THIS DATA ALREADY EXIST IN
PUBLICLYAND IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AND MORE ACCURATELY
PORTRAYS THE COST OF HOUSING IN
THE COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING A
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY.
AB SEVEN TEN WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS TRUST OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND THEIR COSTA
LEVINE ESTIMATES WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS CHAIRED TO RUSSO FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
I AND GARAK BILL HIM A STATE A
STUDENT AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND ALSO CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON OMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND SHARE MEDINA MY NAME IS
DEREK WILL HOME AND I AM A
GRADUATING SENIOR IN
COMMUNICATION STUDIES AND FUTURE
MASTER STUDENT AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
ALSO SERVICE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
I THINK I MET SOMEONE MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR AUTHORING A. B.
SEVEN TEN A BILL CO SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
FACING A COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS.
AS SUCCESSFUL AS WE BEEN HOLDING
OFF TUITION INCREASES WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT AGAINSTTHE
INCREASING COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS WORKING WITH
OTHER STATEWIDE COLLEGE STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS TO JOIN EVERY
STUDENT VOICE IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THE NEED FOR REFORM AND
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE AID
SYSTEM.
CENTRAL TO THE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM IS A FEDERALLY REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE CALLED THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
CUSTER TENANTS IS ACTUALLY A
MISNOMER THAT REALLY MEANS THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL AID
THAT A STUDENT CAN RECEIVE
ATTENDING THAT COLLEGE.
MUCH OF THIS FORMULA INCLUDES
COST SEVEN INSTITUTION LIKE
TUITION FEES BUT OTHERS ARE NOT.
LIKE HOUSING AND FOOD.
THESE NUMBERS ARE ESTIMATES AND
HAD NO SET FORMULA OR STANDARD.
IN MANY CASES THESE NUMBERS WERE
SET OVER A DECADE AGO UNDER
ADJUSTED EVERY YEAR.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THOSE
FIGURES WE FIND A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
BASED ON RESEARCH BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER SERVICES GOES THE MOST
EXPENSIVE COUNTY IN THE STATE
WITH AVERAGE HOUSING COSTS OF
ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH.
WELL CENTERS GO STATE CASA
ATTENDANCE ALLOWS A MAXIMUM OF
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH. FOR
HOUSING AND FOOD.
I LIVE IN A HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
SQUARE FOOT APARTMENT IN THE
TENDERLOIN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
RIGHT PAID FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH FOR RENT.
THIS LEADS ME SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS
LEFT FOR FOOD FORCING ME TO RELY
ON SOCIAL SERVICES AND SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS. EIGHT OTHER CSU
CAMPUSES IN LESS EXPENSIVE
MARKETS ALL HAVE THE EXACT SAME
COST OF ATTENDANCE NUMBERS.
HOW IS THIS AN ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT IF THOSE STUDENTS ARE
PAYING FOUR HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS?
PER MONTH FOR HOUSING ON AVERAGE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FEDERAL
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
FAIR MARKET RATE HOUSING FIGURES
FOR EFFICIENCY UNIT?
WE FIND THAT NINETEEN OF THE
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
UNDERESTIMATE THEIR COST FIGURES
BY TWO THOUSAND TO EIGHT
IN MY EDUCATION I'VE LEARNED.
THAT THE VA EVERY SYSTEM IS
PERFECTLY DESIGNED TO GET THE
RESULTS THAT IT ACHIEVES.
THE RESULT HERE THAT WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC A STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
AND MOUNTING OBSTACLES TO
COMPLETING AN EDUCATION.
MANY STUDENTS COME TO SERVICES
GO STATE FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE NOT REALIZING HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS.
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS THE
FINANCIAL AID ADMINISTRATORS
GIVE THEM.
THE RESULT IS THAT THEY FEEL
BETRAYED AND DISEMPOWERED BY
OBSTACLES THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH THEIR COURSE WORK.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT GET HELP
FROM FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE
THEY'RE SET EXPENSES EACH MONTH
EXCEED THE CAMPUS MAXIMUM.
THE STANDARDIZATION OF THESE
NUMBERS ONE POWER MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS AND NOT COST ONE DOLLAR
AND BUDGET EXPENDITURES.
MY RETURN TO MY EDUCATION BEEN
AND REACHING AND REWARDING
EXPERIENCE THAT I'M AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR THE MATURITY I HAVE.
TO HANDLE ALL THE SACRIFICES THE
STUDENTS TODAY ARE ASKED TO MAKE.
I COULDN'T EVEN BALANCE A
CHECKBOOK IN NINETEEN I DON'T
KNOW HOW THESE STUDENTS TODAY DO
IT.
HOWEVER THE YOUTH OF TODAY
REPRESENT OUR FUTURE.
THE MORE WE INVEST IN HELPING
THEM REBUILD REALIZE THEIR
INHERENT POTENTIAL.
THE MORE CAPACITY THEY WILL HAVE
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA AN EVEN
BETTER PLACE TO LIVE.
WE BELIEVE AB SEVEN TEN IS AN
IMPORTANT UNNECESSARY FORMED OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible] SEVEN WITNESS
[inaudible]
YEAH QUESTIONS [inaudible]
DID YOU.
ANY ANY US OUR SUPPORT.
WITNESSES [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
MISS.
FROM THE PUBLIC [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS OF FROM THE TIRES
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NO QUESTIONS CLOSING STATEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- CLERK
WHEN YOU A STATE
THE MOTION.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ROTH MEDINA.
CHOI.
CHOI I GLORIA BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN I KILEY
GONZALEZ?
IN THE
ELEVEN OKAY.
MR LOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS -- ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO ASSUME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW.
SECOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS AB
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH FROM
STIPULATES THE SALE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES BE APPROVED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE
TRANSPARENCY AND CANDIDLY
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
OKAY ANY -- SUPPORT THE
WITNESSES [inaudible]
OKAY.
CANNABIS OUR BEHALF CALIFORNIA
LOGIN CONSUMER COLLISION.
QUICK AS QUICK [inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL I JUST OF HIGH TO ME --
FROM HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT SIR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW -- BUT I'M NOT HERE
NECESSARILY IN THAT CAPACITY SO
MUCH IS WHAT BRINGS ME TODAY IS
MY TIME BEFORE I WAS A PROFESSOR.
I WAS A DISTINCT HONOR BEING A
OFFICER IN UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS I LET MARINES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- I CAN'T PENDLETON
AND ALSO -- FOR ABOUT A YEAR
WHILE DEPLOYED TO IRAQ MOST MY
TIME WAS IN FALLUJAH.
AND IN WHEN I DID BECOME A
PROFESSOR UST I STARTED A
VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TYPICALLY
FOCUSED ON ASSISTING VETERANS
WHO HAD BEEN HARMED BY FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS.
SO IF YOU LET THAT SINK IN FOR
SECOND WE HAD SUCH A PROBLEM
WITH VETERANS WHO WERE BEING
ESSENTIALLY SCANNED OTHER GI
BILL BENEFITS BY FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS THAT WE HAD TO START AN
ENTIRE CLINIC -- I WRITE THE
HISTORY OF OF JUST SEEING OF NON
PROFITS SCHOOLS BY.
BYE BYE FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS
IS -- IS IS BEEN VERY TROUBLING --
HOW?
IT SPECIFICALLY IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OVER THE COURSE OF
TIME WE'VE HAD -- WE'VE HAD
SCHOOLS SUCH AS HE'LL BEING
PURCHASED WE'VE HAD SCHOOLS SUCH
AS ARGOSY PURCHASING -- LAW
SCHOOL SOME SOMEBODY BEEN AROUND
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME AND ARE
NOW AT THIS POINT -- ESSENTIALLY
ASLEEP SO MOVING TRAIN WRECK
THAT'S GOING ULTIMATELY END UP --
PROBABLY WITH A SCHOOL BEING
CLOSED DOWN.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL
THAT'S GOING TO ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
REVIEW THE PURCHASE OF THESE
TYPES OF SCHOOLS AND ENSURE THAT.
THE COMMUNITY BROADLY THAT
STUDENTS TAXPAYERS ARE PROTECTED
AND THEREFORE IN MY CAPACITY AS
MANAGING ATTORNEY THE BETTORS
CLINIC I SUPPORT BILL AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO AS
WELL THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CASINO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY WINNERS.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO NO
OKAY AND NO TWEETERS.
OUT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED -- AND I THINK WE'VE
HEARD TODAY THAT MUCH TESTIMONY
FROM VETERANS AND FOR THE NEED
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
SO I THINK THE AUTHOR WE HAD A
MOTION BY.
MS GONZALEZ A SECOND BY.
THIS -- WHEN AND MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN I HIGHLY
GONZALEZ?
GONZALEZ I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
SANTIAGO WEBER. FIVE ZERO WE
WILL KEEP THAT -- TO KEEP THE
BILL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE WILL GO TO ITEM FORTY
TEAM[inaudible]
MISTER MCCARTY.
AG [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THOSE IN HERE DIFFERENT IN ONE
TWENTY SIX YES.
FIRST OF ALL I GET THANK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH US ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN PROTECT.
OUR STUDENTS IN THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY THEY WANT --
TO FIRST OF ALL EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINE THE
ANALYSIS.
SO THIS MEASURE WOULD CLOSE THE
LOOP HOLES ON THE SENSUALLY THE
KICKBACKS INCENTIVES THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE FOR
PROFIT COLLEGE IN HISTORY.
ALMOST EVERY MAJOR SCANDAL
INVOLVING FOR PROFIT COLLEGES.
STARTED WITH THEIR SO CALLED
RECRUITERS THESE RECRUITERS ARE
RELIGIOUS HIGH PRESSURE SALES
PEOPLE THINK OF THE BOILER ROOM
THE MOVIE THE BOILER ROOM.
THEY GET PAID BY THIS BY THE
NUMBER OF BODIES THEY PUT IN
SEATS I WHISTLE BLOWERS WERE
PART OF THE AG COMPLAINT AGAINST
ASHFORD UNIVERSITY.
TALKED ABOUT THESE TYPE OF
BOILER ROOM TACTICS AND SOME OF
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE SALES TAX
ACT AS THEY'VE EVER SEEN.
OTHER RECRUITERS WHO WORKED FOR
THE FOR PROFIT EVEREST COLLEGE
RECORDED SAYING THEY WERE LAID
OFF FOR FIELD FOR FAILING TO
MEET THE ENROLLMENT QUOTAS.
AND THE BOMB SO THEY GOT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER EVERY A
DOZEN OR SO STUDENTS THEN ROLLED
OUT WORSE.
OF COURSE IS THESE COLLEGES ARE
PUBLICLY FUNDED -- ENTITIES WITH
OUR TAX DOLLARS FOR FINANCIAL
AID.
SO IN IN ESSENCE -- OUR TAX
DOLLARS ARE AT RISK.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE GETTING THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK --
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE SADDAM WITH
A LOT OF DEBT AND NOT A LOT OF
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
AND THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WOULD FOCUS ON THE
HARSH RECRUITING TACTICS OF
THESE ENTITIES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT STUDENTS GOING
FORWARD -- WITH ME ARE TWO
WITNESSES TO OUTLINE -- THIS
ISSUE -- BOB.
MUSIC EXCUSE ME AND STEPHANIE
SAIFUL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
STIEFEL I SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AS
A VETERAN AND A FORMER STUDENT
OF A FOR PROFIT COLLEGE.
WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD I
WAS ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTH FLORIDA IN TAMPA?
WHILE AT A ON CAMPUS CAREER FAIR
I WAS RECRUITED BY -- RECRUITERS
FROM INTERNATIONAL ACADEMY OF
DESIGN AND TECHNOLOGY.
I SPOKE TO THOSE COUNSELORS
ABOUT MONEY -- OBSTACLES
ATTENDING THE LARGE UNIVERSITY
LARGE CLASS SIZES -- BEING A
SMALL FISH IN A BIG CITY KIND OF
THING.
AND LATER I BEGAN THE PROCESS OF
THOUGHT DURING THEIR SCHOOL AND
SPEAKING FURTHERMORE WITH THEM --
THE COUNSELORS MADE THE PROGRAM
I ADT VERY APPEALING TO ME THEY
TOLD ME THAT THE SCHOOL HAD A
COUNSELING SERVICE THAT PROMISE --
INTERNSHIPS OR JOB PLACEMENT
ASSISTANCE -- LUCRATIVE CAREERS
AND DESIGN.
AT THAT POINT I WAS VERY
INTERESTED AND I DECIDED TO
ATTEND IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE I TRANSFERRED
FROM U. S. F. TO IT TEAM.
I STARTED TAKING MY CLASSES AND
IT FELT LIKE THEY WERE JUST A
CHECK IN THE BOX.
I WAS NOT TRAINED ON SOME OF THE
ADVANCED SOFTWARE THAT WAS
NEEDED FOR CERTAIN PROJECTS THAT
WERE ASSIGNED TO ME I WAS GIVEN
MINIMAL INSTRUCTION.
AND IT DID NOT MATTER IF THE
WORK THAT I DID MYSELF AM IN
COMPARISON TO MY PEERS WAS
AVERAGE OR STELLAR WE ALL
RECEIVED THE SAME GRADE.
THERE WERE TIMES I WOULD RECEIVE
A TEST BACK WE COMPARE WITH MY
FELLOW STUDENTS I WOULD HAVE AN
ANSWER MARK INCORRECT.
AND A FELLOW STUDENT WOULD HAVE
THE SAME ANSWER MARCH CORRECT.
AFTER A YEAR OF APPLYING FOR
DESIGN SCHOOLS AFTER COMPLETING
MY DEGREE.
I ADT.
I WAS FORCED TO TAKE ON SEVERAL
JOBS TO MAKE ENDS MEET --
EVENTUALLY LEADING ME TO JOIN
THE MILITARY.
I JOINED THE MILITARY WITH THE
INCENTIVE OF HAVING MY LOANS
PAID BACK.
AFTER.
COMPLETING ALL OF MY TRAINING AS
A CANINE MILITARY POLICE OFFICER.
I WENT TO THE PROPER PEOPLE TO
HAVE MY LOANS PAID BACK AND WAS
TOLD I DID NOT QUALIFY BECAUSE
OF THEIR CREDIT ATION OF THE
SCHOOL.
AT THIS POINT I ALSO REALIZE
THAT THE SCHOOL WAS BEING CLOSED
DOWN.
MY CREDITS WOULD NEVER
TRANSFERRED TO ANYWHERE EVEN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AT THIS TIME I ALSO WAS PAYING
BACK STUDENT LOANS. TO THIS DAY
I HAVE PAID OVER SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BACK TO THESE
LOANS.
I LIKE I SAID HAVE A DEGREE THAT
IS ESSENTIALLY A PIECE OF PAPER
I CANNOT TRANSFER ANY CREDITS OR
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION.
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE PAID OVER
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS I
STILL -- OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I SPEAK TO YOU IN HOPES THAT YOU
PASS THIS BILL SO THAT THIS CAN
NEVER HAPPEN TO ANOTHER STUDENT
OR ANOTHER VETERAN AGAIN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MY NUMBER SIR
UNFORTUNATELY STEPHANIE'S STORY
IS IS ALL TOO COMMON ME.
SINCE WE FOUNDED THE CLINIC IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WE HAVE
REPRESENTED LITERALLY HUNDREDS
OF VETERANS WHO HAVE BEEN
SCAMMED -- BY FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS -- THERE'S TWO MAIN
TIME FRAMES WHEN THE MISCHIEF
OCCURS ONE IS DURING THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS AND ONE IS
AFTER A MOMENT IN THIS BILL WILL
SQUARELY ADDRESSED SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAPPENED DURING THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS.
MY CLIENTS REPORT TO ME ALMOST
UNIFORMLY -- THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO HIGH PRESSURE SALES
TACTICS THAT INCLUDES DOZENS OF
UNSOLICITED PHONE CALLS EMAILS
LETTERS I'VE HAD CLIENTS WHO HAD
RECRUITER SHOP AT THEIR HOUSES.
SHOP AT THEIR PLACE OF BUSINESS
TRYING TO GET THEM TO A ROLE IN
THE SCHOOLS.
AND THEY'VE BEEN LIED TO ABOUT
ALMOST EVERYTHING YOU COULD
POSSIBLY IMAGINE BEING LIED TO
WITH RESPECT TO A PROGRAM.
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD -- MIS
INFORMATION WITH RESPECT TO JOB
PLACEMENT RATES.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ATTENDING AN ACCREDITED
SCHOOL THE TOTAL LENGTH OF TIME
OF THE PROGRAM THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE
INSTRUCTORS AND THE MATERIAL
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE UTILIZING.
I'VE EVEN HAD THAT EARNS WHO
BEEN MISLED AS TO WHETHER THE
SCHOOL COULD HAVE REASONABLY
ACCOMMODATE THEIR SERIOUS
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITIES.
AND I THINK THE CRUX OF THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE FOR PROFIT
SCHOOL MODEL HAS INCENTIVIZED
BAD BEHAVIOR BY RECRUITERS.
WHEN THE COMPENSATION AND
VARIOUS AND SUNDRY OTHER RELATED
ASPECTS OF THEIR?
WOMEN ARE TIED TO HOW MANY
STUDENTS CAN BE ENROLLED.
BY THAT INDIVIDUAL RECRUITER
IT'S ALMOST INEVITABLE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE PROBLEMS IN
SO I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL GO
UP AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE LESS
VETERANS WERE SEEKING OUR
SYSTEMS DOWN THE ROAD.
I SUPPORT THE BILL IN AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AT OUR CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE AMITY FOUNDATION IN
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DANIEL CAN ACCOUNTS ARE ABOUT
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
RAYMOND CURTIS WITH VETERANS
EDUCATION SUCCESS IN SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN SAN DIEGO RESIDENT NAVY
VETERAN AND A FORMER MILITARY
OUR MILITARY ADVISER NOT FOR
UNIVERSITY ESPORTS.
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
IN SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
ST MARTIN DEAL OF CONSUMER
PRETEND TO LEAVE BUT SHE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SUBMIT HER SMART.
BOB SIMON WITH THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
I WILL GET ON WITH THE DOWNING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING AMITY
FOUND AMITY FOUNDATION IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
JUST HOW TO ME -- FROM HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- I'M SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
IT IS ALWAYS GOOD COMING IN
AFTER ABOUT SEVENTY PEOPLE HAVE
COME IN BEFORE ME.
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE --
MY NAME'S KIDS ACRONYM A PARTNER
OF TWIN MORRIS AND I'M GENERAL
COUNSEL THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS.
I I SPECIALIZED IN LAW OF
PRIVATE COLLEGES -- AND IN A
FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED WITH THE
C. PPV THE THE PPV.
THE BPP AND WAS INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
THAT LED TO THE ENACTMENT OF THE
CURRENT ACT.
OF THE THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY IS
A A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM.
I'D RESPECT WE SUGGESTED TO BE
BAD POLICY AND DESTRUCTIVE.
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL ARE
BASING THEIR ARGUMENTS ON SOME
INACCURATE FACTUAL PREMISES I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF.
FIRST CALIFORNIA LAW AND IN THE
ARTEDUCATION CODE NINETY FOUR
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN ALREADY
PROHIBITS COMMISSIONING.
SO THAT'S THE EXISTING LAW
WITHIN OUR EXCEPTIONS PROGRAMS
LESS THAN NINETY DAYS.
ABLE ONLY AFTER COMPLETION AND
FOR ANY EXCEPTIONS PROVIDER IN
THE FEDERAL LAW WITCHER
EXCEPTIONALLY NARROW.
IN BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
PROHIBITS PROVIDING ANY GIVE TO
A STUDENT THAT IN CASH.
AND LIMITS ANY GIFTS TO
EXTREMELY NET VERY SMALL NOMINAL
AMOUNTS IN NON CASH.
KNOW THAT THE BILL'S AUTHOR
CLAIMS THAT IN ALMOST EVERY
ABUSE I'M QUOTING HERE.
BY THE HIGHEST PROFILE FOR
PROFITS ORIGINATES WITH HIGH
PRESSURE SALES TACTICS MOTIVATED
BY BOUNTIES PAY THE SALES PEOPLE
FROM ROLLING STUDENTS.
NO MATTER WHETHER THE STUDENT OR
NOT IS PREPARATION IS PREPARED
TO SUCCEED IN SCHOOL.
THIS IS UNTRUE THERE ARE NO
CONDITIONS THERE ARE NO BOUNTIES
THERE ARE NO BONUSES.
AND THEIR EXISTING FEDERAL LAW
NO PERSON INVOLVED IN ANY WAY
WITH ADMISSIONS OR FINANCIAL AID.
NO THE SALARIES INCREASE OR
DECREASED FOR SUCCESS OR FAILURE
IN ADMISSION.
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE AND THE
COMMITTEE REPORT DOESN'T CITE
ANY EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE
ASSERTION. TO MY KNOWLEDGE IT
DOESN'T EXIST.
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF DOING
THIS WORK.
REPRESENTING.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS OVER THE
YEARS I NEVER ONCE SEEN A SCHOOL
FOUND LIABLE. FOR PAYING
COMMISSIONS OF ANY KIND AND I
THINK THAT'LL PROBABLY BE AT
LEAST ONE OF THE ONES TO KNOW.
A POINT OF IMPORTANT INFORMATION
HERE UNDER THE NEW FEDERAL AUDIT
GUIDE IN ACTED LAST YEAR.
THE CPA'S THAT HAVE TO ORDER THE
SCHOOLS FOR COMPLAINTS EVERY
YEAR A REQUIRED TO DO FORENSIC
EXAMINATION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE IS ANY INCENTIVE
COMPENSATION PAID.
DOWN TO THE GENERAL LEDGER DOWN
TO THE PAYROLL AND THEY LOOK
PRETTY HARD IN THE RECORDS WOULD
TEST INDEPENDENTLY OF THE
ABSENCE OF INCENTIVE
COMPENSATION.
SO IT'S JUST NOT TRUE THAT ANY
OF THE SCHOOLS RECENTLY CLOSED
OR SOMETHING CLOSE TO WHILE AGO.
HAD INSTEAD OF A COMMISSION
INSTRUCTOR -- STRUCTURES IT'S
IT'S REALLY A NONEXISTENT
PROBLEM.
THE TWIST OF THE CURRENT BILL.
SINCE THE THE CONDUCT SPOKEN OF
IS LARGELY PROHIBITED BY CURRENT
LAW IS A TWIST THAT PROHIBIT
SCHOOLS FROM TERMINATING THE
EMPLOYEE THE IN THE EMPLOYMENT
ADMISSIONS WRAPS -- WARP
INSTRUCTORS THAT ARE
UNSUCCESSFUL IN DOING YOUR JOB.
NOW THAT THAT THAT SEEMS SILLY
WOULD CREATE -- CLASPING PLEASE
IN THE STATE THE ONLY EMPLOYEES
IN THE STATE TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
OF THAT WOULD KEEP THEIR JOBS NO
MATTER HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE
DOING IT.
NO BUSINESS SHOULD HAVE TO KEEP
AN EMPLOYEE THAT'S NOT COMPETENT.
THIS IS AN ESTABLISHED RIGHT ON
THE TITLE FOR THE NINTH CIRCUIT
APPROVED IT IN THE POT VERSUS
SILICON VALLEY CASE QUITE
SOMETIME AGO.
THINK OF IT LIKE A SMOG STATION
IF IT MAKES SENSE TO BAN
COMMISSIONS THAT MECHANICS GIVE
PEOPLE A PASS WHEN THEIR CARS TO
PASS.
BUT MAKES NO SENSE TO REQUIRE
THAT IN THAT MECHANICS WHO CAN'T
REPAIR CARS SHE KEEP THEIR JOBS.
STATE AM I HEARD IN THE FOLKS
THAT CAME BEFORE ME ABOUT THIS
WAS A BAD ACTS.
MISSIONS WITH THIS BILL DOESN'T
SPEAK TO THAT THE LAW BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE ALREADY
PROHIBIT MISREPRESENTATIONS OF
ANY KIND OF MISSIONS.
IN THE RECENT CLOSURES OF
TERRIBLE ARE NOT ADMISSIONS
ISSUES IN ANY OF THAT
THERE'S JUST NO EVIDENCE NONE
THAT IMMUNIZING EMPLOYEES FROM --
IT PERFORMANCE STANDARDS WOULD
HAVE A BENEFICIAL RESULT.
THE REPORT ALSO REFERS TO ONE
PROVEN ANECDOTES ABOUT SUPPOSE
IT ILL TREATMENT OF ADMISSIONS
RAPS.
IN AN UNEDUCATED ATTORNEY
GENERAL LAWSUIT -- I THINK
MAKING POLICY BY ANECDOTE
PROBABLY ISN'T THE WAY TO
PROCEED ONE FINAL POINT AND THEN
I'LL CONCLUDE HERE ABOUT OTHER
BAD CONSEQUENCES.
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS AND AND I
WOULD ASK YOU TO WRAP IT UP YES
SIR -- FEDERAL LAW PERMITS
SCHOOLS TO CONTRACT WITH SERVICE
ENTITIES TO HELP WITH A VARIETY
OF NON EDUCATIONAL TASKS THEY
CAN BE PAID TO THE PERCENTAGE OF
TUITION RECEIVE THIS CALL
BUNDLED SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD BLOW UP THOSE
PERFECTLY LEGAL AGREEMENTS WHICH
RUN OFFENSIVE AND NOT IMPLICATED
IN ANY MISCONDUCT.
I'D RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE REJECT THE BILL IT'S
BAD POLICY IT'S DESTRUCTIVE AND
WRONG THE PROBLEM WITH SIX TO TO
TO ELIMINATE HAS ALREADY BEEN
OUTLAWED AND IT'S NOTHING NEW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MAP BACK REPRESENTING CAPS IN
OPPOSITION.
FRED JONES REPRESENT THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
RETAINING STUDENTS THE
PRECLUSION ON INCENTIVE PAY FOR
THAT THANK YOU.
I HAVE AN ULTIMA REPRESENTING
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN
CARRINGTON COLLEGE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY.
ANY TWEETERS.
C. NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THIS GUY.
A FOR THE OPPOSITION WITNESS I
I'VE LOST TRACK OF WHERE HE WENT
HE'S A GROCER YES I THINK YOU --
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
YOUR ARGUMENT.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT -- THE SIR
PRACTICES OF THIS BILL IS --
SEEKING A REGULATOR ALREADY --
FORBIDDEN BUT YOU THINK THAT
THIS BILL WOULD WOULD SORT OF GO
A STEP FURTHER AND AND OUTLAW
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS CAN YOU
EXPLAIN A LITTLE MORE WHAT YOU
MEAN BY THAT WHAT KIND OF
LEGITIMATE PRACTICES THIS WITH
INCREDIBLE.
YES SIR THE COMMISSIONING IS
ALREADY ILLEGAL UNDER BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW.
THE THE THE THE PROVISIONS IS
BUILT TO THAT EXTENT ARE
REDUNDANT OF EXISTING LAW AND
HAD NOTHING.
THIS BILL GOES A LITTLE FURTHER
AND TALKED ABOUT.
HAVING IT MAINTAINING EMPLOYMENT
OF PEOPLE BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THEY ENROLL OR IT USES
THE WORD QUOTA IS A LOADED TERM.
BUT BASICALLY IS IS A CIRCUIT
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
THE IDEA I THINK OF OF THE
ADVOCATES IS THAT THE ADMISSIONS
REP SHOULDN'T BE A SHOULD BE
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR JOBS EVEN IF
THEY CAN'T ENROLL STUDENTS.
AND THE IDEA I THINK BEHIND IT
IS THAT.
THE THE FEAR OF LOSING YOUR JOB
CAUSES PEOPLE TO SAY AND DO BAD
THINGS I SUSPECT THAT THE THE
THE THE SHORTHAND WAY TO DO IT.
OBVIOUSLY BAD ACTOR READY MISS
REPRESENTATION ABUSIVE ACTS AND
OTHER ALSO THE DECEPTIVE ACTS
ALREADY ILLEGAL.
BUT MY POINT SIR IS THAT.
A BUSINESS OUGHT TO BE A MISSION
TRIP JOBS TO ENROLL STUDENTS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT OUT THERE
WITH PRESS GANGS PULLING METAL
BARS THE RULING OF THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO ALLOWED
TO ENROLL.
IN THESE LEGITIMATE AND LEGAL
PROGRAMS IT ADMISSIONS REP CAN'T%
SUCCEED IN DOING THAT.
NOT COPIES DO THEIR JOB.
NOW THE IDEA I I THINK OF MY
FRIENDS ON THE OTHER SIDE IS
THAT.
THOSE INCENTIVES ARE BAD AND
THAT THE IF IF THOSE INCENTIVES
ARE ELIMINATED THEY'LL BEHAVE
BETTER.
AND THEREFORE THESE ABUSES WON'T
OCCUR I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND THE BAD CONDUCT IS ALREADY
UNLAWFUL IN OTHER WAYS.
NO BUSINESS SHOULD HAVE TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY CAN'T DO
THEIR JOB -- I I I LOOK IS HARD
AS I COULD AND COULDN'T FIND
ANOTHER CLASS IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD HAVE THAT
KIND OF PROTECTION.
AND THIS WOULD APPLY FOR THOSE
IN ADMISSIONS WRAPS -- THIS
WOULD APPLY TO INSTRUCTORS
PLACEMENT PEOPLE ANYBODY
DOWNLINE ON WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION ANY EMPLOYEE WHO
LOST THEIR JOB WOULD ALMOST
CERTAINLY CLAIM.
THAT THIS WAS THE CAUSE OF IT
BECAUSE A LOT OF STERN AND DRAMA
IN THIS WITHOUT I THINK.
IT ADDING ADDING A LOT OF VALUE
IN A FIND A WAY.
IT'S IT'S IT'S BUILT WITHIN THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL IT GOES
FURTHER THAN EXISTING LAW.
IT'S THE ONLY PART OF THE BILL
WHICH IS NEW OTHER THAN PERHAPS
PROHIBITING THE USE THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTS OKAY SO YOU YOU THINK
IT'S IT'S OKAY -- FOR AS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS YOU ENROLL TO
BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
EMPLOYEES OVERALL -- JOB
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION BUT IT'S
ALREADY ILLEGAL IN IT IT'S
ILLEGITIMATE IF THEY'RE SOMEHOW
COMPENSATION IS TIEDTO THOSE
NUMBERS LIKELY.
ALL THE ADMISSIONS WRAPS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY TO
MIKE TO MY KNOWLEDGE THEY DO
THIS WORK VERY EXTENSIVELY A
STRAIGHT SALARY.
AT THIS POINT THERE'S THERE'S
JUST NO WAY TO PAY PEOPLE AN
INCENTIVE EVEN EVEN THE SOUL
THING LEFT OPEN BY THE BY THE
THE FEDS UNDER THE TITLE.
FOR WHICH WOULD BE PAY
GRADUATION BONUSES ONLY ONE
SCHOOL IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY TO
MY KNOWLEDGE.
DOES THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
AFRAID TO DO IT EVERYONE IS
SWITCH TO STRAIGHT SALARY I'VE
WRITTEN MOST OF THOSE PLANS.
A FOR PEOPLE NOW.
IF IT'S A DIFFERENT THING TO
GIVE PEOPLE A MONETARY INCENTIVE --
SET.
PEOPLE ARE BOUNTY OR OR
COMMISSION ONE OF ITS READY
LEGAL AND WAS ILLEGAL IN THE
MAXINE WATERS ACTED IT'S ILLEGAL
NOW.
IT MISSED RECORDED YOU AGREE
WITH THAT KIND OF
CHARACTERIZATION THE DISTINCTION.
BETWEEN YOU KNOW -- JUST BEING
PART OF YOUR EVALUATION ON THE
ONE HAND AND PROVIDING FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES ON THE OTHER.
I DON'T I THINK THE FACT PATTERN
BACK AND FORTH ARE TAKING OUT A
BIT OUT OF CONTEXT AND I I
BELIEVE THAT SOME OF THE ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ADOPTED.
BUT COMMON ASK MISTER -- CHARMIN
TO HELP US OUT RELATE.
TO THE CONFLICT BETWEEN FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW SURE YES I WOULD
BE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW DEFERS TO THE
FEDERAL IF YOU'RE COMPLYING
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL.
OR SUBJECT TO THE FEDERAL RULE
THAN THE STATE ROLE HAS NO
AFFECT WHAT WE SEEN OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS IS THAT THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY
TOLD SCHOOLS WERE NOT REALLY
GOING TO ENFORCE THIS AND EVEN
IF IT DOES GET ENFORCED WHEN NOT
GONNA FIND YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE HAD A LOT OF VIA A LOT OF
CROSSING COMING REALLY SUPER
CLOSE TO THE LINE PROBABLY
CROSSING THE LINE AND THEN IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THERE
WAS MORE ENFORCEMENT SO IT SO
PART OF THE GOAL OF THIS BILL.
IS A STOP DEFERRING TO THE
FEDERAL IF WE WANT TO ENFORCE
THIS ON OUR OWN IN CALIFORNIA WE
CAN.
DO SO -- AND THAT'S AND THEN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE LOOPHOLES
AND IN THE FEDERAL LAW --
INCLUDING THE BUNDLING PROBLEM
WHICH I'M EMBARRASSED TO SAY I
HAD SOMETHING TO DO WITH
CREATING THAT PROGRAM THAT THAT
LOOPHOLE I DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD
BE A PROBLEM IT HAS PROVEN TO BE
A PROBLEM THAT ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO
BASICALLY HIDE.
THIS -- THESE BOUNTY PAYMENTS IN
THESE PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
PAYMENTS TO COMPANIES THAT ARE --
DAD THAT TO COMPANIES THAT ARE
DOING THE RECRUITING AS WELL AS
SOME OTHER THINGS -- ON QUOTAS --
I I RECENTLY VISITED -- A VERY
AGGRESSIVE FAST GROWING --
ONLINE COLLEGE WHICH HAPPENS TO
BE NONPROFIT SENT A SOUTHERN NEW
HAMPSHIRE UNIVERSITY AND I ASKED
THE PRESIDENT OF THAT UNIVERSITY
DO YOU USE QUOTAS IN YOUR IN
YOUR RECRUITING AND HE SAID.
ACTUALLY I SAID SO IF THERE WAS
A BILL THAT THAT SAID NO QUOTAS --
FOR FOR FOR YOUR ADVISORS YOU
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING WHO ARE
RECRUITING HE SAID I WOULD HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
WE JUDGE OUR EMPLOYEES BASED ON
THE QUALITY OF THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE.
INTERESTED IN ENROLLING IN THE
SCHOOL AND THEIR OTHER NUMERICAL
THINGS YOU CAN HAVE NUMBERS OF
CONTACTS WITH PEOPLE WHO CALL
THE SCHOOL -- THOSE KINDS OF
NUMBERS BUT WHEN YOU CONDITION.
EMPLOYMENT OR HATE OR PAY ON
GETTING THE ACTUAL SALE THAT'S
WHEN YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY TELLING.
YOUR EMPLOYEES OR CONTRACTORS DO
WHATEVER YOU POSSIBLY CAN SAY
WHATEVER YOU NEED TO TO GET THIS
ENROLLMENT AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO PREVENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISTER LOWE YEAH YES I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR --
SPECIFICALLY FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA OF HIGHER
EDUCATION WHETHER OR NOT IT BE
YOU -- WITH.
OUR FORMER AT UC DAVIS
CHANCELLOR OR A NUMBER OF
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES BUT I JUST
APPRECIATE BRING THIS FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE CONCERNS
OF OPPOSITION AS YOU CAN TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND THAT'LL MAKE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OF THE MR -- IF MCCARTY V. LIKE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU I I THINK THIS IS A
VALUE STATEMENT THAT THAT WE
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY ONE THAT UNFORTUNATELY
PREYS UPON STUDENTS POOR
STUDENTS STUDENTS OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR -- WITH
TREMENDOUS STUDENT AT THE END
WITH LIMITED.
JOB PROSPECTS AND HAVING MORE
TRANSPARENT TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE RECRUITING THEM I THINK GO A
LONG WAY TO TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS SADLY RIVAL AND
WE'VE ALREADY ESTABLISHED THAT
YOU EXCEPT IN THE YES THE
AMENDMENTS.
WELL I I WANT TO ECHO MANY OF
THE STATEMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES --
I I WAS -- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATOR RIDE FOR
THIRTY SOME YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW WHERE WORK BY
STUDENTS DID AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
WAS IMPORTANT TO ME AND WHERE
THEY WENT.
AND I HAD HEARD STORIES YOU KNOW
AS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER.
SOME OF THE STORIES THAT MISS
MCCARTY ALLUDED TO ABOUT --
YOUNG.
SPECIALLY A LATINO MALES BEING.
LOOKED FOR AMONG SOME OF THESE --
FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS -- BUT I I
HAD LIMITED INFORMATION AS A
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER -- BUT BUT
BUT TODAY FROM WHAT I HEAR HEAR
FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ACROSS THE NATION EVEN.
I I I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM.
REALLY KIND OF APPALLED BY SOME
OF THE PRACTICES THAT I'M
HEARING ABOUT.
I I I REALLY HAD AN INDIVIDUAL
CALL ME TEX ME YESTERDAY SHE
LATINA WAITRESS.
OF FORMER WAITRESS WORKING IN A
WAREHOUSE IN RIVERSIDE.
AND SHE SAID THAT SHE WANTED.
SHE WAS GOING TO GO BACK TO
BEING A WAITRESS BECAUSE SHE
FELT IT WAS A BETTER JOB.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME SHE HAS TWO
CHILDREN TWO TWO YOUNG KIDS AND
SHE WANTED.
TO ADVANCE YOUR EDUCATION AND SO
SHE HAD PICKED OUT -- A FOR
PROFIT SCHOOL.
A FOR PROFIT SCHOOL.
TO STUDY A MEDICAL CODING.
AND I TEXTED HER BACK.
I TEXTED HER BACK LAST NIGHT BE
CAREFUL.
BE CAREFUL OF WHERE YOU GO
[inaudible]
ASK QUESTIONS.
BUT THAT BE CAREFUL TODAY.
IT SEEMS LIKE.
NOT EVEN STRONG ENOUGH ADVICE --
I'M GLAD I TOLD HER TO BE
CAREFUL AND ASK QUESTIONS
BECAUSE AGAIN.
I AS CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I I DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE PRACTICES
THAT I'VE HEARD HERE.
SO I VERY MUCH THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISTER LOWE.
WE NEED A SECOND.
SECOND BY MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHILE [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KYLIE.
KYLIE NOT VOTING [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
IN DALLAS I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
EVER I FOUR ZERO WE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NEXT.
ITEM -- THIRD TEEN.
THIS FLOWER OKAY AND AND I HOPE
I DID OKAY AND THE NAME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I LIKE HYPHENATED NAMES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO WE ARE AN ITEM THIRTEEN A B..
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BOTH THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO PRESENT A
B. THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
AM I ACCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND IT'S IN THIS BILL
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
CRITICAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD.
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
ONLINE FOR PROFIT OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THE LARGEST SHARE
CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED IN ONLINE
SCHOOLS.
ARE ENROLLED IN FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS IN OTHER STATES.
AND IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLED BUSINESS SECTORS IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY AS WE
HEARD EARLIER FROM MY COLLEAGUE.
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE WORSE
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT OUTCOMES
IN CALIFORNIA BASED DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
THEY SHARE BORROWERS WHO END UP
IN DEFAULT IS ALSO HIRED AT
THESE OUT OF STATE DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS THAN ANY IN
STATE PROVIDERS.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT
HOLD THESE OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AS THOSE IN OUR OWN
STATE SO THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WILL
BRING THOSE OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS IN LINE -- TODAY
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS SUSAN
CURTIS A FORMER STUDENT KAPLAN
UNIVERSITY AND ANGELA PERRY A
POLICY ANALYST WITHTHE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS.
AT HOWARD IS ALSO HERE FROM AND
CHILDREN'S ADVOCATES ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ANGELA PERRY ARE
AND AS I'VE SAID BEFORE I'M A
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS -- WELL SOME HOPE THAT
ONLINE EDUCATION CAN HELP MORE
STUDENTS EARN COLLEGE DEGREES
THE PROMISE OF DISTANCE
EDUCATION ALSO HAS PERILS.
THE CHALLENGES IN ASSESSING
ACADEMIC RIGOR AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES FOR ONLINE PROGRAMS CAN
BE EVEN GREATER THAN THOSE AT
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY OF OVER PRICED
AND POOR QUALITY PROGRAMS
LEAVING STUDENTS WITH DEBTS THEY
CANNOT AFFORD.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN HIGHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS BASED EXCLUSIVELY
ONLINE IN CALIFORNIA -- MOST OF
THESE STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED AT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHERE TUITION IS LOW AND THE
TOPIC THE CREDITS TYPICALLY
TRANSFER TO OTHER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ON A ROLL
ONLINE IN PROGRAMS THAT ARE
LOCATED OUT OF STATE.
AND THE LARGEST SHARE OF THE
STUDENTS ARE IT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES WERE STUDENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY LIKELY TO END UP
WITH DEBT THEY CANNOT REPAY.
THE AVAILABLE DATA SHOW THAT
THERE IS REASON FOR CALIFORNIA
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STUDENTS OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ENROLL
CALIFORNIANS ONLINE HAVE BEEN
WORSE STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT
OUTCOMES THAN TO CALIFORNIA
BASED ONLINE PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
HAD LET HAS LED TO THE CREATION
OF MANY LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER THESE LAWS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY ONLY APPLIED TO
SCHOOLS LOCATED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA NOT SCHOOLS IN
ROLLING CALIFORNIANS BUT IT
BASED ELSE ELSEWHERE.
CALIFORNIA TOOK AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
REQUIRING OUT OF STATE COLLEGES
TO REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
AND TO PROVIDE GREATER
ASSURANCES A FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
STUDENTS WHO SCHOOLS OR PROGRAMS
CLOSED.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
REGISTRATION SYSTEM SUFFERS FROM
THREE KEY FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS.
FIRST THE STATE LACKS THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
REST TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
SECOND THE STATE LACKS THE
AUTHORITY TO REVOKE A SCHOOL'S
REGISTRATION IF WRIST TO
STUDENTS IS IDENTIFIED.
AND THIRD THE SYSTEM LACKS A
COMPLAINT PROCESS MEANING
STUDENTS HAVE NO WAY TO IDENTIFY
ISSUES WITH THE BUREAU DIRECTLY.
ABC THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES BY
REQUIRING OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS TO REPORT WHEN KEY
OCCURRENCES TAKE PLACE THAT
MIGHT SIGNAL RISK TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
IT EMPOWERS THE BEER TO TAKE
ACTION IF THEY DETERMINE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE AT RISK
AND IT CREATES A COMPLAINT
PROCESS FOR STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
THESE ONLINE PROGRAMS.
THESE ARE ESSENTIAL STEPS
FORWARD FOR THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE BUY.
IT NOW ALSO LIKE TO ALLOW SUSAN
TO GIVE HER PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
HI THANK YOU -- AGAIN MY NAME
SUSAN CURTIS I TOO AM A VETERAN
OF THE UNITED STATES ARMY -- CAN
MOVE THIS LITTLE OKAY COKE.
THANK YOU -- I HAD WANTED -- TO
I HAD WANTED TO STUDY PARALEGAL
DEGREE I WAS WORKING WITH A
MAJOR INSURANCE COMPANY WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF CLAIMS THAT.
LITIGATION AND I WAS BASICALLY
ADMINISTRATIVE PROFESSIONAL.
I'M AT THE TIME I WAS
RESEARCHING UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES I WAS RESEARCHING SAINT
MARY'S COLLEGE IN MORAGA.
THEY HAD A PARALEGAL PROGRAM BUT
THE PROGRAM WAS ACTUALLY BEING
PHASED OUT OF THEIR UNIVERSITY --
SO -- NEED TO SAY AFTER SOME
RESEARCH I HAD TO DECIDE TO GO
WITH KAPLAN.
I HAD A SON IN GRADE SCHOOL SO
WORK FAMILY -- I WAS OF THE
ESSENCE INTO BERIC GAINS SOME
EDUCATION.
AROUND -- UNDERSTANDING IN THAT
AREA PARALEGAL STUDIES --
PARTICULARLY WHEN I CONTACTED
KAPLAN UNIVERSITY.
I FOUND IT PROTECTS.
CONCERNING THE NEVER REVIEWED
PREVIOUS COLLEGE TRANSCRIPTS.
AND UPON YOU KNOW IN HINDSIGHT
EVEN THOUGH I DID -- GO TO THE
WHOLE PROCESS THEY NEVER --
REQUIRED.
A PRE REQUISITE FOR EXAMPLE
COLLEGE COMPOSITION.
ARE THEY BASICALLY TAUGHT YOU
HOW TO FRAME WORK IN RIGHT.
BUT IT DIDN'T LEAVE ME WITH THE
SKILLS NECESSARY TO OBTAIN A
POSITION.
IN A LAW OFFICE WHERE I WAS ABLE
TO APPLY.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA LAW TO FOR
EXAMPLE WILL'S TRUST AND ESTATE
PLANNING -- THAT IS ONE ISSUE
THAT I FACED.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS -- THE ONLINE
PLATFORM FOR THE UNIVERSITY WAS
CONSTANTLY CHANGING THERE WERE A
TON OF TECHNICAL ISSUES.
THERE WERE TIMES WHERE I WOULD
TAKE AN EXAM.
IT WOULD PHASE OUT I WOULD FEEL
THE EXAM AND HAVE.
TO GO THROUGH THIS WHOLE ARRAY
OF OF EXPLAINING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THEIR
TECHNOLOGY -- THE OTHER ASPECTS
IS WITH OUR ONLINE LECTURES WE
WERE FORCED TO BUY.
PURCHASE COLLEGE MATERIAL.
THAT THE PROFESSORS WOULD NOT
EVEN LECTURE ON ON A ONE HOUR.
HE YOU KNOW.
EEK IN OAK PARK PLATFORM CAMPUS
OR YOU KNOW -- LECTURE.
SO -- THE OTHER PART OF MY
EXPERIENCE WITH CAPTAIN IS --
THEY MADE IT SEEM THAT.
I WOULD BE ABLE TO FULFILL MY
GOALS AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
PURSUED IN A CAREER IN PARALEGAL
STUDIES BUT IN CALIFORNIA AND
THERE WERE NO INTERNSHIP.
OPPORTUNITIES.
THERE WERE.
A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT WERE
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THAT
YOU WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH -- EVEN YOU KNOW AS
YOU KNOW FORMER STUDENTS SO --
IT REALLY FELT I REALLY FOUND
ABANDONED WITH VERY LITTLE
RESOURCES TO CONNECT IN THE
COMMUNITY TO SAY HEY I HAVE THIS
EDUCATION.
THERE WAS NO NETWORKING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND JUST -- TO JUST TO SUMMARIZE
[inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
I'M GONNA STOP STOP.
THE YEAR.
A PRESENTATION OKAY -- WE'VE
GONE OVER THE FOUR MINUTES
ALLOTTED TO OKAY BOTH SO RIGHT I
THINK I THINK YOU DID A GOOD JOB
OF PRESENTING.
WHAT YOU WANTED SO THANK YOU AND
I'M GONNA CALL FOR OTHER
WITNESSES -- IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OBLIGATED DONNIE WITH
GOOD DONNING THAT SO SEE IT'S
HERE REPRESENTING THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS THE AMITY
FOUNDATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
DANIEL CAN OKAY AS HER BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL B. TERRACE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JUST A PART OF ME -- ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
TWEETERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MISTER CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR OF IT IMPRINTS
PER.
WOULD SUPPORT THE FEEL.
BUT THE I A WOULD LIKE TO ASK US
SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
IS THIS -- BE A CONCERN NOT OUT
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT.
INSTITUTION [inaudible]
A SOLEMN.
THE SCHOOL.
OPERATING OUT OF STATE AND WOULD
HAVE A BRANCH IN OUR STATE WHAT
DO YOU MEAN.
OUR ONLINE COLLEGES SO THESE ARE
ONLINE INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
BASED OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
ARE SELLING THEIR SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WERE.
CHAINING THESE DEGREES ONLINE
OKAY YEAH THE WAS SO WHAT I WAS --
THINKING IF THAT'S THE CASE AND
HOW WOULD YOU ENFORCE IT FOR A
THE SCHOOL OFFERS DEGREE IN
FLORIDA.
AND ANYBODY CAN AND REWARDED YOU
CANNOT PREVENT THE STUDENTS ARE
FROM ENROLLING.
IN ONLINE COLLEGE OUT OF STATE.
WE ENFORCE OUR LAWS TO ANY --
BUDDY WHO SELLING TO
CALIFORNIANS IN ANYWAY RIGHT SO
YOU KNOW AMAZON CAN'T COMMIT
FRAUD HERE'S ANOTHER BASED IN
SEATTLE BECAUSE THEY SELF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS OF THE SAME
WOULD BE TRUE OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
I AM IN V..
ONLINE DEGREE OFFERING PROGRAM
OR DEVELOPER -- TO ANYONE WHO
HAS SO ONLINE ACCESS SAFE I SIGN
UP.
JUST. FOR MY BENEFIT
[inaudible]
AND THE SCHOOL IN FLORIDA OUT
WOULD HAVE TO RE FUSE A SENSE SO
WE ARE NOT AUTHORIZED. TO TWO OF
ALL FOR THE PROGRAM TO YOU --
WAS A LIVING IN CALIFORNIA WE
CANNOT ACCEPT YOU THEY HAVE TO
REFUSE THAT THE ACCEPTING.
YES TO ADD OUR CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SO -- WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS MAKE IT REALLY CLEAR?
THAT UNLESS YOU REGISTERED.
AND DID ALL THE KINDS OF SELF
REPORTING THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE
BILL.
THEN YOU WOULD BE OFF IF YOU DID
NOT DO THOSE THINGS YOU WOULD BE
OPERATING HERE ILLEGALLY.
NOW.
THE ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GO AFTER PEOPLE WHO DO THINGS
ILLEGALLY.
IT'S REALLY NOT DIFFERENT
WHETHER IT'S AN ONLINE COLLEGE
HEADQUARTERED.
IN SOUTH DAKOTA.
GETS OFFERING THINGS ILLEGALLY
HERE OR IF MY MOM WHO IS NOT A
LAWYER.
DECIDES TO START PRACTICING LAW.
THE REMEDIES THAT THE INTERNET
GENERAL HAS TO STOP THOSE THINGS.
ARE COURT ORDERS IN JUNCTIONS
IT'S THE SAME THING SO WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IS FEAR AN OUT OF
STATE.
COMPANY.
AND A HEADQUARTERS IN WISCONSIN.
AND THROUGH THE WEB YOU'RE
SELLING HERE.
AND YOU'RE NOT REGISTERED.
YOU WOULD BE OPERATING ILLEGALLY.
SOME PEOPLE MAY CHOOSE TO
OPERATE ILLEGALLY BUT IN ORDER
TO CATCH THEM OPERATING
ILLEGALLY SO AFTER A FEW DAYS
UPON THE APPLICANT THAT THEY
HAVE TO READ A SELF MONITOR WITH
HIS -- WITH HIS CHILDREN IS
COMING FROM IT YEAH THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT EXISTING LAW DOES
ALREADY REQUIRE A REGISTRATION
PROCESS THAT IS ALREADY EMBODIED
IN EXISTING LOT THIS WOULD
SIMPLY IMPROVE THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS AND AT SEVERAL KEY
PROTECTIONS TO THE EXISTING
REGISTRATION PROCESS.
BUT IT THE STATE DOES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CREATE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANY BUSINESS TO
OPERATE AND TO SELL ITS WARES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION IS NO DIFFERENT -- AS
AD AND USED TO THE GREAT LAWYER
EXAMPLE AND YOU HAVE TO BE YOU
HAVE TO BE BARRED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BY THE BAR.
OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA AND SO YOU
DO THERE ARE LOTS OF OTHER AREAS
WHERE THIS IS ALREADY A
REQUIREMENT THERE ARE LOTS OF
PARALLELS.
SO YES THAT'S EXACTLY CORRECT.
AMONG THE FIVE ITEMS SO THEY ARE
I SEE -- ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE -- ON
WHEN THE BUREAU ON NONPROFIT THE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION B. P.
P..
A RECEIVE SO THIS FIVE DOCUMENTS.
CAN THEY MAKE A JUDGMENT THAT
THEY FINANCIAL STABILITY.
WHETHER THAT THE SCHOOL OR
SUSTAIN THOUGH WOULD LOCK WILL
NOT CLOSE NEXT YEAR.
SO RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO
INFORMATION ON THAT PROVIDED --
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE SOME
SELF REPORTING ON ANY ON SEVERAL
INDICATORS OF RED FLAGS PROBLEMS
AT THE SCHOOL WHETHER THEY'RE
UNDER INVESTIGATION WHETHER THEY
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THEIR
ACCREDITATION -- WHETHER THE
STATE OR FEDERAL EDGE AGENCY IS
LOOKING INTO ISSUES AT THE
SCHOOL -- THEIR FINANCIAL THAT
STABILITY SCORE WHICH IS WHICH
IS OF COURSE NOT ONE OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS -- BUT THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL OTHER REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD INDICATE RISK
STUDENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED.
YEAH THESE THESE ARE -- GOOD THE
MANAGER SAID TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDENTS WERE NOT BECOME A
VICTIM THAT ALONE.
BECAUSE I HAD AN EXPERIENCE --
KNOWS SOMEBODY.
THE TWO STUDENTS ARE COMING FROM
I BELIEVE THE NAME WAS A
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL IN.
LOS ANGELES THAT THEY WERE
PURCHASED A PIE HI HERE -- LEVEL
CORPORATION.
AND THE SCHOOL WAS SO GOING VERY
WELL BUT ONE OF THE THE BRANCHES
SELECT ART SCHOOL IF THEY
PURCHASED A LAW SCHOOL WAS DOING
WELL BUT OUR SCHOOL YOUR
FAVORITE DOES SO WELL.
THE MONEY THEY WERE MAKING MORE
MAKING UP BY IN THE COULD NOT
HANDLE THE ENTIRE SITUATION AND
THAT THEY CUT UP.
OF BANKRUPTCY AND THE STUDENTS
IN THE MIDDLE BECAME THE VICTIM
SO THAT'S WHY.
I WONDERED.
WHY NOT TELL YOU IT DID NOT
REQUIRE SPECIFICALLY FINANCIAL --
DOES SOUND SOUNDED NEZ SO OR DID
THE FULL TOWARD.
PROFITABILITY -- YEAH NO I THINK
YOU RAISE AN IMPORTANT POINT
MISTER CHOI AND WE'LL LOOK AT
THAT GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I
THINK IT COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
HELP FURTHER PROTECT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
RIGHT WELL I THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR BRING IN THE BILL FOR THE
AMENDMENT ON PAGE SEVEN WILL BE
PROCESS AND BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. TWO IN A MOTION BY
MISTER LOWE AS SECOND BY MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
MADAM SECRETARY BE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA ALL RIGHT MEDINA I CHILE.
JOY I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KYLIE.
KYLIE I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBBER II. SIX ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND NOW WE'LL GO TO ITEM.
ITEM I I DON'T SEE MR MONTA SO
WE WILL GO TO ALL I'M SORRY.
SORRY.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM EIGHTEEN MISTER
BOND THIS MINISTER CHECK USE ME
EXCUSE ME.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A B.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTIES FOR WHICH IS
A COMMON SENSE BILL.
THAT AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO EXTEND
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
DEADLINES FOR STUDENTS DUE TO
NATURAL DISASTERS.
OR EMERGENCIES.
WE HAD SOME STUDENTS DUE TO THE
WILD FIRES FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID THAT WAS NEEDED
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WE HAD A
38% DECREASE IN FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE OF THAT
DISASTER THIS IS A?
A GOOD POLICY GOING FOR THE
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY FOR THIS DO
NEED COMMISSION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE.
WE HAVE DAVID O'BRIEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HERE WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS WELL AS
KEEM JACKSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
THEY BEGIN.
THANK YOU ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS DAVID O'BRIEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS IS IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REFERENCED A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE.
THAT ALLOWS FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN OUR STATE.
SUCH A THREE DEADLINES FOR
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS WHEN
THERE'S BEEN AN EVENT SUCH AS A
NATURAL DISASTER OR A STATE OF
EMERGENCY SO I MEAN THAT'S OUT
OF THE CONTROL OF THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES.
THAT MAY INHIBIT THEIR ABILITY
TO MEET THE MARCH SECOND
DEADLINE WE HAVE FOR OUR CAL
GRANT AND OTHER STATE FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE COMMISSION TO
EXTEND THE DEADLINE.
BUT AFTER THIRTY DAYS THE EVENT
OF SUCH AN EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCE -- WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT A PRESET THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO LOOK FOR
CONFIRMING THE BILL THANK YOU.
HOW MANY OF SKY JACKSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND AS I
MENTIONED BOTTOM LINE UP FRONT
THIS IS A VERY LOW COST AND
COMMON SENSE APPROACH?
THAT HELPS STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
REMOVE ADMINISTRATIVE BEARS
ACCESS COLLEGE FUNDS DURING A
TIME WHEN THEY ACTUALLY NEEDED
THE MOST.
THE DEPARTMENT SUPPORTS -- SIX
MILLION -- STUDENTS AND FAMILIES --
TO BE READY FOR COLLEGE AND AND
CAREER -- FOR MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES IT'S A FIRST IN
MULTIPLE GENERATION OPPORTUNITY
TO GET INTO COLLEGE AND WE KNOW
THAT FOR THOSE FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS POSTURE IN COLLEGE.
THAT -- FISCAL RESOURCES SHOULD
NOT BE A BARRIER IN
ADMINISTRATIVE BEAR SHOULD NOT
SHUT THE DOOR ON THEM -- AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL HELP
REMOVE THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS TO IN A TIME WHEN THEY
NEEDED AS OUTLINED IN IN THE
BILL AS MENTIONED BY SIMPLY
MEMBER BOND SO WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND WE REQUEST YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF EDUCATION TRUST WESTERN
SUPPORT.
TYLER I DO RB AFTER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IRAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST AND
SUPPORT.
HELLO MAGGIE WHITE WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE A LETTER ON
FILE BUT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
C. NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE -- I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MR BIDEN.
DISTURBANCE BY FAST DRIVER THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE MEASURE FORWARD --
TO AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL.
AID COMMISSION TO POSTPONE
APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR
STUDENTS TO EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES -- DURING -- THE
EMERGENCIES I THINK IT'S A
EXCELLENT BILL -- BEFORE.
WE CALL THE ROLL I NEED A MOTION
FOR URGENCY [inaudible] FOR
URGENCY.
SO WE HAVE A FIRST FOR URGENCY
AS SECOND BY [inaudible]
DR WEBBER.
AND IF VOTING ON THE URGENCY OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
LATEST VOTES ON THE URGENCY
MEDINA MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
LATE GABRIEL -- WHEN?
KYLIE.
KYLIE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I LOW.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBBER I SIX ZERO WE WILL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
NOW DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL.
MOVED BY DR WEBBER SECOND BY
DOCTOR CHOI.
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS DO PASSES
ADOPTED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA. TWO PASSES
AMENDED YES [inaudible]
HI.
MEDINA I CHILE.
I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN?
KYLIE.
KYLIE I CONSOLIDATES.
GONZALEZ I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBBER HI. SIX ZERO WE WILL KEEP
THAT.
WE CAN'T GO ON MATERNITY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M GONNA ASK THE AUTHOR TO TO
STAY FOR A SECOND A MINUTE.
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR A
SECOND.
OKAY.
I WAS GOING SO WELL.
WHAT DID I DO -- JUST TRY TO
KEEP MY HEAD DOWN GET IN AND OUT
FAST.
I SEE EVEN ROOM FOR THROUGH US
REMEMBER ME. TO GO TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
AMAZON [inaudible]
ME.
MORE LET.
EVERYONE THAT WE PRESENTED IS
ONE LESS [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH -- I DON'T THINK IT.
IS HERE.
FOR TWO I HAVE NO IDEA.
YEAH CALL ME LATE LAST NIGHT
.
AND THE USE OF THE
THIS IS
--
ONE STILL ON ONE SIDE
[inaudible]
WE LAST [inaudible]
THIS
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW
THANK YOU EVERYONE'S INDULGENCE
WHILE WE TOOK A BREAK.
I I JUST WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE URGENCY OF THE BILL PASSED
WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE VOTES
HERE PRESENT.
WITH THAT.
WE ARE GONNA TO REVOKED.
ON THE BILL [inaudible]
URGENCY PAST.
URGENCY OF THE BILL IS IS DONE.
WE ARE GONNA REVOTE.
ON ON THE BILL.
ITSELF.
SO WE HAD A MOTION.
ON THE BILL BY.
WHATEVER DR WEBBER SECOND BY.
DOCTOR CHOI AND MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
THAT MOTION TO DO THAT AND THE
MAN TO APPROPRIATION MEDINA HI.
HI.
HI LORI HI LORI HI LORI.
GABRIEL -- WHEN HIGHLY?
IN DOLLARS.
HI LO HARRISON.
YEAH WHETHER HI WEBBER I'D. FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THE BILL WILL BE.
ON CALL.
THANK YOU AND NOW WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM. THREE MR MERRY SUE
G. A. B. [inaudible]
SEVEN TWENTY AND AND MR MERRY
SUJI [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YES PLEASE.
I'M GONNA [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SOME OF THOSE SEVEN TWO ZERO
THIS IS THE MAIL ORDER BY
COLLEGES THROUGHOUT THE DAY AS
WELL AS MY MARK BYERS AND OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WITH ONE OF THE THINGS
[inaudible]
YEAH AFTER.
DO YOU NEED SITUATION BASICALLY
COLLEGES WELL MY STATEMENTS
WRAPAROUND FORMAR HIRES.
NOW MOST OFTEN.
BECAUSE THIS IS ADAM WHAT'S
MOMENTS CORRECTIONAL SERVICE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE MOBILE
PHONES IN THE AGENCY. TO PROVIDE
OVER FIFTEEN IS THAT.
NOW RECEIVE -- TRAINING AND
EDUCATION TO THE HOUSE PROGRAMS.
PETER KNOWING NO NEED VERY LOW
INCOME NOR WORKING.
DOES THIS NEW PLATFORM PROVIDED
FINANCIAL DISINCENTIVE -- WILL --
SAFETY TRAINING PROGRAMS AND IS
ON AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE THERE
FOR ANY.
BOOKS THAT ARE KIND OF WILDFIRES.
THIS IS A FEW MILES FROM THE
CAMP FIRE -- LAST YEAR SO.
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
GRAMS.
I HAVE THE GENERAL SMITH
PRESIDENT.
AS WELL AS SCOTT LOGGING
ASSISTANT.
DIRECTOR OF THE PEACE OFFERINGS
YEAH TRAINING PROGRAM ALSO
AVAILABLE ALL.
RIGHTS.
FOR WELCOME AND JUST A REMINDER
THAT IT'S TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ALL THAT THANK YOU
FOR A LOT TODAY ABOUT EDUCATION.
AND SO I I JUST ONE DAY HE WOULD
OFFER THE WORLD -- CANNON THEY
CALL US BUT ALSO FOR PEOPLE.
IN MY REGION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- CALORIE FREE HOLDS IS.
TO YOU COULD CALL AND ASK FOR
PERMISSION THIS IS YOUR
INSURANCE POLICY BY HAVING OUR
POLICE FIRE.
AND RUSSIA'S LONG STRING TO
OFFER -- FIFTY SEVEN THE STUDENT
CENTER VIA AS OPPOSED -- TO
TRANSFER OAKLEY VISIBLE SO TO
HELP.
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
COMMERCIALS FOR THAT -- IN AS A
DESIGNER FOR THAT TOGETHER --
MAYBE LOOK FOR OTHER THAN THIS.
YOUR CONSEQUENCES FOR EXAMPLE OF
THE WORLD CRUISE THE METRICS.
THEY ALSO WHO LOVE. TO READ IF
YOU SHOULD FIRST THE NETWORK
STILL PREFER THAT.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE ASK OUR
OFFICE IS A LITTLE BIT YEAH.
THIS -- ONE OF THE VEHICLES.
IN EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY IS NOT
FOR INDIA.
AGAINST CRIME FREE CONCERN ABOUT
THE SAFETY OF ALL FORMS --
BECAUSE IT WAS RETURNED.
ARE YOU [inaudible]
VERSION.
OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT THIS TRAINING
IS NEEDED IT IS DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE A BOTH IN TERMS OF
BUREAUCRATIC CHALLENGES BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE WE HAVE.
THE FACILITIES TO TRAINED --
INDIVIDUALS AND THE EQUIPMENT.
BY HAVING AN INSTRUCTIONAL
SERVICE AGREEMENTS THAT IS THAT
THE ONLY VEHICLE THAT WE COULD
BE ABLE TO DO THIS AT THIS GIVEN
TIME.
SO I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A. B.
SEVEN TWENTY I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL VERY TIMELY.
IN A FIVE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK STAFF FOR FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER A BEAUTIFUL -- ANALYSIS --
YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB AND I
THINK IT SPEAKS VOLUMES THAT
THERE'S REALLY NO NEGATIVE
SUPPORT OR NEGATIVE AGAINST THIS
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
FIRST RESPONDERS FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHO JOINED ME
HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
GOVERNMENTS ARE -- GROUP -- YOU
QUICK CABBIE I ACTUALLY
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING I'M HERE
AT THE INVITATION OF GOLDEN WEST
COLLEGE.
A LEATHER THROUGHOUT A FEW OTHER
DISCLAIMERS I I WORK FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH THERE FOR I'M
NOT IN A POSITION TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
BUT I CAN OFFER SOME SOME
TALKING POINTS THAT WILL HELP
ILLUSTRATE.
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE AND
THE ADVANTAGES THAT THAT THE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND POST HALF.
AS OF RESPECT -- OFFERS PUBLIC
SAFETY -- THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA IN THE COMMISSION OF
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING THE THE BASIC ACADEMIES
AND ALL THE TRAINING ENJOYED
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL RELATIONSHIP.
THAT HAS CREATED A STANDARD
WHERE -- HE'S ALSO TRAINING IN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE GOLD
STANDARD.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
AFFORDED BY THIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
SPECIFICALLY TO FOLD.
FIRST OF ALL IT GIVES THOSE
ENTRY LEVEL OFFICERS AND PUBLIC
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN COLLEGE
CREDITS AS THEY MOVE FORWARD IN
THEIR CAREERS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THOSE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENCY -- MONIES ARE F. T.
E.'S.
PROVIDE A SUBSTANTIAL OFFSET TO
THE COSTS FOR A PERSON TO GO
INTO THE BASIC ACADEMY.
SO WITH RESPECT TO THAT
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW IT COSTS A
NON APHELIA CELL SPONSORED
STUDENT ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED MAYBE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GO TO AND ACADEMY.
THERE'S A LOT OF OUR APPLICANTS
THAT PROBABLY DON'T HAVE TWO
NICKELS TO RUB TOGETHER LET
ALONE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THOSE F. T. D.'S FD CERTAINLY DO
OFFSET SOME OF THOSE COSTS.
THE ADVANTAGE OF THAT IT IS
ALLOWS A LOT OF PEOPLE TO COME
INTO THE PROFESSION.
THE REALITY IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS A GATEWAY PROFESSION INTO THE
AMERICAN DREAM WE HAVE -- A LOT
OF FUTURE POLICE OFFICERS AND I
WOULD IMAGINE FIREFIGHTERS THAT
COME FROM.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
DISADVANTAGE FINANCIAL
BACKGROUNDS IN THE CERTAINLY
FORT THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
THAT AMERICAN DREAM AND MOVE
FORWARD AS THEY THEY MOVE
FORWARD INTO THEIR RESPECTIVE
CAREERS.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INVITING ME TO
TESTIFY IN THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IS THAT I'VE READ ON BEHALF ME
COLLEGE LEAGUE ADHERENTS PORT.
THANK YOU TEAR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO ON CURRENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT.
BERRY GRUBIN'S COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN GO TO PRISON CITY
COLLEGE FIRE ACADEMY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TECH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FOR SUPPORT.
HI I'M TOM ROW FROM THE FRONT OF
THE STORM I'M TRAINING MANAGER
AND OUR AGENCY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RON LAURINBURG DEAN OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE TRAINING CENTER
GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
TWO MCGRATH PRESIDENT GOLD WAS
COLLAGEN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR KEVIN TRITON AND
THE SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT FOR
FEATHER RIVER COLLEGE ON BEHALF
OF THE FOUR SERVICE EMPLOYEES
WHO NEED THIS TRAINING OR IN
SUPPORT.
MARK STEVENS REPRESENTING L.
CAMINO COLLEGE IN TORRANCE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DEPUTY JASON MANY RIGHT OFF.
ON BEHALF OF SERVICEMEN PRESENT
ANY SERVICE OFFICE ONCE FOR THE
BILL.
ALEXANDER CELLS IN PRISON K.
SHARES OFFICE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE BY DOCTOR WHEREVER SECOND BY
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
ANY ANY.
AND THERE WERE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- MR MERCY TO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED FOR A
I HAVE A I AM I THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I
WAS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHRISTY.
AT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS WHERE WE HAVE
A VERY SUCCESSFUL FIRE ACADEMY
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ACADEMY.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THESE ARE
TWO COMMUNITIES OF BOTH -- FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIREFIGHTING
SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AND IN FACT THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD -- SECRETARY
READ PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MALINA HI CHARLIE.
CHOI I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
I GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KYLIE [inaudible]
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I LOW
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBBER I SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND NEXT I WILL GO TO ITEM
SEVENTEEN DR WEBBER [inaudible]
THE SECOND.
AND THIS BILL DOES ENJOY SUPPORT
SUPPORT RIGHT.
SO WE'LL BE FREE THAT'S HOW.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING US
AT THIS TIME -- I HAVE SOME.
OF EXPERT WITNESSES HERE WHO
HAVE PLANES TO GET SO I
APPRECIATE THAT -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TODAY I HAVE THE
PLEASURE PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD CHANGE
ACCOUNTING REQUIREMENTS SO THE
CREW DEVELOPMENT IN COLLEGE
PREPARATION NON CREDIT COURSES.
THAT HAVE A DEFINITE DEFINITIVE
END DATE WOULD ALSO ALSO KNOWN
AS MANAGING MOMENT CAN ARE
FUNDED PER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENT BASED ON EXPENSES DATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW NON CREDIT
COURSES INCLUDING NON CREDIT
CAREER DEVELOPMENT AND COLLEGE
PREPARATION COURSES ARE FUNDED
BASED ON A POSITIVE ATTENDANCE.
POSITIVE ATTENDANCE IS BASED ON
ACTUAL COUNTING OF ENROLL
STUDENTS PRESENT AT EACH CLASS
MEETING.
THESE OPEN ENTRY OPEN EXIT
WITHIN EIGHT IT WOULD ENABLE
STUDENTS TO MOVE IN AND OUT OF
CLASSES ON THEIR ABILITY TO
MASTER CERTAIN COURSE MATERIALS.
THIS IS DIFFERENT FROM CREDIT
COURSES COURSES WHICH ARE FUNDED
BASED ON A CENSUS DATE.
MANAGING ROMAN COURSES WHICH
HAVE A DEFINITIVE START AND END
DATE HAVE BECOME MORE THE NORM
FOR CDC P. NONCREDIT COURSES AS
THEY HAVE SHOWN TO INCREASE
STUDENT RETENTION AND SUCCESS.
SEVERAL COLLEGES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED ACADEMIC BENEFIT OF
MANAGING MOMENT COURSES TO
INSTRUCTIONAL RESEARCH.
THESE BENEFITS INCLUDE INCREASED
TO AN ATTENDANCE 43% FOR
MANAGING ROLLED WENT VERSUS 33%
FOR OPEN ENTRY AND OPEN EXIT
COURSES.
THIS WOULD BETTER EQUALIZE
FUNDING FOR NON CREDIT CDC.
SEE THE CP COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED WHAT THEY STARTED IN
DATE MENACING MOMENT BY
AUTHORIZING THE ATTENDANCE OF
THOSE COURSES TO BE TAKEN
ACCORDING TO A CENSUS DATE.
RATHER THAN ON POSITIVE
ATTENDANCE.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WOULD FREE
UP PRECIOUS FACULTY TIMES OF THE
FACULTY CAN BETTER ADDRESS
LEARNING NEEDS OF STUDENTS LEAN
TO EVEN GREATER STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE LATEST SET OF AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIES IT BOTH FACE TO FACE
AND DISTANCE EDUCATION
INSTRUCTIONAL METHODS ARE
INCLUDED.
NONCREDIT DISTANCE COURSES SCORE
EDUCATION IS GAINING MOMENTUM
AND THESE COURSES ARE TYPICALLY
COMPETENCY BASE WITH STEWED
STUDENTS GAINING SKILLS
CERTIFICATION AND COMPETENCIES
WITHIN A SHORT OF SHORT TERM
FLEXIBLE SCHEDULING STRUCTURE.
THE CURRENT ATTENDANCE MODEL
DOES NOT SUPPORT THIS MODE OF
INSTRUCTION INSTRUCTION IF WAS
IMPORTANT CLARIFIED DISTANCE
EDUCATION IS INCLUDED.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THE ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FOR
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN IS
CARLOS -- TEARS FROM THE SAND
HILL COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
AND VALENTINO PURTELL FROM THE
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY CONTINUING
EDUCATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR CARLESS
TURNER CORTEZ THE PRESIDENT OF
SAN DIEGO CONTINUING EDUCATION
JUST TO PROVIDE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION UNLIKE EIGHTY
EIGHT IN THE K. TWELVE SETTING
WHERE YOU CONSTANT ATTENDANCE
ONCE PER DAY.
AND THE A POSITIVE ATTENDANCE
FOR ADULT EDUCATION YOU HAVE TO
COUNT STUDENTS IN FIFTEEN MINUTE
INTERVALS IMAGINE THE WORKLOAD
THAT THAT CREATES FOR FACULTY --
WHEN THE WHEN THE ASSEMBLY OF
SUPPORTED CDC P. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN THEY DID SO IN THE
HOPES THAT WE WOULD EXPAND ESL
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA?
A SHORT TERM INTENSIVE CAREER
EDUCATION FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
AND THE UNDER SERVED UNDER
EDUCATED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT SEEN
AN EXPANSION OF CD C. P. COURSES
OVER THE PAST DECADE BECAUSE OF
THE WAY WE TAKE ATTENDANCE IN
THESE COURSES.
AT THE COLLEGE IS WE TAKE
ATTENDANCE TWICE PER TERM WHICH
ALLOWS INSTRUCTORS TO TEACH A
CURRICULUM THAT SEQUENTIAL.
THE OPEN ENTRY OPEN EXIT MODEL
THAT HISTORICALLY IS
CHARACTERIZED ADULT EDUCATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MEANS
THAT STUDENTS COME AND GO AS
THEY PLEASE.
FROM A PEDAGOGICAL ARE AND
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO PERSPECTIVE
IT'S ALL BUT IMPOSSIBLE TO TEACH
A SET OF SKILLS UNLESS YOU CAN
TEACH SKILLS THAT BUILD UPON
THEMSELVES IN AUTO PROGRAM AT A
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM AT A
COATING PROGRAM.
IN A NURSING PROGRAM THEREFORE
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT A CHANGE IN HOW WE TAKE
ATTENDANCE IN ADULTS NONCREDIT
EDUCATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE JUST TO
DISSENT IS BASED APPORTIONMENT.
ALSO IN ADDITION THE NEW STUDENT
SUCCESS FUNDING FORMULA IS
INCENTIVIZING COLLEGES TO
ELIMINATE PRE TRANSFER ENGLISH
AND MATH THE REALITY IS MANY
STUDENTS CAN'T SUCCEED IN
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH A MAP.
UNLESS THEY ALSO HAVE THE
SUPPORTS REMEDIATION THAT
WORKING NEEDS TO MOVE IT WILL
MOVE TO NON CREDIT.
IT WILL NOT MOVE TONIGHT CREDIT
HOWEVER UNLESS WE CHANGE THE
ATTENDANCE FORMULA BECAUSE MANY
DISTRICTS ARE JUST INCENTIVIZED
TO DO SO.
AND LASTLY -- WITH RESPECT TO
THE ONLINE COLLEGE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM NORTH ORANGE COUNTY WILL
SPEAK TO A JUST A MOMENT THE
ONLINE COLLEGE IS ATTEMPTING TO
REACH A PARTICULAR POPULATION TO
ACHIEVE CERTAIN ENDS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN ADULTS
NONCREDIT EDUCATION IF WE WANT
TO HAVE A BIGGER BANG FOR OUR
BUCK IN REACHING ADULT LEARNERS
THE WAY TO DO SO IS WAS THAT
DEVICE COLLEGES TO EXPAND CDC P.
NONCREDIT PROGRAMMING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER WERE
SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU IN SAN
DIEGO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VALENTINA PURTELL AND I'M THE
PROVOST OF NORTH ORANGE
CONTINUING EDUCATION I'M ALSO
THE LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR THE
BOARD OF ASSOCIATION OF
CONTINUING AND COMMUNITY
EDUCATION.
WHICH IS A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL -- MY COLLEAGUE FOCUSED IN
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE BILL I
JUST WANT TO ADD WHY THE BILL IF
PASSED WILL INCENTIVIZE COLLEGES
TO OFFER MORE DISTANCE EDUCATION.
ONLINE NONCREDIT OFFERINGS --
TRADITIONALLY NON CREDIT SERVICE
ON TRADITIONAL STUDENT
POPULATIONS AND THAT MEANS
TYPICALLY OLDER STUDENTS WAS
MANY WORK AND FAMILY PRIORITIES.
THOSE THAT SOMETIMES CAN NOT
COMMITTED TO IN PERSON STUDIES
AND NEED AN ABILITY -- TO STUDY
EITHER FROM THEIR HOME OR EVEN
WORKPLACE BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
PERCENTAGE OF ONLINE OFFERINGS
FOR NON CREDIT IS VERY LOW RIGHT
NOW IN THE STATE.
IN COMPARISON TO THAT OF CREDIT
YET WE PROVIDE COMPETENCY BASED
FLEXIBLE EDUCATION THE REASON
WHY IS BECAUSE THE ATTENDANCE
COLLECTING FORMALIZE VERY
CUMBERSOME FOR ONLINE NONCREDIT
OFFERINGS.
IT IS SENSES BASED BUT IT
REQUIRES TWO SENSES DATES SO WE
HAVE TO MEASURE ATTENDANCE AT
THE BEGINNING AND AT THE END OF
THE TERM THAT WE HAVE TO AVERAGE
IT OUT.
AND MULTIPLIED BY THE LENGTH OF
THE TERM SO -- IT'S VERY
CUMBERSOME LABOR INTENSIVE AND
FOR MANY COLLEGES IT REQUIRES
CREATION OF A PARALLEL AND
SEPARATE SYSTEM AND NOT MANY
COLLEGES HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
SO.
I WILL STOP RIGHT HERE -- WE'RE
JUST VERY EXCITED -- TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
RIGHT WING IN THE MILITARY IS.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH ANNOUNCEMENT
ON BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOT HILLS THE
ANZA PERALTA AND SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
DR WEBBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
I JUST A COMMENT -- WITNESS THE
FIRST WITNESS -- REFERENCE THE
WAY K. TWELVE TAKES ATTENDANCE
AND USUALLY YES K. TWELVE
TEACHERS TAKE ATTENDANCE ONCE A
DAY -- EASY.
BUT SUMMER SCHOOL SUMMER SCHOOL.
WITH POSITIVE.
ATTENDANCE FOUR TIMES A DAY. FOR
THIRTY SIX STUDENTS BY HAND ON A
SCANNED SHE PROBABLY NOT THE
BEST WAY USE OF INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME WE'RE TEACHERS TIME THIS
SEEMS LIKE A SIMILAR -- FIX
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
SO.
MOVED BY MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SECOND BY MISTER GLORIA MEMSIC
INTERVIEW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE
GONZALEZ?
GONZALEZ I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBBER HI. EIGHT ZERO BILL IS
OUT.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
CARLOS WITH.
WHOM THE ROOM HAS OF THE OKAY
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
MISTER BLOOM ITM FOR A. B.
EIGHT TO NINE AND SAY WHEN THE
STRUCTURE.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB EIGHT TO NINE PERMITS THE C.
S. USED TO AWARD DOCTORATE
DEGREES IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
TO COMPLY.
WITH THE CHANGING PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS AND ENSURE THAT.
ENSURE THE CONTINUATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS -- TEASE WORK WITH
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES AND
CONDITIONS TO ENHANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO PERFORM DAILY
ACTIVITIES -- TEAS LIKE MY
WIFE'S SUPPORT CHILDREN WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES PEOPLE
RECOVERING FROM INJURIES AND
OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCING
COGNITIVE OR PHYSICAL CHANGES.
AND WHILE -- TEES OFF FOR
NECESSARY SUPPORT FOR MANY TO
HAVE A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA RANKS
FORTY FOURTH IN THE NATION IN
ACCESS TO OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS WERE ALSO HOME TO
ONLY 8% OF TEAS WHILE HAVING 12%
OF THE US POPULATION.
AND SO AS WITH MANY HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS
A CLEAR SHORTAGE OF TEASE.
NOW THE ACCREDITATION COUNCIL --
FOR TEASE RECENTLY TOOK STEPS TO
SHIFT THEIR CERTIFICATION ENTRY
FROM A MASTER'S DEGREE TO A
DOCTOR DOCTORATE LEVEL DEGREE.
AND WITHOUT THE AUTHORITY TO
TRANSITION OUR PROGRAMS TO
DOCTOR AT LEVEL PROGRAMS THE
CURRENT -- T. PROGRAMS AT SAN
JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AND CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS WOULD NO
LONGER MEET ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS AND WOULD BE FORCED TO
SHUT DOWN.
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
UNDER THEIR SERVICE LEARNING
MODELS TO CS YOU PROGRAMS
PARTNER WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY
CENTERS AND REHABILITATION
CLINICS TO PROVIDE FREE AND LOW
COST SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY
WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE THOSE.
SERVICES WITH THE PROJECTED
GROWTH IN EMPLOYMENT BY 24% OUR
ABILITY TO OFFER THESE PUBLIC
PROGRAMS WOULD GREATLY IMPACT
THE SUPPLY OF HIGHLY SOUGHT
AFTER.
HEALTH CARE SPECIALISTS TO SPEAK
MORE ON THE NEED FOR THE BILL
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE --
WITH ME THE INTERIM DEAN OF THE
COLLEGE OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SCIENCE.
AT SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE CS YOU SYSTEMS INTERIM
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR OF
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT I HOPE I GOT THAT
RIGHT.
HI MAGGIE WAY AND WITH THE CSU
SYSTEM OF MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
AUDIENCE HAS THE MUCH FANCIER IN
LONGER TITLE.
I HAPPY TO BE HERE VERY EXCITED
I THIS IS ONE OF TWO SPONSORED
BILLS PIRACY AS YOU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
HI MY NAME IS MAGGIE WHY I'M A
LET'S LEAVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
SYSTEM HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE AUDIENCE.
AT WILL NOW BE TURNING IT OVER
TO DR PAM RICHARDSON TO MY LEFT
WILL BE PROVIDING HER
PERSPECTIVE AS AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST FORMER FACULTY MEMBER
NOW PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR AT
TENNESSEE STATE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME'S PAMELA PAMELA
RICHARDSON AND I MEAN -- DEAN OF
THE COLLEGE OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SCIENCES IT'S HANDS IT STATE
UNIVERSITY AND ALSO AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
I'VE BEEN ON THE FACULTY AND
ADMINISTRATION IT SENDS A STATE
FOR OVER TWENTY ONE YEARS
INVOLVED WITH THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY PROGRAM.
AS REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS A CS YOU HAS THE ONLY
PUBLIC PATH TO A CAREER IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY IN THE
STATE.
AND BETWEEN OUR TWO PROGRAMS AT
SAN JOSE AND DOMINGUEZ HILLS WE
CURRENTLY GRADUATE 30% OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST EDUCATED
IN CALIFORNIA.
NATIONALLY ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS ARE INCREASING AND THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY PROFESSION
IS CHANGING.
CONSEQUENTLY SEVENTY SIX OF THE
NINETY SIX TOTAL OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING TO A
DOCTORATE DEGREE IN PREPARATION
FOR THE PROFESSIONAL DEMAND. FOR
DOCTORAL LEVEL EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA ALL OF THE PRIVATE
PROGRAMS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
OR IF ALREADY TRANSITION TO A
DOCTORATE LEVEL EDUCATION AS
WELL.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS NEED A
PUBLIC OPTION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY DOCTORAL PROGRAMS.
I CAN SPEAK FOR US AND AS A
STATE STUDENTS WHO ARE VERY
SOCIALLY CONSCIOUS WHO ARE VERY
CONNECTED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH CARE
ACCESS TO PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THEY DESERVE TO HAVE A DOCTOR
LEVEL EDUCATION THAT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BE LEADERS IN CHANGING
HEALTH CARE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
THE AUTHORITY WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS WITH
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY OPTIONS TO
ADVANCE OUR OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
EDUCATION AND TRAINING SO THEY
DO NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN.
ONLY PRIVATE SCHOOLS OR OUT OF
STATE OPTIONS THE COST OF
TUITION AT CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE
MASTER'S PROGRAMS IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
RANGES FROM EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND AT C. S. U. THE TOTAL
COST OF TUITION FOR TWO AND A
HALF YEAR.
MASTER'S PROGRAMS IS ROUGHLY.
NINETEEN THOUSAND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE DOCTOR DEGREE WOULD
CONTINUE TO BRING SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS TO OUR STUDENTS.
WE'RE PROUD THAT OUR GRADUATION
RATES EXCEED 95% AND OUR
GRADUATES HAVE A 97% PASS RATE
ON NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
EXAMINATION WHICH ALIGNS WITH
THE SUCCESS RATES OF THE STATE'S
PRIVATE PROGRAMS.
ARE PROGRAMS PREPARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE READY TO
JUMP INTO THE WORK FORCE WITH
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE FROM THERE
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND HOURS.
OF FIELD WORK IN HOSPITALS
SCHOOLS ON CAMPUS CLINICS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WHERE
THEY PROVIDE SERVICES TO ENABLE
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES INCOMES AND
ABILITY LEVELS. TO LIVE SAFE
PRODUCTIVE AND HEALTHY LIVES.
THE DOCTOR A LITTLE PROGRAM WITH
BILL ON THE GREAT SUCCESS OF OUR
MASTERS LEVEL PROGRAMS IN THE
VITAL COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED OVER
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AT SAN JOSE
STATE AND TWENTY YEARS AT
DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
THIS IS WHY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT KAISER PERMANENTE HEY
THE CENTER FOR ELDERS
INDEPENDENCE IN MANY OTHER
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THEY AND I KNOW THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE HARD WORKING HIGHLY
SKILLED AND EAGER TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WE'RE VERY PROUD OFFERING
AFFORDABLE PUBLIC PATH. TO
CAREER IN THIS IMPORTANT HEALTH
CARE FIELD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN OFFICIALS CROWN CHERUB
PROFESSOR AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST FOR FORTY YEARS AND
I'M IN SUPPORT?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
SCENE.
NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- YES SECOND.
YEAH BUT IT'S YOUR CHOICE.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
ARE.
ADVANCED -- US -- THIRTY INTO
PROFESSION WOULD BE A GOOD THING
BUT THE I'M JUST CARRIERS SO.
SINCE YOU DO HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN THEM MY MOST CASES A
DOCTORATE DEGREE SOME MORE
ACADEMIC RESEARCH AND TEACHING --
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF FOR THIS --
DOCTORATE DEGREE IS -- OF VANS
TO SKIERS SO OR TO PRODUCE SO
ACADEMIC -- OF FUTURE -- FOR
FACULTY MEMBERS.
WHAT A DEAL A TWO MONTH THE
PURPOSE OF WHAT NEED FOR THIS
DOCTOR DEGREES OF NO THAT'S NOT
FUN QUESTION IT'S ACTUALLY
CLINICAL DOCTORATE SO IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN A PHD WHICH IS A
RESEARCH DOCTORATE?
IT'S A CLINICAL DOCTOR DEGREES
IN FIELDS LIKE NURSING PHYSICAL
THERAPY AUDIOLOGY ARE PREPARING
PRACTITIONERS TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE -- AT AT
HIGHER LEVELS LEADERSHIP --
MANAGEMENT SKILLS SO IT'S IT'S
WHAT'S CALLED AN APPLIED DEGREE
OR CLINICAL DEGREE SO THE FOCUS
IS MORE ON ADVANCED CLINICAL
SKILLS IN CLINICAL APPLICATION
RATHER THAN SIMPLY CONDUCTING
RESEARCH PER SE.
SO SO A KARNATAK OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST A WITH A MASTER'S
DEGREE AT THEY ARE THE PEOPLE IN
THE FRONT AND I AND INTERACTING
WITH THE CUSTOMERS AND THE WITH
THE ADVANCES DEGREE THERE WILL
BE CONTINUING IN THE CLINICAL
SETTING.
YES CORRECT I SEE AND THEN THEY
WOULD BE MORE OF INTO POSITION.
ON TO TEACH MAYBE PART OF SO IN
COMING.
UP OR THE RESIDENT SAYS SOURCE
SPEAKER IN THE BEGINNING CAREER
IS THAT THE PROPOSED.
AT YES THAT'S CORRECT THEY COULD
ALL THE WORDS I IF I IF I GET A
TREATMENT THE FROM DR.
IN NOW OR TIA -- LIKE AT THE
DIFFERENT IN BETTER TREATMENT
THAN -- THE ONE WITH THE MASSES
TO WE NOT NECESSARILY I MEAN IT
WITH THE THAT THAT THE PRACTICE
STANDARDS WOULD BE THE SAME
WHETHER YOU'RE PREPARED TO SING
AT THE MASTERS A DOCTORAL DEGREE
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT.
THE CLINICAL PRACTICE STANDARDS
IT PROVIDES HIGHER LEVELS OF
SORT OF ANALYSIS AND USE OF
RESEARCH DATA AND ALSO -- KIND
OF LEADERSHIP ABILITIES
MANAGEMENT TO TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
TAKE MORE LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
IN HEALTHCARE.
NO ONE OFFICE OF ADVANTAGE OF
FOR T. HOW WITH THAT HER DOCTOR
DEGREE YOU WOULD BE -- LIKE A
HOSPITAL SETTING AND THEY CAME
IN AND THEY CAN BE A PREFERRED
THAT SAID DR.
IS A MINNESOTA AND HE IS SO OKAY
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE A
THANK YOU AND JUST IN ADDITION.
THANK YOU NEED OUT THERE FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD.
AS DOCTOR CHOI AND MY COLLEAGUES
MAY REMEMBER I HAD FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE -- RECENTLY IN AND I
KNOW PERFECTLY WELL THE
DIFFERENCE NOW BETWEEN --
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST AND A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST BECAUSE I GOT
TO ENJOY BOTH.
AND AND WHEN A SAY WHAT
EXCELLENT OF WORK HI I RECEIVED --
BOTH AT UC IRVINE FROM
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND ALSO AT
LAST YEAR UNIVERSITY AGAIN BY
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS.
AND PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND AND
WHILE I WAS THERE -- THEY THEY
SHARED WITH ME WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE HIGH COST AS MUCH AS I
LIKE OUR PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
THE HIGH COST OF THE EDUCATION
FOR THEM.
AT THE PRIVATE INSTITUTION THAT
WE SHARE -- AND HOW MUCH THEY
APPRECIATE HAVING AN ALTERNATIVE --
AT THE CSU SO THANK YOU --
MISTER BLOOM FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR THAT A MOTION BY MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SECOND BY
MISTER GABRIEL AND MADAM
SECRETARY.
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHILE.
I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I LOW
[inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
WEBBER II. NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
GO AHEAD AND DO THE CONSENT
ITEMS BUT PLEASE COME TO THE
TABLE.
SO MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
FOR CONSENT CONSENT ITEM.
THE MOTION YES [inaudible]
PLEASE.
MOTION BY MISTER GLORIA SECONDLY
MISERABLY.
MOST OF THE WORLD.
TINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
I A RUMBLE GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I'D BEEN SOLID.
DOLLARS HI LO PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I NINE ZERO CONSENT IS
PASSED AND WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE ARE
NOW AN ITEM SIXTEEN A B..
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE AND AGAIN
THIS -- ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE
TO PARTNER -- ONCE AGAIN WITH --
ASSEMBLYMEN CORK FOR THE THIRD
STRAIGHT YEAR ON A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND THAT'S A
FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
ONE CALLS UPON CALIFORNIA'S
UNIVERSITIES TO RENEW THEIR
COMMITMENT TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AS A FOUNDATIONAL CAMPUS VALUE.
IN A TWENTY SIXTEEN A TORY ON
THE BOSTON GLOBE UC PRESIDENT
APOLOGETIC DEPORT TANO WROTE
THAT THE SANCTITY OF FREE SPEECH
IN OUR COUNTRY.
IS HARDLY GUARANTEED AT LEAST
NOT ON OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
SHE CONTINUED TO SAY THAT AS A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM I WRITE TO
SHOW HOW FAR WE HAVE MOVED FROM
FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON CAMPUSES.
TO FREEDOM FROM SPEECH SPEAKERS
ARE DISINVITED SHE WROTE FACULTY
ARE VILIFIED AND ADMINISTRATORS
LIKE ME ARE CONSTANTLY ASKED TO
INTERVENE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
UNIVERSITY TO MAKE AND
DISSEMINATE A FREE SPEECH
STATEMENT THAT AFFIRMS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AT THE UNIVERSITY'S
COMMITMENT TO PROMOTING IT.
A B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE APPLIES
TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
COMPLY IT BUILDS UPON A C. R.
TWENTY ONE FROM -- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH I PRESENTED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SOME WOMEN
CORK THAT RESOLUTION CALLED UPON
CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITIES TO
ADOPT FREE SPEECH STATEMENTS AND
PATHOS IT PASSED BOTH HOUSES OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
WITH UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
TODAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO START ONCE AGAIN
LEADING THE NATION AND PUTTING
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AT THE CENTER
OF UNIVERSITY LIFE.
I WANNA THANK ASSEMBLING KIRK
FOR JOINING ME IN THIS EFFORT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- SELLING WHEN KYLIE IS
SET AT ALL IN THE HOURS LATE SO
I'LL JUST ASK YOU IF YOU ARRIVE
VOTE.
AND THEN ALSO JOINING ME TODAY
IS US OKAY TERRA COBB WHO IS
WITH THE SLAVIC AMERICAN CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE YES GOOD AFTERNOON
YOUR MEMBERS -- AND HONORABLE
CHEER -- I AM SIR GAUGE ARABIC
OFF OF THE SLAVIC AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HE CAME HERE
IN IN THIS COUNTRY AS A
IMMIGRANT -- TWENTY THREE YEARS
AGO.
AND GREW UP IN SOVIET UNION LOOK
DOWN THE SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
THERE WERE FREEDOM OF SPEECH WAS
NOT ENCOURAGED MORE PROTECTED.
AND WHEN I CAME HERE I ENJOY A
GREAT BENEFIT THEM -- YOU KNOW
OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH OBTAINING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
COLOSSUS IN THIS COUNTRY MY
DAUGHTER IS CURRENCY AND THAT C.
AS YOU.
AND I WOULD LIKE HER AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CAMPUS A
COMMITTED TO ENJOY -- AND BE
PROTECTIVE THAN THAT AND THE
RIGHT OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH THANK
YOU I'M NOT I'M RESPECTFUL
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I MAKE A MOTION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND ALSO IT.
BOBBY TAYLOR WHO ACTUALLY WILL --
WENT TO BERKELEY DURING THE
CAMPUS FREE SPEECH MOVEMENT IN --
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
FIELD SETTING COMPANY.
STRONGLY FAVORING THIS BILL THE
THE THE FREE MARKETPLACE OF
IDEAS SHOULD BE TRULY UNFETTERED.
HELLO -- IT'S MY FIRST TIME HERE
SO IF I'M NOT DOING THIS
CORRECTLY SO PLEASE FORGIVE ME
SO AT AT I SUPPORT THE BILL --
AS AN INDIVIDUAL -- BECAUSE I'M
A MOM AND I HAVE CHILDREN WHO
ARE ABOUT O ENTER COLLEGES.
AND I'M A TAIWANESE AMERICAN.
I URGE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH BECAUSE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO SAY THAT WERE TAIWANESE.
THIS COULD HAPPEN IN COLLEGE AND
THAT MY KIDS AS YOU KNOW WHERE
TONY IS AMERICAN.
BY THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
AMERICAN HERE -- YOU KNOW AND
ALSO I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
OFFENDING ANYONE.
I PROBABLY SAY I WANT AMERICA TO
BE GREAT AND I WANT CALIFORNIA
TO BE GREAT I HOPE I'M NOT
OFFENDING YOU.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
ANY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY TWEETERS.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS LED AN A I HAVE A QUESTION --
I BELIEVE THIS MOVES TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ACT.
IN THAT MOVEMENT I'D LIKE A YOU
I I'M NOT GOING TO OFFER IT AS A
CONDITION OF OF THE MOTION BUT
I'D LIKE TO KNOW MISTER KYLIE IF
YOU WOULD ADD A PROVISION TO
ENSURE.
THAT OUR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
KNOW THAT THEY ALSO HAVE A RIGHT
TO FREE SPEECH WITHOUT
RETALIATION OF ANYONE CALLING
IMMIGRATION SERVICES ARE I
NASSER -- KIND OF ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT I I'D LIKE THAT
PLACED IN THE BILL SO THAT WE
INSURE THAT OUR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO OFTEN TAKE.
REALLY BRAVE STANCES ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES CAN DO SO WITHOUT FEAR
OF RETALIATION ARE YOU WILLING
TO ADD THAT IN YOUR BILLS AT
MOST THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
MY BILL THIS IS -- AND IT'S ALL
RIGHT I'M SORRY I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- LONGER
THAN A YEAR OKAY -- JUST SO I
CAN CLEAR FIND THIS WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING IS IS FOR THEM.
TO WRITE A DOCUMENT MAKE A
STATEMENT PUBLIC I MEAN WHAT ARE
THEY TO DO I'D MOST CAMPUSES
HAVE SOME POLICY SOMEWHERE
WRITTEN.
ON FREE FOURTH ONE FREE SPEECH
SO.
WHAT ARE YOU ASKING OF THEM TO
DO THIS DIFFERENT YES WE HAVE ON
A COUPLE EXAMPLES THAT ARE CITED
IN THE RESOLUTION THAT WE ALL
PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
ARE ALSO -- PRINTED IN FULL AS
PART OF THIS BILL -- ONE IS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO THEY
PUT OUT A A FREE SPEECH
STATEMENT -- THAT -- WAS THE
PRODUCT OF YET A LOT OF WORK ON
THE PART OF CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLARS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS --
THEY JUST SETS FORTH THE
IMPORTANCE OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH
ON THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS AND THE
ROLE OF THE UNIVERSITY AND BEING
PROMOTING A DIVERSE -- YOU KNOW
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS AND THEN WE
ALSO INCLUDE A SIMILAR STATEMENT
PUT OUT BY THE CHANCELLOR OF THE
UC IRVINE WHO'S ACTUALLY HIMSELF
WORK WITH US -- ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND THAT YOU KNOW
YOU SEE BERKELEY HAS ALSO IN --
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS ADOPTED A
SIMILAR STATEMENT SO -- WE USE
THOSE AS MODELS ALTHOUGH YOU
KNOW THERE FOR UNIVERSITIES ARE
FREE TO CRAFT THEM -- AS THEY
SEE FIT AND THIS WILL BE A
MANDATE FOR EVERY CAMPUS TO
DEVELOP A POLICY.
RATHER THAN ACCEPTING THE U.
C.'S POLICY OR THE C. ISSUES
POLICY.
IT'S ONE TO WRITE A DIFFERENT
POLICY OR JUST SIMPLY ACCEPT THE
UNIVERSITY'S POLICIES WHAT IT
WHAT ARE THEY DOING IS IT.
EVERY CAMPUS RIGHT THE POLICY OR
THE C. IF YOU WRITE A POLICY FOR
ALL FOR THE SYSTEM YEAH SO EVERY
CAMPUS COULD HAVE ITS OWN --
ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY YOU KNOW YOU
COULD HAVE -- THE THE SAME
STATEMENT USED MULTIPLE CAMPUSES.
SO BASICALLY WE JUST REQUIRING
THEM TO DO A STATEMENT.
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY FOR EACH
CAMPUS AND AND WE DID THAT
BEFORE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE DID A
RESOLUTION -- THAT ENCOURAGED
CAMPUSES DEDUCE ON SOME HAVE IN
FACT -- DONE JUST THAT AS I
MENTIONED UC BERKELEY THE OTHER
ONES RESOLUTION NOW WE ACTUALLY
MOVED TO WRITE THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH STATEMENT THAT'S RIGHT
AND THIS BILL ACTUALLY I PASSED --
IN A SIMILAR -- SIMILAR BILL
LAST YEAR THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY OKAY AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENED TO IT -- APPROPRIATIONS
OKAY -- AND AND YOU HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH WAS GONZALEZ'S
REQUESTED.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND I'M I WAS IN FAVOR
OF THIS UNTIL ALL THAT STARTED
BUT SEEM TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH
WOULD WOULD MAKE SCULLY ONE OF
THE THINGS WE WOULD TRY TO
GUARANTEE IS THAT THOSE WHO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES WOULD NOT.
SUFFER ANY RETALIATION AS A
RESULT OF WHAT THEY EXPRESS I
MEAN.
THAT'S GENERALLY THE CONCEPT OF
FREEDOM OF SPEECH OTHERWISE IT'S
NOT FREE IS IS THERE.
THE COURT I I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT ALL RIGHT THE CONTROVERSY IS
SO I'M NOT I'M NOT SURE --
EXACTLY WHAT MS GONZALEZ WAS
ASKING FOR BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
SAY.
RETALIATION BY WHO OR RIGHT NOW
IF YOU'RE ON THE CAMPUS I
BELIEVE YOU'RE PROTECTED.
WITH THE DC MINISTRATION ALLOWED
WHO WHO DO YOU WANT TO PROTECT.
THAT'S THE QUESTION FOR ME I
WANT TO PROTECT UNDOCUMENTED
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHO WE
INVITE ONTO OUR CAMPUSES TO FEEL
THAT THEY ALSO HAVE THE THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS.
IS PUT OUT THERE -- I I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S CONTROVERSIAL
DON'T WE ALREADY HAVE LAWS THAT
AFFECT WHETHER OR NOT IT'S A
UNIVERSITY ADMINISTRATION.
DON'T THEY HAVE TO RESPECT THE
RIGHTS FOR OF THE I I KNOW IT'S
AT LEAST POLICY.
THAT THEY RESPECT THAT SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO YOUR WE
ALREADY HAVE A WORRIED ABOUT WE
ALREADY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS WELL WHAT I
WANT TO ENSURE IS THAT THESE
STUDENTS.
WHO -- WHO MIGHT FEEL
INTIMIDATED OTHERWISE IT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN AT THE KIND OF
GROUPS WHO ARE PRESSING FOR THIS?
NEW STEP THAT THAT IT IS ALREADY
RESTATING LAW THAT THEY ALSO
FEEL PROTECTED BECAUSE I I WOULD.
I BE CONCERNED THAT THEY GIVE IN
THE GENESIS OF OF THIS NEW
PROFOUND MOVEMENT THAT WE HAVE --
SOME STUDENTS WHO DO NOT FEEL
WELCOME ON CAMPUS AND WON'T KNOW
THAT THIS IS SPECIFICALLY ALSO
OUTLINED FOR THEM BUT SO ARE YOU
ASKING THAT THERE BE A STATEMENT
LIKE THIS.
INCLUDED IN WHAT WE RE CREST THE
UNIVERSITIES TO DO YES THAT THE
OKAY SO THAT'S WHAT YOUR
INFORMATION -- A SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AT THIS ALSO APPLIES TO
THEM AND THAT THEY'LL BE FREE OF
RETALIATION RESTATING THE LAW AS
WE'RE DOING HERE RIGHT SO THAT
WE CAN INFORM ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE AND
DOCUMENT THAT THEY'RE WELCOME ON
CAMPUS IN THE WELCOME.
TO EXPRESS THEIR FREEDOM WELL
I'LL TALK TO MY JOIN AUTHOR
ABOUT IT AFTERWARDS.
GAVE UP -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I I HAVE TO SAY I
WAS INCLINED TO SUPPORT THIS --
SORT OF AS A NO BRAINER BECAUSE
I'M A BIG FIRST MMA GUY BUT NOW
I'M I'M START TO QUESTION THAT.
AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS MISTER
KELLY WHAT'S YOUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE APPLICATION OF THE IRST
AMENDMENT. TO NON CITIZENS
INCLUDING THE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THAT -- MRS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER MENTIONED.
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT THIS IS ABOUT -- MODELING
UNIVERSITIES TO ADOPT FREE
SPEECH STATEMENTS AFTER THE
UNIVERSITY CHICAGO UC IRVINE --
AND EXPRESSING THE IMPORTANCE OF
FREE SPEECH ON CAMPUS.
I AGAIN I'LL JUST ASK MY
QUESTION AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S
DIRECTLY SQUARELY ON POINT WHICH
IS WHAT YOUR INTERESTS
UNDERSTAND OF THE APPLICATION OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT. TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ON CAMPUS
I HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT.
AND MR GABRIEL I'M GOING TO
INTERJECT HERE JUST TO GIVE SOME
BACKGROUND AND HISTORY OF HOW WE
WE GOT HERE.
AND WHY MR KYLIE'S BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- AS GENTLEMEN
STATED.
YOU KNOW I I I WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT -- REMIND PEOPLE IN THE
SEVENTIES WHERE WE VERY MUCH
VALUE OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
AND IT WAS IN THE LATE SIXTIES
RIGHT IN THE LATE SIXTIES AT AT
BERKELEY WHERE MY AUDIO SAVI ON
THE FREE SPEECH MOVEMENT BEGAN.
AND AND I AM.
PROUD TO SAY THAT MY YOU SAW THE
CAME TO MY CAMPUS UC RIVERSIDE
SOMETIME BEFORE I GOT THERE BUT
HE WAS THERE.
AND THEN I GO BACK TO BERKELEY
AND I STAND IN THE PLACE WHERE
MY IDEAS OBVIO BEGAN THE FREE
SPEECH MOVEMENT AND THAT'S THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ALL BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH --
ESPECIALLY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
HOWEVER -- AND WHY WE ARE HERE
IS BECAUSE IT HAS.
AS I THINK THE AUTHOR.
INDICATED YOU KNOW COME UP AGAIN
BY STUDENTS AND INVITING THIS
INVITING SECURITY AND SO IT IT I
THINK WE HAD TWO BILLS LAST YEAR.
ON FREE SPEECH AND AND I VERY
MUCH PREFERRED THIS WENT TO THE
ALTERNATIVE.
A BILL THAT WAS OFFERED AND SO
WE SUPPOTED THIS BILL -- I I
THINK IT IS.
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL --
IT ENJOYS A SUPPORT POSITION OF
A PASS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR.
I I I I AS THE CHAIR THINK IT
SHOULD A PASS OUT OF COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR AND I JUST HEARD --
OUR COLLEAGUE MR QUIRK OFFERED
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
I AM.
MIGHT HOPE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
I I APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I THINK
MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT -- THE
PURPOSE IS THE FIRST MAN OR
PROTECT PROTECT ALL SPEECH AND
IT'S ESPECIALLY SPEECH THAT'S ON
POPULAR OR FROM PEOPLE THAT THE
MAJORITY MAY NOT WANT TO HEAR
FROM IT SO.
I I THINK THE INTENTION -- I'M
GONNA SURMISE HEAR FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE IS THAT SOMETIMES
CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS ONLINE
LIBERAL CAMPUSES MIGHT NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE EXPRESSING THEIR
OPINION.
AND I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT
THEY SHOULD BE COMFORTABLE BUT
AT THE SAME TIME I THINK THAT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ALSO HAVE
TO FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE EXPRESSING
THEIR OPINIONS IT WITHOUT FEAR
OF REPRISAL AND IT CAN'T JUST BE.
FREE SPEECH FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
WE AGREE WITH THAT HAS TO BE
FREE SPEECH FOR ALL AND SO I'M
VERY SURPRISED ESPECIALLY GIVEN.
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS THAT IT SQUARELY
APPLIES TO NON CITIZENS THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MUCH DISPUTE
ABOUT THAT.
IN IN THE CASE LAW AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE THAT THERE SOME HESITANCY
HERE ABOUT -- YOU KNOW UP SAYING
THAT WE'RE GONNA SUPPORT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WHEN IT APPLIES
TO UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS.
THAT GIVES ME PAUSE BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE WHAT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS MEANT TO PROTECT
AGAINST WHICH IS THE GOVERNMENT.
PICKING SPEECH THAT IT AGREES
WITH AND NOT BEING WILLING TO
SUPPORT SPEECH THAT HE DISAGREES
WITH SO -- I I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT IT HAS A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION THAT THAT WEIGHS
VERY HEAVILY FOR ME AND THINKING
ABOUT THIS BILL BUT WE HAVE TO
BE CLEAR WHEN WE'RE DOING THIS.
THAT FREE SPEECH MEANS FREE
SPEECH FOR EVERYBODY INCLUDING
ARE UNDOCUMENTED I I I KNOW
WHERE DISAGREE WITH EITHER SIDE.
WITH EITHER THE AUTHOR OR
ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID HERE
AS A MATTER OF FACT.
AND I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY AND I'M
SITTING HERE WITH.
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT ATTORNEYS.
JUST A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I
DON'T THINK WE CAN.
WE I DON'T THINK WE CAN ADD OR
TAKE AWAY TO THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
I I I THINK FREE SPEECH AS AN
AMENDMENT AT AS GUARANTEED IN
THE CONSTITUTION IS JUST THAT
AND IT IS [inaudible]
CONSTITUTIONALLY GUARANTEED AND
AS I DO REMEMBER AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER THAT -- FREEDOM
OF SPEECH DOESN'T STOP AT THE
CLASSROOM DOOR.
EVEN AS IT APPLIES. TO HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AND I AGREE ON ALL THE NEWS ON
ALL THE NEWS BUT I I'M JUST
SAYING THAT SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE HAVING I
THINK.
IS A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW OF THIS BILL THAT'S
BEING PRESENTED HERE I DON'T I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DISAGREEMENT.
BY MR QUIRK OR MR KYLIE THAT
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS THAT
FREEDOM OF SPEECH -- IS FOR ALL.
AND WE WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
QUITE A BIT IN THIS COMMITTEE
YOU KNOW -- YOUR REGARDLESS OF
POINT OF VIEW YOUR REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS I I I DON'T
DISAGREE -- I'M JUST SAYING THAT
SOME OF THIS DISCUSSION MIGHT BE
BETTER HAD.
OUTSIDE THIS COMMITTEE AFTER --
WE WE DEAL WITH THIS BILL AS IT
IS NOW IN THIS COMMITTEE.
SO WHAT DID WE HAVE A MOTION.
I THINK THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND YES WELL OKAY SO WE DID
HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION WAS MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
IF WE HAD TO MOVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR CHOI.
SECOND BY [inaudible]
MISTER KYLIE.
OF MADAM CHAIR IF YOU'D CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHILE.
JOY I GLORIA.
YOU'RE NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING GABRIEL.
GABRIEL NOT VOTING -- WHEN --
WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I GONZALEZ.
IN DALLAS NOT VOTING LOW.
LOW NOT VOTING PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBBER NOT VOTING. FOUR ZERO WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR APPS.
BELIEVE I'M NEXT [inaudible]
YEAH -- THAT [inaudible]
THE YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I RESENT.
AV.
EIGHT THIRTEEN FORTY SIX ABC
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WILL ALLOW
THE TERMS OF FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
CLOSURES AND MISS REPRESENTATION
TO RECOVER FUNDS.
SPAT WHILE ATTENDING SCHOOL.
WITH ME TODAY.
IS NO ZIMMER A LAWYER FROM
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATE.
AND JENNY MORRIS A FORMER
STUDENT.
IMPACTED BY FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
MISS REPRESENTATION.
AT A MEETING OF OUR YEAH GO
AHEAD.
I JUST LANDED IN IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I REMIND MY PRESENTERS
THAT EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES YOUR
QUICK -- JUST.
A QUICK COMMENT AND I MAY HAVE
TO THE GENIE STATEMENT FOR HER
BECAUSE SHE SEEMS TO HAVE LOST
HER VOICE WHICH IS GOING TO GET --
SO MY NAME IS NO WASN'T AROUND
THE MANAGING ATTORNEY FOR HAS.
A GREAT ADVOCATE THERE IS A NON
PROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION THAT FOCUSES ON
ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUES.
AFTER FIVE YEARS IN PARTICULAR
IS THAT A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
HELPING FORMER STUDENTS OF
FAILED.
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES WERE
ADVOCATING FOR A. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BECAUSE IT'S
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
RECOGNITION OF THE FAR REACHING
FINANCIAL IMPACT.
THAT FAILED FOR PROFITS HAVE ON
THEIR STUDENTS.
WE'VE SPOKEN WITH HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA TO OUR FORMER
STUDENTS OF FAILED AND FAILING
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES LIKE HEALD.
EVEREST AND WHY ATTACK THESE ARE
THE CORINTHIAN COLLEGES I. T. T.
BROOKS THE ART INSTITUTE AND
MARINELLA.
DID YOUR ROLE DURING THE
SCHOOL'S COLLAPSE OR AT A TIME
WHEN THE SCHOOLS PROGRAMS WERE
SO DEGRADED THAT THEY WERE
DEVOID OF EDUCATIONAL VALUE.
THE WAY THE COST OF THE MISSION
AND THE RESULTING DATA IS ONE
FINANCIAL HARM.
THAT THE STUDENTS THERE BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT THE ONLY CAR
FORMER STUDENTS TELL US THEY
WERE PRESSURED TO SIGN UP FOR
CLASSES IMMEDIATELY.
AND ALSO THE TRAVELER MOVED
HIGHER PRICE COMMUNITIES TO
ATTEND CLASSES AND INEFFECTIVE
INTERNSHIPS.
THE STUDENTS HAD TO CUT DOWN
HOURS ON WORK OR SOMETIMES STOP
ENTIRELY LOSING INCOME IN ACCESS
TO BENEFITS SUCH AS HEALTH CARE.
THEY SPEND DOWN FAMILY SAVINGS
ON CHILD CARE FOR CLASS TIME.
SUGGESTED SCHOOL SUPPLIES THAT
WERE EFFECTIVELY REQUIRED AND
STUDY.
THEY DID THIS BECAUSE THEIR
SCHOOLS LED THEM TO BELIEVE THAT
THE SACRIFICES WERE NECESSARY
FOR THIS SUCCESSFUL FUTURE AND
THAT OF THEIR FAMILIES.
THE FORMER FOR PROFIT STUDENTS
WERE TARGETED BY PREDATORY
SCHOOLS IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
THEIR FINANCIAL VULNERABILITY.
MOST ARE LOWER INCOME AND MANY
WERE THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES
TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
MANY HAVE WORKED HARD FOR LOW
WAGES FOR YEARS AND WERE SOLD A
FOR PROFIT EDUCATION AS A WAY TO
GET AHEAD.
OFTEN THESE ARE NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS SUPPORTING THEMSELVES
AS WELL AS CHILDREN PARENTS ARE
EXTENDED FAMILIES.
WE'RE ADVOCATING FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FUNDER STRESSED.
CAN BETTER NOT COMPLETELY BUT
BETTER REPAIR THE HARM DONE TO
THE STUDENTS AND GIVE THEM A
REALISTIC CHANCE OF RECOVERY
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
I HAVE NO VOICE [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT TODAY IF I MAKE IT STOP?
YOU CAN READ IT.
MY NAME ACTUALLY NOT MY NAME IS
JEANNIE MORRIS I WENT TO THE NOW
DEFUNCT MARINELLA SCHOOLS A
BEAUTY HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE PROGRAM
WAS TEN SHORT MONTHS NOTHING TOO
GLAMOROUS THE SCHOOL WAS A SMALL
HOLE IN THE WALL PLACE.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE
ENROLLED AT LEAST WHILE I
ATTENDED WAS EITHER ON SOME SORT
OF GOVERNMENTAL ASSISTANCE OR
HAD TO HAVE THEIR PARENTS COSIGN
FOR THEIR LOANS.
AT MARANELLO EVERYONE WITH THE
SCHOOL WAS NOT BEING TRUTHFUL
ABOUT THE FUN THEY RECEIVED ON
THEIR LOANS BUT WE COULDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT THAT SCHOOL
PREYED UPON PEOPLE OF COLOR
PEOPLE WITH LIMITED INCOME.
BECAUSE WHEN THOSE PEOPLE
WRITTEN ROLLED IN THE PROGRAM
BUT IT SURE THAT THE SCHOOL
WOULD CONTINUE TO RECEIVE.
TITLE FOR LOAN PAYOFFS THE
SCHOOL ONE AS FAR AS GENERAL
STUDENTS KNOWING THEY HAD NO
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED AND
HAD FRAUDULENT PASSING.
TEST SCORES PUT ON THE
APPLICATIONS FOR FEDERAL LOANS
JUST TO SECURE THAT LOAN A
FEDERAL LOAN.
I WAS ONE OF THE STUDENTS I
ROLLED INFORM THE WRECK STARTED
I HAD NO HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
GED THEY ASSURED ME IT WAS OKAY
JUST TAKE THIS TASK YOU'LL GET
IN.
SO DOES THE TESTING RIGHT OFF
THE BAT SOMETHING WAS OFF AS
SOON AS I'M DONE I GIVE MY TASK
IN THE PROCTOR PULLS OUT ANOTHER
TEST ALREADY GRADED AND SAYS
THAT I PASSED.
SO I STARTED BY TAKE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHICH WAS FROM ROLE
MEANT THAT I HAD TO GET A
PERSONAL LOAN FOR THE SCHOOL
CALLED THE MARINELLA ALONE WHICH
IS TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
A COVERAGE SUPPLIES AND BOOKS.
THROUGHOUT THE TWO TEN MONTHS
YOU MAKE MONTHLY PAYMENTS BACK
TO THE SCHOOL TO PAY OFF THE
LOAN EVERY STUDENT HAD TO GET A
MARYLAND MERIT ALONE.
I DEBATED BORROW FOR MY MOM FOR
RENT BECAUSE I WAS MAKING MY
MONTHLY PAYMENTS TO THE SCHOOL
MY HUSBAND COULD NOT WORK
BECAUSE HE WAS PROVIDING
CHILDCARE -- IF YOU DIDN'T MAKE
THE PAYMENTS TO THE SCHOOL YOU
WERE KICKED OUT.
THE SCHOOLS DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT
THE GRANT MONEY I RECEIVED WENT
TO ROOM AND BOARD EVEN THOUGH I
DIDN'T RECEIVE ROOM AND BOARD.
TRANSPORTATION WHICH I NEVER
RECEIVED ANY MONEY FOR AND
MISCELLANEOUS.
I DON'T LIVE ON CAMPUS THIS WILL
NEVER PAID FOR ANY GAS WHERE WAS
THE REST THAT WHAT THE
MISCELLANEOUS.
THE SCHOOL ALSO FORCED ME TO
INCREASE ONE OF MY LOANS TO MAKE
SURE I GOT MY MARINELLA LOAN
PAID OFF BEFORE I WENT TO STATE
BOARDS.
WHEN THE SCHOOL RECEIVED A CHECK
IN MY NAME THEY TRY TO MAKE ME
SIGN THE CHECK OVER TO THEM?
I'M UNSURE OF HOW MANY.
IT IS ACTUALLY DID BUT I DID NOT
I HAVE TO CASH THE CHECK WHEN
THE SCHOOL FOUND OUT THAT I CAST
IT WAS THREATENED WITH EXPULSION
OF MY LOAN WAS NOT PAID BACK IN
FULL.
THE PROGRAM'S TOTAL COST ROUGHLY
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT MINE WERE.
TWENTY TWO I WAS PROMISED A
LIFETIME JOB PLACEMENT
ASSISTANCE AND THAT WOULD MAKE I
WOULD MAKE TEN TIMES MORE MONEY
WITH MY COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
I'M REALISTIC I KNEW I WOULDN'T
BE SOME SUMER SUPER GLARING
GLAMOROUS HAIR STYLIST LIKE TAB
WITH THE COFFEE.
BUT I THOUGHT I WOULD MAKE MORE
THAN MINIMUM WAGE I'VE YET TO
FIND AN HOURLY JOB THAT PAYS
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
MY EXPERIENCE IS NOTHING UNUSUAL
TO ANYONE IS ATTENDED A FOR
PROFIT POST SECONDARY COLLEGE MY
TIME IN MARANELLO IS UNNECESSARY
DATA THAT I'VE HAD TO CARRY WITH
ME FOR YEARS.
THEY DID CHECK TREMENDOUS DAMAGE
TO ME AND MY CREDIT.
AND THE PROCESS TO GET THAT DEBT
FORGIVEN WAS JUST AS BAD.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL LAW
SUPPORT STATEMENT OF FROM THE
PUBLIC [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU.
ANGELA TERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SIX PORT.
AND SUCCESS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON IMAN **** ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SHOUTS OAKLEY IN SUPPORT.
AT OUR SENIOR COUNSEL CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BOB SHERMAN WITH THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NOT ANYMORE -- AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
OKAY OUT BACK -- TO THE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR STATEMENTS.
IF NONE THEN NOW COMES CLOSE.
SO THIS BILL IS THE FIFTH AND
LAST ONE THAT WE HEAR TODAY ON
FOR PROFITS I THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT.
OF FIVE BILLS THAT WE PASSED
TODAY [inaudible] SEVEN SEVEN
BILLS HAVING TO DO WITH FOR
PROFIT COLLEGE AND I BELIEVE
THIS IS THE LAST.
ONE I THINK THEY WERE IMPORTANT
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT WE
PASTOR TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOTH.
OKAY -- MOTION HAS BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED -- CLOAK A STATE THE
MOTION AND PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE TO
THE PROCREATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI HI JOY I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I CONSOLIDATES.
GONZALES I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I TEN ZERO ZERO IF.
ANYONE IS ABSENT OR LEAVE IT
OPEN TO ALLOW ME TO CLOSE THE
SESSION.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO IT
ADD ON'S AND FILE ORDER.
ITEM [inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY FIVE TO ONE BLOOM.
HE'S NOT HERE GABRIEL
[inaudible]
ITEM.
ONE GABRIEL I KYLIE.
KYLIE I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I'D. TEN ZERO EIGHT B.
FIVE TWENTY ONE IS OUT.
ITEM TO AB SEVEN ONE ZERO MEDINA.
HI MEDINA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I WELL I KYLIE.
NUMBER TWO SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT [inaudible]
ZERO KYLIE I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WEBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I'D. TEN ZERO AB SEVEN
TEN IS OUT.
ITEM.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN TWO ZERO
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
HIGHLY I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO II. ELEVEN ZERO AB
SEVEN TWO ZERO IS OUT.
ITEM FOR A. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT TO NINE HELLO.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D. ELEVEN ZERO A B.
EIGHT TO NINE IS OUT.
ITEM FIVE A B. TEN SEVENTY FIVE
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON ICE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TWELVE ZERO AB TEN
SEVENTY FIVE IS OUT.
ITEM SIX A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA GLORIA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I'D SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I ELEVEN ZERO MAYBE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE IS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. TWELVE THIRTY
FOUR WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
BLOOM I GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I
KYLIE?
KYLIE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I'D SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I TWELVE ZERO A B. TWELVE
THIRTY FOURS UP.
ITEM EIGHT ABC [inaudible]
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE?
KYLIE I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I'D SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I'D.
WELL ZERO A B. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
IS OUT.
ITEM NINE AB [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KYLIE [inaudible]
KYLIE NARROW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER HI. NINE ONE ABC THIRTEEN
FORTIES OUT.
ITEM TEN A. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I HIGHLY. FORTY ONE
CORRECT.
KYLIE I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I ELEVEN ZERO A B.
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE IS A ITEM
ELEVEN A. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I HIGHLY [inaudible]
KYLIE NO [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER HI. TEN ONE A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO IS A ITEM
TWELVE AB [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE BLOOM.
BLOOM I WHEN -- WHEN I?
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBBER I NINE ZERO ABC THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE IS OUT.
ITEM [inaudible]
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I LOW?
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR IS OUT.
ITEM.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE CHILE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
APRIL I WHEN -- WHEN I PATTERSON?
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I NINE ZERO ABC
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE IS OUT.
ITEM. FIFTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX BLOOM.
LOOM I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I TWELVE ZERO A B..
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX ITEM SIXTEEN
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE THE
CORRECT MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING. FIVE ZERO
EIGHT B..
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS NOT OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN KYLIE.
KYLIE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO II.
WELL ZERO AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM.
EIGHTEEN AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KYLIE
[inaudible]
HIGHLY I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
ZERO WELL. ZERO SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR IS UP YEAH.
OKAY FOR THAT KIND [inaudible]
OKAY. FORTY ONE OKAY.
LET'S SEE THE ONLY ONE IS THAT
ON THE REST HE WAS HERE FOR OKAY.
YEAH. THIRTEEN I SAY WHAT NUMBER
IS THAT ITEM NUMBER. TWELVE
TWELVE TWELVE OKAY HANG ON WHAT
IT IS.
THAT'S OKAY. FOR ALL I MISSED A
FEW.
ON ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE KYLIE NOT VOTING TO
KNOW.
OKAY HANG ON I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
LET ME DO IT IN ORDER. TO BE.
I JUST WANT TO CHECK TO MAKE
SURE I GOT MY VOTE YEAH.
WELL -- YEAH [inaudible]
IF YOU.
SURE.
IT'S FUN [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE JUST GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM
OKAY [inaudible]
AND NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FIVE TO
ONE BALLOON.
BLOOM HIGH [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PATTERSON NOW.
A ELEVEN ONE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE OUT.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SEVEN TEN BLOOM.
BLOOM I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
TWELVE ZERO EIGHTY SEVEN TEN
ITEMS.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
PATTERSON [inaudible]
LISTEN ONLINE.
WELL.
ZERO EIGHTY SEVEN TWO ZERO ITEM
FOR A. B. EIGHT TO NINE
PATTERSON [inaudible]
ARSON I'D. TWELVE ZERO EIGHT B.
EIGHT TO NINE IS -- ITEM.
SIX AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
BLOOM [inaudible]
I WELL ZERO AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE IS A I DON'T THINK SO.
EVERYONE SOME.
FIVE OKAY EVERYONE'S ON THAT.
ONE TURNING TO THE ONSTAD.
NOT FOR THE MOUNTAINS. TEN
ELEVEN NOT VOTING ON STAFF
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND TO NOT VOTING THAT.
ONE OKAY.
OKAY.
SEE CHARLIE. THIRTY SIX THREE
HAVE.
BEEN -- YOU GET CAN ASK A
SEVENTY NINE THE WE'RE JOURNEY